الانسان الحداسي هو انسان مهان
غير انه فارغ من الداخل نحن لا نعرف كل
انواع الحريه التي انتجتها التاريخ البشري
نحن نعرف فقط الحريه السياسيه التي
انتجتها الدول الغربيه لنا لانه تاريخ
الحريه الذي لا نمارس اليوم وقد مارسته
البشريه بانواع عديده قبل القرن التاسع
عشر قد مات
قتل من قبل
الحريه الغربيه هل انت تشوف انه الفتوحات
الاسلاميه كانت احتلال
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح اتذكر مقوله تقول
بان كل شيء حولنا نسميه الحياه ومن صنع
اشخاص مثلا
اذكى مننا ابدا واؤمن بهذا الفكره لكن
المشكله الان هي
عليها فتحت هذه الحلقه وبتعالجها بشكل او
باخر اي ان كل هذه الحياه ومفاهيمها هي
منتجات غربيه الحريه اللي نعرفها هي
بتعريف غربي الانسان منه ولماذا هو موجود
تعريف غربي العمل تقاعد المساواه وزي ما
يقولون عد وغلط
ضيفي لديه مشروعي ضغط هدف زاعه الخطاب
المهيمن على الدراسات الاسلاميه في الغرب
لان يعتقد ان الغرب فهمنا ونظر الينا
بعدسه استشراقيه فاتاه بالعيد يقول
درست التاريخ الاوروبي لافهم التاريخ
الاسلامي التاريخ الاسلامي كما نعرفه
اليوم ليس تاريخنا
فما هو التاريخ الاسلامي كيف نشات وتطورت
الشريعه الاسلاميه من بدايه الخلافه
الراشده مرورا بالدول الاسلاميه حتى ظهور
الدوله
الحديثه
وما ان تفتح باب الدوله الحديثه والحداثه
الا وتفتح معها ابواب واسئله فلسفيه
اخلاقيه جوهريه وهذه الاسئله والنقاشات
والنقودات هي ما يطمح اليه ضيفي ان تطرح
في اروقه الجامعات والاكاديميه للعربيه
والغربيه ضيفي هو الدكتور وائل حلاق استاذ
علوم اجتماعيه في جامعه كولومبيا
الامريكيه في قسم الدراسات للشرق الاوسط
رساله للدكتور كانت بعنوان هل انسد باب
الاجتهاد نتيجه لارق واسئله محيره ساقتلي
هذا السؤال وصارت رسالته للدكتوراه
والحلقه دسمه
ومليئه بالاسئله المحيره
والاجوبه اللي تقودي لمزيد من الاسئله
قبل ان نبدا الحلقه هذه كما هي كثير من
حلقات جان مليئه بالمواد والمراجع التي
تتعلق بمواضيع طرحها ضيف في سياق الحديث
او من معلومات مهمه من رحله البحث
والاعداد جمعناها لكم على شكل رساله
بريديه فاذا كنت مهتم رابط الاشتراك في
نشره فنجان البريديه موجود في صندوق وصف
هذه الحلقه اما الان
لنبدا شو بتتوقع يكون طوله المقابله
يعني ممكن
شو الطول المثالي
الطول المثالي هو اللي انت تكون وصلت فيه
فكرتك بشكل مثالي صدق يعني في حلقات تكون
ساعه وتكون كافيه
في حلقات الى اربع ساعات وتكون
كمان ناجحه كتير ناجحه يعني
سمعت قلت بواحد من ضيوفك انه في حلقه 3
اكثر من 3 ساعات وجابت اكم مليون صحيح
يعني فيها في حلقه ثلاث ساعات شوي
جابت يعني الان خمسين مليون ما شاء الله
عن العلاقات عن العلاقات وفي حلقه برضو
يعني هذيك ممكن تقول انها تمس الناس كثير
والسي حلقات غريبه يعني ما صرت تعرف
الارقام حقيقه
فمثلا ما اعرف ليش صارت زي كذا يعني في
حلقه مع جورج صليبه ايوه ايوه يا زميلي
فيعني نخبوويه مفترض
والحلقه وصلت الى الان سبعه مليون
ملاحظة فغريب يعني قبول الناس ما تعرف ما
تعرف مسبقا ما اعرف يعني زي كتابه الكتب
يعني تكتب الكتاب ولا تعرف الكتاب ربما
يكون عادي وربما يشتهر وكل من نفس المؤلف
والمؤلف لا يعرف يعني هي تمشي على كل
الاشياء سواء الكتب بالافلام
صحيح في نوع من الخلطه الكيماويه اللي صعب
الواحد يتنبا لكل مركباتها وكل ما زادت
رغبتك في انك تصنع ماده للانتشار كل ما
قلت اعتقد انت صنعت الماده لاجل الماده
كل اذا بدنا ناخذ استراحه ممكن وساعتها
ممكن انه
تقطع نقطه حاول تحط مساحه يكون في
المشاهد لا يعرف
في اي وقت يناسبك ممتاز لكن فيه مشكله هي
انه
اودي اعرفها منك هل تتوقع ان الناس
تعرف او تفهم مشروع وائل الحلاق لان كل ما
سالت ترى يعني طبعا
يتوقف توقف على نوع الكتاب
تحت البحث او اذا كان المشروع هو المشروع
الكلي لواء الحلال من ناحيه كتب
بتصور في اختلاف وتفاوت كبير بين التجاوب
الجمهور
الدوله المستحيله بالذات
قد خلقت ضجه كبيره
واستطيع ان اقول ان هناك نخبه معينه التي
فهمت الكتاب بشكل دقيق وممتاز
حتى حتى
بعض المسلمين في امريكا هنا
قد استطاعوا ان ان
يغوصوا في معاني الكتاب وقد فهموا هذا
الكتاب بشكل دقيق واحيانا اشعر يا ليتني
قد ندبت لهم ان يتكلموا بالنيابه عني ولكن
في احيانا اخرى طبعا كان في اساءه للكتاب
اساءه من من نوعين اساءه بنيه طيبه مجرد
انهم لم يفهموا الكتاب او انهم لم ليس لهم
الخلفيه الضروريه لفهم الكتاب وهذا شيء
طبيعي لا تلوم احد على ذلك ولكن هناك نخبه
صغيره صغيره قد هاجمت الكتاب
بنيه غير صافيه
لاجل تهديمه وتهديم مشروعه وهدم
نزهه الشخصيه التي كتبت الكتاب
الغربيين وغير العرب
لهم ردود فعل اكثر
معتدله من من بعد العرب
في العالم العربي الدوله مستحيله اثارت
ضجه للسبب وهو بسبب المعارك الفكريه التي
قامت حول الكتاب فانا لست الطرف الوحيد في
الدفاع او في تفسير الكتاب فهناك العديد
من الاشخاص الذين يدافعون عن الكتاب لانهم
يعتقدون
او يؤمنون بنظره عامه تشبه نظرتي للمشاكل
التي نواجهها اليوم ممتاز انا بحاول ما
استطعت يعني هذه الحلقه ودي انها تمس اغلب
الناس انا اعتقد انه في كثير من المفاهيم
اللي تطرحها
اللي اذا الناس فهمتها ممكن تنعكس على
حياته بالاجمال ليس بالضروره على نطاق
الدوله وانما حتى لنطاق الشخصي والفكري
لاي انسان فبنحاول ما استطعنا
فيقول يا رب فبدي بسبب ارجع الى نقطه يعني
انت قلت
انا كنت في بدايه بحثك كنت حاولت بحث
تاريخ الاوروبي لفهم تاريخ الاسلامي وتقول
صحيح ان التاريخ الاسلامي كما نعرف اليوم
ليس تاريخنا
اذا يعني ودي اعرف ايش الاشياء اللي ما
نعرفها عن تاريخنا الاسلامي
كتابه التاريخ اليوم تختلف تماما عن كتابه
التاريخ قبل اقامه
التاريخ بما نعرفه اليوم هو وليد
الممارسات الاوروبيه في القرن التاسع عشر
حتى في اوروبا ليس قبل القناه التاسع عشر
بكثير
بطبيعه الحال وكانها معادله رياضيه ليست
بحاجه
للمرهنه هو ان اذا كنا ننطلق من اي خطاب
كتب في الحاضر مين معناه بالمعنى قرن
التاسع عشر والعشرين فنحن نقرا التاريخ من
من من المعطيات ووجهات النظر ومشاعر
والتفكير
هذين القرنين اضف على ذلك حتى لو لم يكن
هناك استعمار او لم يكن هناك اي شيء اخر
حتى لو كنا فقط لنقل المسلمين نعيش من غير
تاريخ الاستعماري الذي حدث لنا في اخر 200
سنه مزبوط بدك تضيف على هذا الاستعمار
الاستعمار استعمار الاوروبي
فريد من نوعه في التجربه الانسانيه وهذا
الذي هذا الشيء قليل من الاشخاص الذين
يفهمون
فطبعا مثلا المسلمين
احتلوا بلاد كثيره الفتوح ما سمي بالفتوح
ولم تسمى بشيء في اللغه العربيه مثلا التي
يوازي كلمه كولونياليتي
او كولونيا لزم ولكن فتوح
فهذا صحيح انها فقط كلمه فتوح ولكن لها
دلائل ومفاهيم عميقه لان الفتح الاسلامي
مثلا كان من نوعيه معينه
تختلف اختلاف تام عن الفتن
الاحتلالات
والاستيطانات والاستعمارات الاوروبيه في
القرن التاسع عشر وهو بالاساس فحدثت
تقريبا جميعا في القناه التاسع عشر حتى في
لما دخلت انجلترا على الهند لم تستطع ان
تخدع الهند لارادتها لم تستطع ان تكون
الهند
بما تظن انها هي السوره الحقيقيه للحضاره
الا في منتصف الا في القرن التاسع عشر من
البدايه ولكن
بمنتصف القناه التاسع عشر حدث
انهيار الهند تماما تحت اقدام
الامبراطوريه البريطانيه هل انت تشوف ان
الفتوحات الاسلاميه كانت احتلال طبعا هي
طبعا هي لما تفتح ارض انت تحتل الارض ولكن
كلمه احتلال كلمه حديثه بالمناسبه
فتوح كلمه قديمه مثل فتوح البلدان البلدان
للبلادري والكذا فتوح تستعمل دائما في كل
المصادر الاسلاميه ولكن احتلال هذا
هناك نقطه اخرى ابو عمر لا يجب ان ننتبه
اليها دائما وانا اوجه ذلك الى هذا الحديث
للشباب ان اللغه
هي مفتاح الفهم والفهم هو مفتاح التصرف
ورؤيه الحياه فاذا لم تكن تنتبه للغه
لا ستضيع
فنحن نفكر اليوم ان ما نستعمله لكلمه مثلا
احتلال
زي كلمه اي كلمه تانيه زي كولونيا لزم او
زي
فتوح او لا
احتلال تيجي مثل ما احنا بنشوف الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ليش بنسميه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لان
الاحتلال يحل محل الفلسطينيين
وياخذ تراث ويسرق ارضهم ويدمر بيوتهم
ويطردهم هذا الاحتلال يحل محل
هذا نوع من الاحتلال هذا النوع الشنيع من
الاحتلال لانه يقصي
المواطنين الاصليين عن ارضهم مثل شو صار
في امريكا مثلا اقصوا كل
ما يسمى بالهنود الامريكيين عن ارض
وقتلوهم وشتتوهم وابادوهم صحيح يعني 90
مليون مواطن
هندي امريكي قتلوا في في الاحتلالات
الاوروبي والاحتلال الاسرائيلي يحاول ان
يمارس ما يسمى ضد الفلسطيني ولكن بشكل
مبرمج وبطيء هذا النوع من الاحتلال ولكن
هناك احتلالات اخرى تبقي المواطنين مثلا
في بريطانيا في الهند لانه لا تستطيع ان
تنفي او تقتل كل الهنود فماذا تفعل
في استراليا وفي امريكا وفي اسرائيل
يحاولون
تدمير
[موسيقى]
السكان الاصليين لانه ممكن صغار ولكن في
بريطانيا في الهند لم تستطع طبعا لانه كان
الهنود اكثر بكثير حتى من من الاوروبيين
كلهم صحيح فشو
اذا انا بقدرش اقتلك وامحيك من الارض عشان
بدي اخذ ارضك بدي اعمل زيي
لانك انت لما بتصير تفكر زيي
خلص انت صرت مني انا باخذك وبسويه في بيت
شو بدي لانه انا عندي السلطه السياسيه
وانت
الرعايه الرعايه
اصبحوا يطيعون
يتقبلون كل المبادئ
والنظرات
السياسيه والاجتماعيه والقيم الاخلاقيه
للحاكم فخلاص يصبحوا يصبحوا من من السكان
ولكن القوه والقياده والسيطره هي في ايدي
المستعمرين فمثلا حكم بريطانيا حكمت الهند
وبدك تقول 150 سنه بشكل فعال وقبلها شي
250 سنه لم تستطع كثير ولكن نجحت في الاخر
ولكن في كل
التجربه هذه 400 سنه
450 سنه لم يكن هناك هندي واحد قد جلس في
البرلمان الانجليزي في لندن صحيح
ولكن الهنود اذا حتى اليوم اذا بتلاحظ
تحكي مع الهنود
خلينا نسميهم اخواننا الهنود بغض النظر عن
ديانتهم كتير متشبعين بالحضاره والعقليه
الانجليزيه يعني منهم وصلوا في تقليد
الانجليزي لدرجه السخافه
تثير على الاقل عندي تثير بعد الضحك
وهم لا يعرفون انهم قد استعملوا هذا
الاستعمار الحديث هو عندما عندما
تبلور ذاتيه المستعمر على صوره ذاتيه
المستعمر
بس مو الان رئيس الوزراء البريطاني هذه من
من
تاثيرات التاثيرات اللاحقه بعد اللاحقه
بعد اللاحقه للاستعمار مثلا انجلترا اليوم
فيها
ملايين من الهنود
هذا الشيء اللي اللي لم يستطع الانجليز ان
يسيطروا عليه
ومنهم وبما انه هناك
هنود كثير في انجلترا الان
فترى ان بعضهم ناجحين جدا ومعهم فلوس كتير
هو يستطيع ان يبنوا ما يسمى بالقوه
السياسيه
فواحد منهم نجح ان يسير ليه لانه قد استغل
هذه
الانقسامات في الصخر
واستطاع ان يحوز على على هذا المنصب ليس
لان الانجليز يحبون الديمقراطيه
ومستعدين ان يتقبلوا كل نتائج الديمقراطيه
هذا هذا مفهوم خاطئ جدا ليش لانه
الديمقراطيه تسمح لكل شيء ما زال هو
ديمقراطي وهذه ديكتاتوريه
لانه الديمقراطيه الغربيه هي مساله الحريه
السياسيه الغربيه صحيح
وهذا موضوع اخر اذا بدك نبحثو ببعض
التفصيل لاحقا خلاص لانه لانه معناه انه
عندك انت الحريه هاي السياسيه هي حريه لها
معنى معين وهي من نوعيه معينه ليست كل
حريه هي نحن لا نعرف كل انواع الحريه التي
انتجتها التاريخ البشري نحن نعرف فقط
الحريه السياسيه التي انتجتها الدول
الغربيه لنا فمثلا اقول لك
غير غير المبدا الحريه بالنسبه
للديمقراطيه الغربيه والليبراليه اعطيني
مثال وفسر لي تفسير
كافن عن نوع اخر من الحريه انا اسال هذا
السؤال دائما لطلابي ولا واحد حتى الان
استطاع ان يجيب ليه لانه تاريخ الحريه
الذي لا نمارس اليوم وقد مارسته البشريه
بانواع عديده قبل القرن التاسع عشر قد مات
قتل من قبل
الحريه الغربيه
فنحن نعرف فقط نوع واحد من الحريه وهذا
النوع الواحد هو نوع سياسي وبالاساس
اقتصادي هو ليس ليس فقط سياسيا وهذا لما
عند انت لما بتروح بتصوت في الانتخابات
هذا مش فعل سياسي فقط هذا طبعا ولكن ليس
هو فاعل سياسي محض انما هو فعل اقتصادي
[موسيقى]
طور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
ودي ارجع لي نقطه الاحتلال والتعريفات
فكنت تقول انه يعني اللي جالس يصير مثلا
في الهند من البريطانيين انهم ما قالوا
لهم اطلعوا لكن خلوهم قالوا
نفس اللي حصل في الفتوحات
فصاروا كل الدول اللي انضمت تحت الدوله
الاسلاميه
يعني اصبحوا عربا مسلمين يعني غيروا
هويتهم
اللغه والهويه حتى الدينيه متدينه بدينا
اخر
مو نفس الشيء لا مش مش
في اختلاف كبير
اول شيء تاريخيا من قليل من الناس يعرفوا
انه حتى في القرن الرابع والخامس الهجري
كانوا المسلمون اقليه في بلادهم هل كنت
تعرف ذلك انت قبل
كانوا اقليه في بلادهم كانوا الحاكمين
وكانت امبراطوريتهم اذا ممكن لانه ما كان
في لاحظ هنا انا
قلتهم ولكن هذا استعمال خاطئ لانهم لم
يعرفوا لم يحددوا لم يعرفوا نفسهم كان
عندهم امبراطوريه هنا عندهم خلافه او
سلطنه
ولا يعني انه ما انا قلت امبراطوريه لان
انا متاثر لسه بالخطاب الحديث
اسمه اصطلاحات مختلفه ليس الا لا كل اشي
له معناه والمعنى يحدد الكميه والكشف
والكيفيه والكيفيه مهمه جدا
خلينا نبدا في اول اول حقيقه عن التاريخ
الاسلامي وهذا بدا حتى في
[موسيقى]
بدر من البدايه من من من عصر عمر بن
الخطاب رضي الله عنه
شو قال قال لما بتفتحوا بلد
خلوهم يتركوهم لحالهم
لكم دينكم ولي دين هذا شيء واضح جدا كان
يعني لم لم حتى يفكر فيه شيء طبيعي اول
شيء عقليتهم كان تشتغل هيك والقران الكريم
اصر عليه
فخلوهم يعبدوا شو بدهم اعطوا اعطوهم حريات
دينيه اليهود
والمسيحيين كانوا يقدروا يتزوجوا ويتاجروا
ويصلوا ويساوي شو بدهم تقريبا حسب
عقائدهم وديانه وديانتهم بس ايه لما تطلع
من بيتك انت في حاره في شارع مشترك للجميع
فيه يهود ومسلمين ومسيحيه والى اخره الى
اخره انت تحترم
القانون او شرع المجتمع بشكل عام وهو شرع
اسلامي فلا تستطيع ان تبيع الخمر ولا
تستطيع ان ان ولا يجب ان ان تتعامل مع
المسلمين بالفائده
[موسيقى]
والاشياء المحرمه والممنوع هو بالاساس
الخمر
واللحوم المحرمه
والخمر كان واحد من المشاكل الكبيره دائما
حتى في التاريخ الواقع ليس فقط من ناحيه
يعني مبادئ
[موسيقى]
فقه مثلا
انما كان في الحقيقه كانت هناك مشكله لانه
الخمر كان شائع حتى بين العرب
فكان السبب مشاكل كثيره فهذه مشكله ما
بدنا نتفاداها واصروا على معاقبه اي اي
شخص يقوم بهذه
[موسيقى]
الافعال الشائنه
ولكن عاشوا
علموا اهم شيء ندخل في
صميم اخر مهم هو انهم اليهود والنصارى
وغيرهم من الاقليات وفي الهند لاحقا عندما
احتل الدوله المغوليه احتلت الهند
كمان فوتوا في جياب المجتمع الاسلامي او
في جياب الامبراطوريه الاسلاميه فوته
الهندوس والبوديه والجانيه والى اخره كان
في 500 600 اقليه في الهند كلهم دخلوا تحت
الحكم الاسلامي فاصبح اصبحت
اصبح
اصبحت الشريعه التي
تطبق على اليهود والنصارى
وزردشتيين تمتد الى تقريبا الجميع الاخرين
الغير المسلمين
ولكن والنقطه الحاسمه هنا ان اليهود
والنصارى وغيرهم
ربوا اولادهم اولادهم
وانشؤوهم على القيم
الاسلاميه على القيم
المله التي هم منها فاليهود استمروا ان
يكونوا يهود والمس وليس ذلك
فالمسلمين اصروا ان يكون لكل احد دينه
انت بدك تكون يهودي ساوي شو بدك يا يهودي
ويحق لك ان واحنا انت من ذمتنا شو يعني
ذمه يعني يعني احنا مديونين الك في انه
احنا ما زال ما انت بتدفع الجزيه والى
اخره مديونين الى الك انه احنا نحميك
نحميك على شروطك الدينيه
الشروط يعني يعني شرائع الكتاب واذا كان
الكتاب يهودي او كتاب مسيحي شرائع الكتاب
هي دائما مقدسه سياسيا فاحترام احترام تام
لهذه الاقليات
لذلك اصبحت الهويه اليهوديه واليهود
والهويه المسيحيه استمرت بكونها
نفس الهويه طبعا مع التغير الازمات تتغير
اشياء كثيره في اي حال ولكن هذه العقائد
كانت
والممارسات اليهوديه مثلا انا استعمل
اليهوديه كمثال استمرت استمرت على مدى
القرون حتى
اقامه دوله اسرائيل
عندما كل شيء انتهى تمام اليهود تركوا
البلاد الاسلاميه راحوا اسرائيل والدوله
الحديثه دخلت فككت المجتمع اليهودي
والاسلامي هذا قصه ثانيه ولكن اللي بدي
اقوله انا انه
ما زال الاقليات في الاسلام وانا يعني ليس
اقليات عدديه ولكن اقليات دينيه بالمعنى
انه ليس هم الحكام مثل المسيحيه واليهوديه
استطاعوا ان يستمروا في
في توليد
نفسهم على مر العصور
على شروطهم هم مش على شروط المستعمر فشوف
قديش في تسامح قديش في
انفتاح اذا احنا بنقول مثلا في كندا انا
عشت في كندا 24 سنه فاعرف هذا اللي بيسموه
يعني مسخره عندما تدرس التاريخ الاسلامي
وترى كيف المسلمين عملوا الاقليات تبعتهم
وطبعا هذا هاي بس من ناحيه عم نحكي عن
طريق من ناحيه من ناحيه تغيير الذاتيه
للمحتل فاذا اذا كنا ممكن نتكلم عن اشياء
اخرى مثلا انه انه اليهود والمسيحيين في
الدول في التاريخ الاسلامي حتى القرن
العشرين اذا بتنظر انظر مصر مثلا محلتين
في عندك اقليات مسيحيه ويهوديه دائما في
في الطليعه كانوا الدكاتره والمحاميه
والتجار والاغنياء وعندهم امتيازات كثيره
ومرات كان عندهم امتيازات اكثر من
المسلمين بشكل غير عدل
يعني مرات بصراحه كان مغامرات كان كان كان
كان مرات يطوفوا
في اندونيسيا عم بتكرر نفس التجربه عندك
ثلاثه بالمئه من اندونيسيا هم صينيين
ويحوزون على 70% من
الثروات الطبيعيه في اندونيسيا والاموال
ثلاثه بالميه من
السكان
بيدهم 70% من ثروات الشعب من ثروات البلد
كيف بتقدر تقرا هذا التسامح ما بين
في الحكم الاسلامي مع غير المسلمين بينما
انه برضو في نفس التاريخ الاسلامي تلقى
العداء اللي جالس يصير كثير مثلا مع داخل
المسلمين بينهم مع المذاهب المختلفه ولا
اللي عنده افكار مختلفه ففيه يعني التاريخ
يعني كثير في الامثله
من طبعا طبعا كان في مثلا بعطيك الفتره
الصليبيه كان كتير في تعدي على المسيحيين
في في اللي بنسميها اليوم سوريا في حلب
ودمشق بالاساس
وبعض القرى الاخرى التي كانت في الزمان
كانت تحوط بتحيط بالقلعات
القلعه دائما حواليها قرى
فهذه كانت دائما عرضه للعنف
فطبعا كان في ليش لانه كان في تشكل كبير
انه المسيحيين في دمشق كانوا يساعدوا
الصليبيين يعني دائما كان لما لما يكون في
اضطهاد ضد مسيحي او يهودي في التاريخ
الاسلامي
لم يكن فقط بسبب تزمت
طبيعي
متشرش في العقليه الاسلاميه هذا لم يكن
دائما في ظروف خاصه التي كانت تؤدي للحاكم
او للشعب ان
يعني يشد الحزام على على الاقليات هذه مثل
مثلا الحكومه الفتره السلبيه بدون شك كانت
مشكله
للمسيحيين في سوريا انا لم اكن هناك ولا
استطيع ان ان اقرر في الامر هل كانوا
جواسيس ام لا ولكن هذا شيء طبيعي مثلا اذا
بتنظر لامريكا مثلا في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه شو عملت
حطت كل اليابانيين في
سموهم في معسكرات مسيجه
اليابانيين اللي كان حتى اللي كانوا ولدوا
من في امريكا من من اجيال ولم يكونوا
يابانيين الا بالشكل ولكن حطوهم كلهم في
هذه المعسكرات ليش لانه شكوا انه ممكن
يساعدوا اليابان هذا شيء طبيعي هذا رد فعل
لا نستطيع ان نقول انه انه
بالرغم من قباحته لا نستطيع ان هناك اشياء
في الحياه قبيحه ويجب ان تحدث يعني لا
تستطيع ان
كما يقولون نحن نولد
فتره الولاده لحظه الولاده في اللحظه
جميله جدا ولكن نولد في الدم
[موسيقى]
صحيح
فهذه قسم من ما تعنيه محاربه عدو قد غزى
بلادك واحتل ارضك وقتل شعبك وقتل الاخرين
يعني الصليبيين لم يقتلوا فقط المسلمين
قتلوا حتى المسيحيين في القدس
وفي القسطنطينا قبل اسطنبول
غزو هناك طبعا وقتلوا البيزنطيين
المسيحيين لانهم لم يكونوا لما كانوش زيهم
بدهم كانوا يخلصوهم
يخلصوا ارواحهم يساعدوهم انه يوصلوا
للخلاص قتلوهم
طيب انا ودي ارجعلي للشريعه فانت في كتاب
في كتاب شريعه كنت تقول انه استطاع النظام
او الدين الجديد في الاولى انه في انتاج
نظام
تشريعي عراقي
ودي تعطيني كيف بدا كيف تشكل هذا النظام
التشريعي من بدايته في عهد الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
مقدمه اذا سمحت
كل رؤيه تاريخيه هي خطاب
يعني عندما اقول ان تاريخ الاسلام قد تطور
كذا كذا كذا هذا خطاب وهذا الخطاب يصبح
قسم من مكوناتي الفكريه ولذلك من المكونات
الذاتيه فالخطاب
يكونني كذات
فهنا هناك على الاقل ساتحدث فقط عن عن
خطابين
خطاب عن فتره نشوء الشريعه لنعنع لنرى
الفرق بينهما ولاحقا ربما سنبحث مسائل
الاستشراق فستكون مقدمه لهذا لهذا لهذا
النقاش اللاحق
هناك خطاب استشراقي يقول ان شريعه تكونت
بعد ان غزا الفتح واستعمر المسلمون البلاد
الاخرى
وقد اتوا من الجزيره
جماعه بدو ما في عندهم شيك لا حضاره ولا
حتى تفكير
كل
النظره الاستشراقيه
لشعب الحجاز
وحتى كل الجزيره بقسم الجنوبي تبعها وين
نشا الاسلام او منتصف الجنوبي تبعها هو
انه
شعب بربري قبلي يعني شو معناته قبلي قبلي
هاي نقطه اخرى ممكن ندرسها بعدين انه قبل
يعني ضد كل القيم المتحضره اليوم
وهذول ما كان عندهم شيء بعتوا
قبائلهم اللي بحبوا العنف واحتلوا الشمال
والشرق والغرب
وبالاخر بمعنى احتلوا الارض هذه طب قالوا
شو بدنا نعمل استحتلناها وشو كيف بدنا
نساوي ما عنا شيء خلينا ناخذ
الثروات الشعوب الثانيه مش بس في الاموال
والاراضي لا الثروات الحضاريه بما في
القانون
فشو سويت اجو المسلمين الى انه ما في
عندهم شيء
هاي النظره الاستشراقيه وانا عم بلخص لك
الان
يمكن لازم تدفع لي شوي لانه بلخص لك انا
حوالي
هذه الخطاب
في 200 كتاب اذا بتلخصهم
وبتختزلهم شو النظر هذه النظره وانا كتبت
عنها كثير بالمناسبه يعني هذا مش مش مش
انطباعات هذا كونت سنوات من الدراسه عشان
هي نقسم كبير من كتاباتي هي الرد على
المستشرقين من هاي الناحيه من ناحيه كيف
تكونت الشريعه
فاخذوا القانون الروماني والقانون
البيزنطي والقانون اللي قبله القانون
اليوناني
والقانون اليهودي كل هذا سرق بالاحرى ما
بقولوا
استقرض بارونج سعر او دين
مثلا شو بقولوا في الانجليزي عشان تلخص
للشباب اللي بحبوا مهتمين بهاي الجلسات
انه يا انه هي يعني يعني استجلابات
لما بتستقرض او انه
تم استعاره او دين معناته انه اه شوفوا شو
اخذوا منه
استعاره هو اخذوا منا
يعني بالاول في نوع من الضمان لازم تدفعه
والتاني هو انه بس اخدوا منا صحتين ربما
فهذه هذه النظره الاستشراقيه هذه النظره
المتطرفه ولا هذه النظره هذه النظره
الاستشراقيه السائده
وحتى اقول بعد كل الكتابات التي كتبت ضدها
بالاساس من عدد قليل من الاشخاص بعدها
سائده كثير لذلك
من كبراء المستشرقين في الشريعه الاسلاميه
قالوا شو
لما صارت الاستعمار في القرن التاسع عشر
شوف كيف كل الحديث على القناه الاول
والقرن العشرين وال19 كله نفس الحديث
اللي بيدرسوا بفكر انه اه هاي كتاب مختص
في القرن الاول ما له علاقه بالقناه
العشرين ولكن اذا بتطلع عليها ده كلياتها
خطاب واحد
بيجي واحد مثل شخص يعد عميد الدراسات
الاسلاميه الشرعيه الاسلاميه في الغرب شو
بكون كل أسمع
انتم يا مسلمين
عانيتم من
قرون تجمدت
ومتجمده وانتو بمازق في القرن 19 يعني هذا
الحكي والاول العشرين
والقانون تبعكم فشل شريعه
فانتم مش راح تساويوا اشي
مش مالوف الكم انتم لما نشاتوا اصلكم انتم
استقرضتوا القانون الغربي اليوناني
والروماني واخره
لانه هو شو بقول المستشفى انه انه هن
المسلمين اخذوا كل هذه القوانين الغربيه
اللي هي اصلا اوروبيه لاحظ مثلا الفارسه
لا يدخل هنا مع انه الفرس اثروا على
الاسلام بكثير ولكن لا يدخل لانه كلياته
شغل استشراق فكل لازم يكون اوروبي
فدخلوا
اخذتوا كل هاي الشغلات وبعدين شو سويتوا
غطتوا في احاديث كذبه
وفي القران فمثلا نظريه استشراقيه حتى حتى
الان تقريبا او حتى حديثا يعني هو تقول ان
القران اتى لي
مضي على الحديث كانك تمضي على
على العقد
يمضي على الحديث على على الشريعه فقط
حوالي الميه بالهجره يعني القران لم يكن
له تاثير على الاسلام اول قرن هو اتى
لاحقا بس عشان يكون الغطاء يعني بسموه
الفينير في الانجليزي بستعملوها كتير شو
هو الفينير هو لما بتجيب انت خشب تعمل منه
طاوله بيكون خشب مكبوس ومش مش اشي يعني
خشب نوعيه عاطله فشو بتساوي بتحط عليه
طبقه طبقه طبقه ماخوذه من شجره طبيعيه
مقصوصه
مليمتر واحد
طبيعي وبتلزقوا عليه فلما الطاوله بتبين
ايش
كانها معموله من خشب طبيعي كلها فهذا
المسلمين حسب الاستشراق عملوه جابوا
القران وخلقوا الحديث عشان هيك النظريه
الكبيره في الاستشاره هو انه الحديث
النبوي كله مخلوق
وتدليس مشروع تدليس كبير
يعني لما بتقرا الاستشراق انت تستنتجي شي
واحد انه المستشرقين بشكل ادبي وبشكل
اكاديمي بقولوا انه هدول المسلمين اكبر
كذابين في الدنيا
كل حضارتهم مبنيه كذب بكذب لانه خلقه كل
كل الاحاديث النبويه تقريبا 5000 حديث حسن
ومستعمل وله
فعاليه في انشاء في في انشاء الشريعه
وتقريبا 700000 واحد تاني
اللي مش مش لا لا تؤخذ في عين الاعتبار
بشكل جدي
على الاقل في الشريعه هذا كله وحتى الحسن
كلياته كده فهو في عندهم شعار كل حديث
هو مفبرك
حتى نثبت العكس
قد قام بهذا الشعار وهو
مستشرق
اوست نمساوي يهودي
واكمل من بعده على عده عديد من من الكبار
مثل سلوك اللي هو هولندي وبالاساس شخص
اللي هو الماني فهذا القانون تبعهم انه كل
حديث هو زائف
حتى يثبت العكس
هذه النظره الاستشراقيه لتكون الشريعه
[موسيقى]
في القرن العشرين قالوا اسمعوا عملتوها
قبل اعملوها اسا كمان خذوا القوانين
الاوروبيه وقولوا انها اسلاميه يا عمي
غطوها كيف بدكم قولوا انه الديمقراطيه هي
شو رهي الديمقراطيه والديمقراطيه بالضبط
زي ما احنا بدنا اياها فبتصير الشورى
الديمقراطيه
فبما انه الشورى لها اساس في الخطاب
السياسي الاسلامي القديم فيصبح الخطاب هذا
منطبق على
الليبراليه الجديده هذا الخطاب الاكاديمي
الغربي هذا الخطاب القديمه واذا بدك بعطيك
بعض المراجع يعني
طيب هذه الصوره الاستشراقيه بس شو صار في
الحقيقه
يختلف تماما اعطني اول شيء
اذا بتقرا
زي ما كل واحد عنده
يعني
عقل موزون وغير مبرمج وغير مهدف
كالعقل الاستعماري اذا قرا المصادر
الاسلاميه نعرف انه القران من اول يوم
القران الكريم من اول يوم نزل كان له
تاثير شديد على المسلمين ليس هناك اي نظير
حتى في التاريخ البشري انا لا اعرف كتاب
واحد اثر على عقول الناس كالقران
هذا هو اول شيء بعدين كما اثبت حديثا
حديثا بخلال بس من بعد ما الصحابه بده
يتوفوا دغري بديو مسلمين يقولوا احنا شو
لازم نساوي في هذه الحاله وقعت عنا مساله
طب كيف بدنا نحل المساله اه شو القران
بقول فبديت من الاول بس هذا كله بده دراسه
القران هو ليس ليست شريعه القران هو كتاب
هدايه ولكن الشريعه شيء كما اصبحت لاحقا
والقران شيء تاني القران هو اساس
واساس الشريعه واساس
ما هي الشريعه هي التفسير اللغوي كما
كما كما
يعني قام بمشروع كبير ابن ادريس الشافعي
رحمه الله مشروع ابن ادريس الشافعي كان
كان بس مشروع لغوي
لغوي
شرعي يعني الرساله تبعته وطبعا في في كتاب
الامه كمان شوي ولكن في الرساله تبعته
بالاساس هي مشروع انه كيف نفهم ما يريد
الله لنا
فكيف نفهم ذلك نريد نريد اشارات ودلائل
والى اخره والى اخره نريد الحبل لنمسك به
لكي نجره ونصل لماذا احسن طريقه اللي ممكن
توصلنا لمعرفه ما يريد الله منا وهو شو هو
تقليد تقليد الله في حكمته
فانت سالت واحد من ضيوفك انا
برنامج انه شو الفرق بين العلم الاسلامي
والعلم الاسلامي كله اذا كان المسلمين لما
درسوا الفلك ولا درسوا الرياضيات ولا لما
ابن الهيثم درس العين او كل شيء كل شيء
والشريعه
وكلياته كان محاوله فهم كيف يشتغل عقل
الله
لانه لما لما لما لما خلق الله الدنيا
خلقها بالعدل
والحكمه
عدل
فكل الهدف هو اننا نفهم كيف وما هو عبد
الله
حتى لما ندرس الكواكب احنا عم ندرس مش
عشان نحتلها زي ما بنساوي بنروح عشان
نلاقي كوكب نستبد زيك قنينه الكوكاكولا
بتشربها وبترميها احنا عم نساوي في الارض
كان كيف بنساوي قنينه الكوكاكولا تشربها
وبترميها من غير مسؤوليه من غير نظره من
غير احساس في انه انت عم بتدمر الارض
ومبسوط انت على حالك ولكن ونفس الشيء
منساوي في الكواكب
علماء الهيئه اليوم هو انه يلاقوا ارض
كوكب زي الارض وبتدور وبقول لك احسنت ان
الحل له انه نلاقي كوكب بعيد عن شمس نفس
المسافه اللي احنا بعيدين فيها عن الشمس
فهناك تنتلئ الشروط او تتكون الشروط
اللازمه انه احنا نقدر نعيش عليها اطلع
على الحكمه هاي ليش بس طيب هو ما في شيء
اذا بدك تلاقي كوكب ثاني صحتين بلاقي كوكب
ثاني ما في شيء غلط فيه بحد ذاته ولكن انت
بدهن يلاقوا كوكب ثاني عشان هذا الكوكب
راح ندمره شايفين شايفين كل يوم كل يوم عم
بتصير عشان الغناء والاقوياء يحطوا حالهم
بسفينه ويطلعوا يعيشوا ملوكنا والباقين
يضلوا هون يعانوا من
التدميرات اللي صارتهم وهذا حقيقه يعني
هذا الفرق بين اه طبعا الفرق العلم
الاسلامي يختلف تماما بفلسفته عن العلوم
الحديثه مع انه كان متفوق في العالم عن
جميع كل الحضارات الاخرى ومع انه حتى ظاهر
العلم الغربي حتى القرن الثامن عشر
الرياضيات والعلوم الفلكيه
والعين
والدوره الدمويه يعني حتى القرن اخر القرن
بدايه القرن الثامن عشر كان
الاطباء المسلمين يضحكوا على الاوروبي
كانوا يضربوها ومش قادرين البريطانيين
يحلوا كيف انه شو هدول الارشادات عشان
يقدروا يقاوموها عشان يحاولوا يحاولوا
سفنهم لطريق ثانيه او يروحوا يحاربوا
الغواصات الى اخره
خلقوا الكمبيوتر اللي احنا اليوم نستعمله
اللي انا وانت والكل خلقوه عشان عشان
الشغله هذه عشان يقدروا يفوزوا في الحرب
ضد الالمان بس وين المشكله
المشكله كان انه يعني كانت في حاجه تطلبت
اختراع وصار اختراع اليوم مفيد لجون ثانيه
المشكله انه يصبح سؤال جيد جدا يصبح
الاختراع العلمي والتطور العلمي يصبح هدفه
ليس خدمه الانسان
لانه تاريخه عنف فمعناته مربوط بشيء تاني
احنا مش شايفينها فمثلا لما بقول لك انا
انه كل
التطعيم اول تطعيمات في في التاريخ البشري
التطعيمات الصناعيه لانه بتعرف انت الهنود
الامريكان وكان عندهم تطعيمات نباتيه ولكن
تختلف وليست فعاله مثل اليوم ولكن كان
عندهم ولكن تطعيمات مثل ضد
التفويد والكوليرا والى اخره وكلياته هذا
هذا انت عارف من وين اجى هذا كلياته اخترع
باوروبا عشان يقدروا يبعتوا جنودهم
نهر النيجر في افريقيا لانه نهر النيجر
كان الطريق الوحيده يقدر يحتله افريقيا مش
قادرين يحتلوها لانه سفنهم وجنودهم بخلال
جمعه جمعتين كلهم يموتوا من الامراض
من من القارس والذباب والى اخره كله
والى اخره فلكون هالحل اللي هي التطعيم
شو معناته هذا معناته انه بدك تبحث اسا
هذا انت اكتشفت اشي واحد انت انت كنت
تعرفه قبلها انه التاريخ الطب هالقد مربوط
مع العنف خلال اللي بيعرفوه خلال
قلالات يعني بحط رابط في وصف الحلقه
لفيديو يشرح يعني بعض اللي حصل انه اصلا
حتى كانت تتم على الناس في افريقيا
بالعنف بالضبط فبدك تبحث علاقه مثلا
الطب في الاقتصاد لانه الاستعمار لم يكن
هيك على وجه الله
بس بنروح نستعمل لا بدهن كانوا كان الهدف
الهدف الاساسي
بالبدايه انه ياخذوا ثروات الشعوب الاخرى
فراحوا سرقوا كل الذهب والفضه من امريكا
جابوه على من امريكا الجنوبيه بالاساس
ولكن الشماليه كمان جابوه على اوروبا
واستغنوا فيها وعملوا عمايل فيها راحوا
على الهند سرقوا كل البهارات تبعتها
والذهب كمان
وحجار كريمه بتعرف الياقوت واخره كانت
الهند مليانه فيها
راحوا على مصر سرقوها فنحن نعرف القصه هذه
ولكن لا نعرف انه الطب مثلا والذي نفتخر
فيه اليوم انه نشوف كيف اليوم ما حدا الكل
عنده علاج مش عارف ايش بالطب الحديث كذا
كذا هذا كلياته مربوط ربط تام تام بتاريخ
الراسماليه اللي هي قسم كبير من تاريخ
الاستعمار اللي هي قسم كبير من تاريخ
العنف
وبنايه اسلحه مدمره الى لم تعرف قبل وقسم
كبير من عقلي الاوروبيه التي تشتغل بهذه
الطريقه انا كتبت كتاب سميته قصور
الاستشراق فانا هناك ادعي انه انه انه
ليست هناك حقيقه
انتجت من اليد البشريه مثل هون السنتر
بارك في نيويورك هذا كله شغل ما في شجره
هون اللي الا مزروعه اصطناعيا يعني ما في
شجره من ابكوها من قبل
هذه هذا خلق انساني
ليست هناك اي خلق انساني
الا
ما يفرضه العقل علينا يعني بالمعنى انه
اذا كانه احنا عملنا اشي هذا نتيجه كيف
بنفكر فالتفكير تبعنا هو اهم اشي يعني
يعني لما انت بتفكر بطريقه بتعمله
فمثلا السكين في المطبخ تعطيه لطباخ منيح
او شريف بينتج لك احلى طبخه بحط لك اياها
وبستقبلك احلى استقباله زي اخوك هو
ومحب والى اخره والى اخره هذا بايده كان
سكين اعطيه لواحد سراق بده يسرق بيتك رح
يقتلك ويسرق بيتك ويطلع
اعطيه لمجرم نعرف شو
السكين مش مهم هنا السكين هو مجرد اداه
اللي بقرر كيف السكين ويستعمل هو العقل
طريقه التفكير
فاوروبا كل تفكيرها من من بدايه تاريخها
مع انه طويل ومعقد والى اخره يرجع حتى في
الى
العصور البربريه عندما نزحت هذه الطوائف
والقبائل البربريه من شمال اوروبا
لاسبانيا والمانيا
لاحقا سمي بالفيزيكوت والاخره والجرمانيين
والفرنكيين وكل هدول كلهم من الشعوب
الشماليه عندهم هدول غزو اوروبا واملو
اوروبا في الناس وكان لهم طريقه تفكير
معينه في في مساله الههم كان اله حرب
ولا الى الان لا تفكيرهم اخذت اخذت اخذت
تتطور وتاخذ اشكال
مختلفه ولكن المضمون بقي بشكل بشكل كبير
بقي نفسه
فعشان هيك بتلاحظ انه مثلا الصينيين كان
عندهم البارود من من من 1500 سنه هو عمله
اول ناس اخترعوا البندقيه هن الصينيين هو
اول ناس كان عملوا فيه البندقيه اللي هو
البارود الصينيين طب ليش يا عمي الصينيين
ما احتلوا العالم عملوا في 1422 بنو اسطول
الف سفينه
بخوفه كل واحد كانت قد اربع خمس سفن
اوروبيه فهذاك الوقت
راحوا على افريقيا
وزاره افريقيا
وحاربوا بعض
المجرمين في البحر البايرس
ولموا النباتات وجابوا ممثلين عن السلاطين
والملوك
يقدموهن للامبراطوريه امبراطور الصيني
ورجعوا رجعوا
والزرافات والحيوانات الجميله والنباتات
الحلوه وبعض السفراء من من من الدول هو
رجعوا فيها وحطوا الاسطول تبعهم بالمواني
الصين وعفنت
اوروبا شو عملت اكتشفت البارود الصيني
واكتشفت انه في طريقه نعمل كمان مدفع
على الحرج من غير من غير التاخر
بدو يبنوا وبنوا اكثر سفن قاتله في كتاريخ
البشري سفنز نسبيا صغيره تحمل مدافع
تطلق بشكل ممكن تعمل خزق في في ثغره في في
سفينه كبيره كبيره وتغرقها
فاصبحت هاي لا للمسلمين ولا الصينيه ولا
اي حدا لما لما نزلوا على المحيط الهندي
البرتغاليين والاسبانيين لما نزلوا بطل
حدا يقدر يقاومهم عشان هيك يسيطروا على
البحر الهندي وتغيرت فيه نمط التجاره تغير
تماما كان نمط التجاره سائد بين المسلمين
والصينيين
والهنود وشعوب اخرى ويتعاملوا بالمناسبه
اغلب الاعراف اللي كانت حسب الشريعه حتى
الصينيين كانوا يتبعوا قانون البحري حسب
مشاريعه فرضته مش لانه مش لانه شعره لا
مفرق لانه كان موجود وكان وكان المتعارف
عليه فاخذوه استعملوه
فهذا كلياته تقطع واصبح البرتغاليين تمرق
من هون بدك تدفع لنا فلوس وربما اذا كانك
انت عامل ذهب او شيء فلوس مش فلوس بناخذ
ذهبك انت للاسر وذهبك من اخته بنبني فيه
قصور في البرتغال وفي فرنسا وانجلترا
المسلمين نفس الشيء كان عندهم رغبه توسعيه
وتوسعه يعني يعني من الجزيره العربيه الى
اقصى فصار يعني حتى هارون رشيد راى الغيمه
قال امطري حيث شئتي فان اخراجك يعني
احتلال هيك ولكن ولكن في حدود
اذا بدك نبحثها بالذات بعد القرن التاسع
السابع عشر نبحث هيك
وهذه اوروبا كانت
الاستثناء في التاريخ البشري هذا اللي
لازم نفهمه احنا انه احنا وصلنا عايشين
كمجتمع ام مجتمعات
متماسكه وسياسيا يعني كان عنا المدن
الصغيره اللي هي كانت مدن مدن دول من من
7000 سنه ما احنا تاريخنا اليوم
تقدر تقول انه تدوين تاريخنا اللي بنعرفه
بالشكل او باخر يعني كثير او قليل ولكن
نعرف شيء عنه او نعرف كثير عنه توقف وين
ومتى انه رجع برجع لخمس ستلاف سنه
في التاريخ البشري هذا المدون اللي نعرف
عنه
الاستثناء الوحيد في هذا التاريخ هو
اوروبا فاذا كانوا في عندك تعرف كيف
تبدا من القرنه وبتطلع فيه هيك هيك على
البسيط يعني بدك دوب اللي فوق الخط الاسفل
بعدين ما بتشوف الا في قفزه
تقريبا اثنين بالمئه من طول الخط ولكن يا
لفوق بتوقف كيف انت بتشوف التاريخ
الاوروبي اذا كانه بتشوفوا طريقه وائل
حلاق معناته لتحت اذا بتشوفها حسب الناس
اللي باعوا روحهم وعقلهم للاستعمار بكون
لفوق
انا اعرف ليش صار تحت بالنسبه لوائل انه
اغلب الناس ترى للاعلى فهذه الحلقه فيها
استطرادات ذات هنا رائعه يعني
تطور الشريعه كنت تطور الشريعه حلو
شكرا على الارجاع
فانا استطيع ان اقول انه اكبر اكبر فعل
واهم فعل
حدث في تاريخ الاسلام لاقامه الشريعه هو
كان في عصر
عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه عمر
يعني لعب دور مخيف في انشاء الاسلام
ليش طبعا هو اقام الدواء وانشا الدواوين
والى اخره ولكن كانت نصها فارسيه اصلا
ولكن حطها والذكاء خارق
فحطها واستعملها بشكل ذكي والاخره طبعا
هذا
واضح ولكن شو عمل قال انه من البدايه قال
انه في كل محل فيه تجمع اسلامي وعاده
كانوا هدول القبائل اللي راحوا غزو
والقبائل كانت تتغاوش مع بعضها فلما وصلوا
في
البتن العراق او حتى في مصر في الفسطاط
اصبحوا فلان يتغاوشوا مع من وفلان اللي هم
احتلوا مصر ولكن بس قعدوا بده يختلفوا على
على مسائل لانه جايبين معهن تعرف تاريخ
قبلي من الجزيره فبده يختلفوا مع بعض طب
هذا عمر مش عايزه اسا احنا بدنا نحتل
البلاد بدنا نعمل بدنا نعمل
دولي نعمل امبراطوريه فشو قال انه في كل
محل فيه تجمع اسلامي بتبني مسجد حالا
بس شو معناه المسجد احنا بنقول ما عنا
مسجد بنسمع بالتاريخ بنقرا بالتاريخ اه
وقد بنى المساجد في الصغور
بنى المساجد في الصغور بس يا عمي شو
معناته هذا شو هو المسالم المسجد مش مبنى
بس
هو اول ما بتبدا في المسجد هو المبنى هاي
اول خطوه صغيره بس شو بصير في المسجد شو
عم الممارسات في المسجد صار في مسجد فيه
فيه امام ومؤذن والى اخره على الصغير على
المصغر ولكن كان موجود واصبحوا يقراون
القصص
والقصص كان فيها كثير فيها من الاحاديث
النبويه وكيف الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان
يتصرف ويعملوا ما يعملش وينهي وما ينهيش
وكثير من من الاثار يعني ما هي الاثار
يعني هي الاقوال
واللغه التي تكون لنا نوع من مصدر
للتصرفاتنا او عبره حتى العبره هي وما هي
العبره العبره هي كمان تقود التصرف
لذلك تسمى عبره
فلما بنى هذه
المساجد وهذا احنا بنحكي يعني
فقط بخلال عشر سنوات 15 سنه بعد وفاه
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
بديت بديوي الناس يروحوا على المساجد
بس هدول اللي راحوا على المساجد المحتلين
القاده تبعتهم كانوا مسلمين على الاخر
بدون شك كانوا مخلصين للقضيه والى ولكن
القبائل اللي ارتدت قبل بس 10 سنوات ابو
بكر كان بعده ابو بكر قبل عمر كان يحارب
فيهم هدول كانوا في الكمانا اشتركوا في
الفتوحات فهذول كان عندهم نصف قلب في
الاسلام
ما كانوا كلهم يعني لا لا لان هدول كل
المسلمين اللي فتحوا على المستوى الشخصي
العادي كلهم كانوا فاهمين شو حتى الاسلام
بالضبط والاخره في منهم كانوا بس بدهم بس
اغلبهم والقياده كانت كلياتها صافيه
القياده كانت صافيه عشان هيك كيف فتحوا
كانوا يروحوا الفين واحد
يكسروا عشرين الف من العدو لانه كانت
ملتزمين بالقضيه
ولكن شو عملوا هدول هدول كان عندهم اولاد
فبعت اولادهم للمسجد وهذا الجيل جيل
الاولاد اولاد الذين فتحوا الاراضي
الفتحاتها الاسلام
هو الجيل اللي بدي ينتج ناس اللي عندهم
ليس فقط ايمان في الاسلام ولكن عندهم
التزام بما يتطلبوا الاسلام كحضاره
ومفهوم شخصي واجتماعي يعني الاسلامي ليس
فقط اشهد ان لا اله الا الله وان محمد هاي
هاي هاي ما بتكفيش لحالها هذا ما بتعمل
هيك مسلم صحيح
بتقدمك للاسلام بتفوتك على الاسلام ولكن
لما انت بتفوت على الباب باب الدار ما
بتوقف عند الباب وخلص بكون انا هون بديش
والباب انا هون تختي انا هون كذا لا بدك
تفوت تشوف شو ولما بتعيش في البيت كفايه
بصيح بصير قسم منك
فالاسلام هو كمان تكوين ذاتيه اهم شيء
عزيزي لازم نفهم اشي واحد انه ليس هناك
فهم لاي ظاهره اليوم ان كانت ظاهره لها
علاقه في التكوين الانساني
الا انها ترجع الى تكوين الذات فيجب ان
نفهم من نحن هو من هم ومن هم ومن هم
فمثلا انا لماذا انت ليش برنامجك انت
ناجحي انا اصلي بفكر في موضوع كم اسبوع
يعني يعني اسا اخذك انا من البرنامج لا
سمح الله واحط واحد تاني البرنامج راح
يتحول تماما ليش لانه ذاتيتك
طريقه تفكيرك طريقه سؤالك للضيف طريقه
معاملتك للضيف طريقه الكل
تستجلب كل هذا يعني صعب حتى مرات فهم شو
بالضبط بدخل في تكوين الذات ولكن كله مع
بعض نجاح هائل والحمد لله
الذاتيه احنا بنسميها والله انا مش مرتاح
معه بدي واحد تاني بس شو معناته ليش لانه
انت مش مرتاح بس مع الشخص لانه هيك لا انت
مش مرتاح مع ذاتيته
الذاتيه هي كل شيء هناك كان في ذاتيه
اسلاميه هدول القبائل اللي اشتركت في
الفتوحات ذاتيه ثم كانت اسلاميه محضة ولكن
بس خلق الجيل الاول ونشا في المساجد بدات
الذاتيه الاسلاميه تتكون بالشكل كانه
تقريبا كل شي موجود هناك
في كان وين نشا الفقه
هذا هاي هاي حقيقه لا نستطيع ان نقول انها
اقل من حقيقه اهراميه
كيف الاهرام في مصر تقف شامخه وعاليه من
اهم الحقائق
لانه لانه
الفقه والقانون
لم يكن هناك
ما نسميه القانون قانون الجهاز السياسي
والقانون الجهاز الاجتماعي
خلق تماما من قبل افراد بسطاء في المجتمع
حتى احيانا الفقراء ولم يخلق من يعني لما
كان لما كان قاضي بمصر او في دمشق كان
يحكم بين الناس او يحكم مرات من الناس
كانت تستعصي عليه مرات قضايا معينه فكان
يكتب مثلا خلينا نقول عمر يقول له
يا عمي انا عاصي بهالمشكله ارشدنا اياها
كل عمر اغلب الاحيان كله اجتهد برايك
طب ممكن انا اليوم مش عارف شو القانون هو
اكتب لمدير او مكتب قانوني في الدوله
وتيجي يقول لي انا اجتهد برايك اليوم
الدولي عندك قانون
ودائما عندك قانون وهي اللي بتحط القانون
ولا واحد تاني بيقدر يتحداها
الخليفه لم لم يشرع
عمر مثلا كان عنده مواقف شرعيه لانه كان
صحابي مش لانه كان خليفه شو الفرق الصحابي
هو يتكلم
بما يعرفها عن فقيه بما يعرفوا عن ما كيف
كان ممكن انه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يحل المشكله فبقول لك انا شفت انا صحابي
شو معناه صحابي انه صاحبه الرسول صاحبت
الرسول هي هو ليس فقط مساله مساله
اجتماعيه هذا اللي احنا بنفكر فيه دائما
المساله الاجتماعيه في الاسلام صحابه
الصحابه والصحابه الرسول هي مساله
ليه معناته الصحابي يعرف عن ما يريده
الرسول والرسول يعرف ما يريده الله
بشكل اقرب شيء بين اي انسان واخر او اي
انسان او اي قوه الهيه اخرى
عمر كان صحابي كان ابن مسعود والى اخره
ابن مسعود مثلا لانه كان ابن مسعود كان من
من
الاكبر القانونيين اذا ممكن يصح التعبير
اليوم قانوني اكبر قانونيه في تاريخ
الاسلام في الاول هدول كيف كانوا ليش
كانوا لانه كانوا
قريبين على الرسول لدرجه انه كانوا يكادون
يعرفون معرفه الرسول هاي المساله مساله
معرفه مثلا مش مساله انه قعدت مع الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم وشربت قهوه
ابو بكر كان يروحوا مع الرسول ويفطروا مع
بعض
ويزوروا
حتى المدارس اليهوديه ويسمعوا شو كانوا
مفتوحين كانوا يعملوا اشياء كثير مع بعض
بس بس هذا بحد ذاته هي مش علاقه اجتماعيه
هي علاقه
هدول الجيل الجديد اللي طلع على المساجد
وتعليم المساجد وما كان يحدث في المساجد
هم كانوا الفقهاء
فالفقه اصبح في يد الناس ليس في يد
السياسه ومن هنا نبدا نفهم الفرق الشاسع
بين المفهوم التركيب التركيبه السياسيه
الاسلاميه والتركيبه السياسيه الغربيه
اليوم
فمثلا كان كان
واحد يكون عنده مشكله
يروح بده يستشير
يستشير حدثه في
يروح للناس عاديين اللي تخصصوا في الفقه
ومتى بتلاقي قصص اخرى مثلا واحد عم ببيع
بواحد بياع جلود تعرف احذيه والى اخره
واخره او او ثياب
بتلاقيه بيعلم قاعد في قدام دكانته في
السوق بعلم طلاب الفقه عم نحكي عن تمارين
هجريه 80 هجريه في دائري حلق وعم بعلمهم
الفقه فبتلاقيه قطعه في في
عليه في درسه لانه اجى واحد بده يشتري
حزام منجل فبقامل الاستاذ باع الحزام واخذ
الفلوس
ورجع وقعد في الحلقه وكمل درسه هذه في
المدينه ولا في كل المدن هذه القصه من من
علم البصر او الكفلاء
لانه كانوا كانوا من من مراكز الاساس
الاولى لنشاه الفقه
فبدء الاول تشكيل الفقه وهو التعبير عن
اجاب عن سؤال ماذا نفعل في هذه الاحوال
اتى من هذه من هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين هم من
المتوسط الاجتماعي لم يكونوا اما قياده
عسكريه او سياسيه وانما كانون الناس مثله
مثلك يعني ناس
بالتجار صغار تجار كبار ويمكن مرات يعني
ناس عاديين اللي عندهم
حياه عاديه فبتسمح لي
استفسر في نقطه تفضل يعني مثلا
قد يكون لكن في الاخير برضو هذا اذا
استشكل عليه امر او احد منهم
صار يعني يفتي خلاف يعني ما بيتفق عليه
مثلا الاسلام في احد بيرده
يتوقف في احد بيوقفها ويقول له طبعا كان
في جدالات على على الاقوال يعني لانه هذا
قول
هو لما يطلع في قول هو مجرد قول ممتاز
وتلقى الوالي معين من عمر بن الخطاب وعلي
العراق
لا لا هو من ارسله وقال له انت تكون هناك
قاضي قاضي قاضي قاضي اه طبعا انا عينتك
دوله طبعا دوله كوالي كحاكم
فيما يمديك تخليها انه انت قبل شوي كنت
تقول انه هذه تصير من الناس من البسطاء
بينما تجد في حقيقه الامر ان
القائد
الخليفه المسلمين امير المؤمنين سمى هو من
عين الوالد القاضي فانا معي صح لا هذا هذا
الشيء واللي بحكي عنه انا شيء ثاني يختلف
تماما
طبعا القضاه هم من قسم من الجهاز
القضائي الذي هو المسؤول عنه كان هو
الخليفه في البدايه وبعدين السلطان لاحقا
في القرون لاحقا هذا طبعا بكون القاضي
لازم يكون عنده خبره وحنكه في اشياء كثيره
بما في قراءه العادات الاجتماعيه والاخره
مش بس قانون يعني لازم يعرف في الشريعه
ويعرف في كثير من الاشياء ولكن هذا نفترض
ان هذا القاضي عين من بعد ما تدربه يعني
حدا علمه كيف يساوي هاي الشغلات صحيح
كيف نشا الفقه هذا شيء تاني كيف كتب الفقه
في كتبه ما له علاقه في القضاء مباشره
يعني كان له علاقه بالمعنى انه مرات اللي
كان يكتب كان قاضي بس مرات لا مثلا احنا
بنعرف انه في بعض القضاه بعض الفقهاء
رفضوا انه يشتغلوا في سلك القضاء رفض عن
مبدا وكانوا محدودين حددوا نفسا
للتصنيف كتابه الكتب والتعليم كشيوخ في
المدارس
هي بالاساس
التعليم الفقه وكتابه والافته فعندك انت
اربع اربع وظائف في القضاء مهمه جدا هي
القضاء والافتاء والتصنيف كتابه الكتب
اللي كمان فن خاص
مع المشيخه وهي تعليم الجيل الجديد
في كثير منهم رفضوا انه يصيروا قضى
والدوله انذاك
لها ارتباط بالقضاء فقط
الافتاء والتعليم ماذا يطبق القاضي يطبق
القاضي الفقه الذي انتجهه بعض ما يسموا
باصحاب الايمان الاوائل لانها هي بدات
المساله في الايمان انه امنوا في الاسلام
بشكل انه دخلوا فيه روحا وجسدا وهذول هذا
السبب انه دخلوا فيه روحا وجزر جسدا جعلهم
يسالوا يتساءلوا طب احنا لما ناكل ونشرب
اذا وقعت الفار في الزيت ولا ولا كلها طب
شو بدنا نسوي فيها هاي فبداوا يلاقوا
يحاولوا يلاقوا حلول لهايل وقدموا قال انا
بفكر انه هيك فانا فقيه نفسي فانا امارس
حسب اجتهادي انا واذا بدك تاخذه واذا بدك
مع السلامه حر انت بحالك واجب فقيه ثاني
عمل نفس الشي وبدي تتكون
زي ما تقول المدارس الفقهيه التي اصبحت
لاحقا تسمى بالمذاهب ولكن المهم المهم جدا
هون انه نفهم انه تكون طبعا كان في
عم بسترد انا الخطاب الاستشراقي اللي
حكينا عنه قبل شوي
كان في طبعا لما احتلوا
الاراضي
الشاميه والفارسيه واخرها طبعا كان هناك
بالاساس حضاره في سوريا والى اخره حضاره
بيزنطيه في الشرق كانت الفارسيه
طبعا كان موجود هناك وكانت مؤثره جدا والى
اخره ولكن
هدول المؤمنين الجدد
اخذوا شو بدهم
ورفضوا شو بدهم
لم يكونوا مثل المستعمرين اليوم في العالم
الاسلامي وغيره انه انه انه ياخذوا على
على الترار كانوا ياخذوه
من موقف قوه من موقف قوه
طيب في عهد الخلافه الراشد كان
اكثر المؤثرين على الشريعه هم الفقهاء
في عهد الرسول في عهد الخلاف في عهد
الخلافه الاولى
يعني
كانت
الفقه لم ينشا بعد يعني كان بعض مؤسسات
مثل مثلا الدواوين
احنا نعرف قسم من من الفقه يعني مزبوط
دخلت على الاسلام من من بلاد فارس بشكل
كبير وليس كليا لانه قوانين
تطورت لاحقا واصبح هناك فيها اشياء يعني
لم يعرفها الفرس قبل ولكن في البدايه في
عصر عمر
كانت فارسيه اغلبها
واصبحت في الاخر
قسم من المواصفات
الفقهيه مثلا اذا بتشوف كل الكتب الاحكام
السلطانيه
وابو يعلى ابن الفراء ولاحقا ابن جماعه
وابن تيميه والى اخره كلياتهم
قسم من مواصفات الشريعه
ولكن لم يكن هناك بعد الجيل اللي انا عم
بحكي عنه فكانوا بعدهن عم بحاولوا بحاولوا
يلاقوا طريقهم
الجيل الفقهاء بدا بالاساس تحت الفتره
الاولى في الدوله الامويه
فقبل اوصل للدوله المئويه ودي بالنسبه
للمستشرقين ما تشوف انه
من الممكن انك تفهم انه يعني انه عادي
اصلا انك تاخذ من هذه الحضارات لتشكل
تشريعك الطبيعي فمثلا الدواوين من فارس او
غيرها اللي اخذتها من الحضاره الثاني وين
الاشكال فممكن معهم حق لا لا بدون شك
المسلمين كانوا كانوا
من
من امهر الشعوب انهن يفتحوا عقلهم لكل
جيرانهم
فدخلوا في الهند
استجلبوا من الهند كثير من يسجلوا من فارس
ومن اليونان والى اخره على الشريعه على
على كل شيء مثلا اذا كانك ما هو ليش بقول
كل شيء لانه لما بتكون شريعه كمان معناته
الشريعه فيه اصول الفقه صحيح طب اصول
الفقه فيه منطق صحيح طبعا
ودخله في اصول الفقه
لانه معناته دخل في الشريعه وكان في نفس
الوقت الكلام فيه منطق وكذا كذا كذا في
هذه التقسيم العلوم في الاسلام هي كثيرا
تكون تقسيمات مصطنعه لانه العلوم
الاسلاميه مترابطه بشكل هائل جدا لدرجه
انه لما تطور علم بشكل كبير واخر بشكل اخر
كشروش الشجرتين جنب بعض تتداخلان بصير
ياخذوا من نفس الارض ويستمدوا ويصير يحكم
مع بعض كمان نحن نعرف انه الشجر اللي احنا
بنتكلم مع بعض وتحت الارض
نفس الشيء
الاسلام
لانه كان ياخذ من موقف قوه باخد شو بدي هو
اللي كان الاسلام كان الدوله خلينا نقول
باصطلاح اليوم اذا صح الدوله الامبرياليه
ومرات واحد ياخذ والثاني ما بدوش مثلا
كان دخل المنطق الغزالي وابن حازم دخله
المنطق بالمناسبه بين حزم بدي في مشروع
قبل ابن الغزالي على عكس المفهوم السائد
اليوم ولكن غزالي كان له اكبر تاثير بدون
شك ولكن هو من ناحيه تاريخيه واسبقيه
الابن حزم بدي قبل الغزال فلم الغزاله
ادخل المنطق
يعني اذا انت بتفهم مزبوط كل
التشعبات المنطق المنطق ينتهي في
الميتافيزيقي والميتافيزيقي اليونانيه
وهنا اشترك الغزالي وابن عليه انه اغلبها
فاسده
فمعناته في اشي غلط في المنطق فعشان هيك
كتب كتب الرد على المنطقيين اليونان 550
صفحه في طبعه اليوم وحتى لما اختصروا
السيوطي اختصروا بشيء تقريبا 150 متر صفحه
تجريد بس في المنطقه وترك الاشياء هذا
كتاب ترجمته انا للانجليزيه
كان في صراعات يعني صراعات مش بالمعنى
السيء ولكن كانت في ديناميكيه كبيره في
فكريه في الاسلام وتقبلوا ورفضوا كثير من
الاشياء فانت مثلا تاخذ اصول الفقه اصول
الفقه مليان من مواد اللي اللي جاي من عده
نواحي ولكن غير المقدمات وصول الفقه في
بعض وصول الفقه اللي هي في القياس في
القياس
المنطقي البرهاني يسمى القياس البرهاني
غير القياس قياس البرهاني وين راح تشوف اي
اشي من بس اذا كانك بتعرف اصول الفقه منيح
منيح تدخل في في مداخله الدقيقه فبتلاحظ
بتقدر بتصير تشم كيف انك انت بتعرف انه في
الاكل هاي انحطوا كركم او حطوا خلينا نقول
محلب او شيء ولكن انت مش راح تشوفه بس
شاموا موجود بس دوبل مش موجود ما بتعرفش
لكن موجود هناك انت بتشوف في عندك تقرا
هذا بتقرا حتى علماء يونان او بتقرا على
علماء هنود بتلاقي في اشياء اراء مشتركه
ليه لانه كلهم
اخذوا من بعض
وفي التاريخ الاسلامي نفسه مشكله
التاريخيه هي انه بسبب
الدعوه العباسيه
[موسيقى]
وثوره على الامويين
وكسرهم
في اصبح هناك
اصبح ثنائي اصبح هناك في خطاب في تاريخ
الاسلامي
واللي تبنوا المؤرخين الجدد بما في
المستشرقين هو انه الدوله الامويه بسبب
معاويه والحروب الاوليه هي الدوله سيئه
وعملت عمايل شنيعه ولاجل العباسيين يصلحوا
الامور ولكن هذا خطا
طبعا عند العباسيين كان في كمان خلفاء
اللي يعني سجلهم مش كثير كويس
الحكم حكم السياسي دائما اطلع على مثلا
تاريخ امريكا ورؤساء امريكا شوف كم واحد
صار في منهم كم واحد منهم فاسد وعمل عمايل
هذا طبيعي في السياسه السياسه هي هذا حقل
السياسي هو حق الذي يمتد بين الخير
والفساد بشكل سواء اكثر للفساد من لانه
يتطلب سياسي دائما تتطلب الكثير من من
الاعمال
الغير اخلاقيه
فهذا هذا لابد نحكم على الامويين لازم
ناخذ بعين الاعتبار كمان هم كانوا حكموا
وكانوا حكام زي الناس ثانيين فيجب ان
يقاسوا بنفس المعيار هذا واحد ثاني
الدعايه العباسيه ضدهم اثرت عليهم كثير
وخلتهم ينزلوا في التاريخ الاسلامي بشكل
سلبي ولكن الامويين كمان تحت الامويين هي
قامت الشريعه بالاساس تحت الهناويين طبعا
ولكن ليس فقط بتشجيعهم بس لانه كان هناك
طريقه تفكير
متعارف عليها عاديه عرفيه التي تطلبت وهذا
امتداد للحديث السابق تتطلبت انه انه
افراد علماء هم الذين يقومون بانشاء الفقه
ومبنى يعني يعني
باللغه الحديثه يعني لم يتدخل الدوله
والامبرا الاسلاميه في انشاء اي قسم او اي
جزء من
السلطه التشريعيه السلطه التشريعيه في
الاسلام هي كانت حضاره بحد ذاتها وهي
العلماء والشريعه
والحضاره التي بثوها وهي كانت ليست فقط
بالقوه القطب السلطه التشريعيه اليوم التي
هي في البرلمانات والى اخره وانما كانت
الشريعه كحضاره والشريعه هي السلطه
التشريع في نفس الوقت فمثلا نعطيك مثال
بسيط عشان نفهم شو اللي عم نحكي عنه انه
اليوم اذا انت بدك
تخدم في الدوله لازم تدرس كتب وتروح على
مدارس القانون التي تعلم قانون الدوله
الدوله تقول لك شو ايش هاي القوانين فانت
لازم تصبح خادم الدوله بالمعنى الفردي
والشخصي وحتى الذاتي لكي تملا هذا
هذه الوظيفه تقوم بهذه الوظيفه ولكن في
التاريخ الاسلامي وحتى اخر يوم كان فيه
خلاف خليفه او سلطان في الاسلام
قضى عليه اتاتورك في تركيا
كان دائما الخليفه ورجال الخليفه واولاد
رجال الخليفه ونساء واولاد رجال الخليفه
وجميع الطاقم الذي يسمى
العائله الملكيه اليوم كان يدرس
ويتشرب
الحضاره الشرعيه في المجتمع فمثلا اولاد
الخلفاء والسلاطين من يعلمهم كان العلماء
ماذا يعلمهم القران والسنه والحديث
والتاريخ الاسلامي
والادب والى اخره
يعني الشريعه كانت المعلمه للسلاطين ولم
يكن بيت السلطان والبيت الخلافي يقرر في
قوانين والشعب لازم
يتبع زي ما احنا اليوم بنساوي في عنا طبقه
تحكم
الغنياء في امريكا والشركات
هي تقرر منهم الحكام والكل بيتبع وين
بتقول لهم يروحوا بروحوا هيك الشعب نقرا
كتب مثلا في هذا الموضوع مهم جدا
والى اخره
فالشريعه كانت كانت مسيطره سيطره تامه على
السلطه التشريعيه
[موسيقى]
كانت الدوله الامويه هذا الاطار اللي هي
انه نشات الشريعه في انشطه قامت السلطه
التشريعيه
وسودت
السلطه القضائيه بالاشخاص الذين يقومون
بهذه المهام يعني القضاه من غير تدخل في
لم يكن للدوله التدخل فيه لان هذه كانت
ظاهره اجتماعيه دينيه لم تكن ظاهره سياسيه
كيف بنقدر نقرا مثلا مثل اللي حصل في
مع خلق القران وقضيته مع احمد بن حنبل مع
السجن يعني كيف تقرا هذه وهي
انه كان السلطانه والخليفه له راي في
الشريعه
المحنه هي
محاوله يائسه لبعض
الخلفاء العباسيين الذين ظنوا انهم
يستطيعون ان يتملكوا الارض
ولكن لم المحنه لم تكن في الشريعه الشريعه
لم لم تكن موضع نقاش موضوع نقاش في المحنه
انما العقائد
عقائد وصول الدين خلق القران والى اخره
فقط
فاصبح ابن حنبل هذه بن حنبل برضو سجن على
قضيه فقهيه قضيه فقهيه
بسبب هاي الشغلات ابن تيميه عنده حياته زي
تشبه الحياه السهره وردي المقتول لانه
لانه
ربما انت تسجن لاشي زي كيف
من غير من ابن تيميه رجل عظيم جدا ولكن
انا منطي مثال على الحاله والوضع انه كيف
اليوم الدوله بدها تسقط تمسك واحد من
رؤساء المافيا
بتلاقي انه بقتلوا كذا بس ما تقدرش تمسك
عليهم اي ممسك فبروحوا بمسكوا عليهم اشي
في الضريبه الدخل
كيف ابن تيميه كان له اعداء كثير لاسباب
ثانيه اخرى لانه بنتها كان كان يحكي رايه
وبقوه زي ابن عبد السلام
ويهين السلطان لما مع انه كان صاحب مع بعض
المماليك الكبار ولكن احيانا كان كان شوي
طبعه قوي فكان مرات يحكي كلام فتربى اعداء
سياسيين كتير كتير بس لما يجوا يحكموا
عليه باشي طبعا هو قسم من من برنامج طويل
عريض مش راح يعزلوا كل المشاكل الاخرى
ويقولوا اه احنا بدنا بدنا نحكي بهاي
الشغله لا في في تعقيدات كثيره
الحلاج الحلاج قتل لاسباب اللي ما الها
علاقه فيه ليش بدهن
يختفي من
المشهد
لانه وقع في في وضع اللي سمح للوزير انه
يخلص عليه ولكن كان عندهم اسباب اخرى تاني
ترى انه في كل
الدول الاسلاميه العباسي
الامويه العباسيه العثمانيه انه ما كان في
هذا التدخل نهائيا في الشريعه زادت
كالسيد الاعلى فوق السلاطين ما هذه كمان
نقطه حازمه جدا انه الشريعه هي التي قررت
ما هي التركيبات السياسيه
والحكم في الاسلام
في
مقوله فكنت تقول وحده ان التصوف هو الشرح
الكلي للشريعه وان الاسلام يتك على بعدين
التصوف والشريعه
ايش تقصد بالتصوف هنا
التصوف هو
الاهتمام الاهتمام
الروح الجروح الجسدي وهنا الروح الجسدي في
بيناتهم شحطه يعني يجوا مع بعض بكلمه
واحده الروح الجسدي لتثقيف الشخصيه
الشرعيه يعني يعني لاحظ انت انه انه
الشريعه بديت في بعض المبادئ التصوف يعني
اذا بتطلع على التصوف متى خلينا نقول
الصوم طب الصوم كان في الشريعه من البدايه
مش بس في الشريعه كان في البدايه في
الاسلام موجود في القران الكريم
في كثير من كثير كثير كما نعرف جميعا في
الايات ودخل واحد من الاركان الخمسه والى
اخره والى اخره بس شو معناه الصوم صوم
يعني احنا ما بعدنا اليوم
بادين نفهم
عشر معشار معشار ماذا تعني مساله الصوم
والجوع في تثقيف الذاتيه الانسانيه بعد في
كتير لازم شغل يعني اذا عندي طلاب انا
بحاول انه اوجههم بهذا الدراسه ما معنى ما
معنى الصوم والجوع وكيف لهم علاقه في في
خلق ذاتيه خاصه لان كتير مهمه جدا فالمهم
انه
مثلا الصوفيه تاخذ مثلا التواضع والصوم
والسكوت وصمت
والمقامات والاحوال جميعها تاخذها
تعجبها تركيبها فعاله فعليه في تصرفات
الشخص الذي هو في الاخر يكون المثال
الاعلى
للذات الشرعيه عشان هيك مثلا ليش الغزالي
كتب احياء علوم الدين شو احياء علوم الدين
احياء علوم الدين هو
خلاصه المجهود الاسلامي من من القرنين او
اكثر السابقين لانه هو كتب الغزالي توفي
505 هجريه 1111 ميلاديه
فكان بدي التصوف هو في بغداد بالاساس هو
انتشر في مكان اماكن اخرى من بدايه القرن
الثالث الهجري وفي نهايه الهجره كان
تقريبا ملامحه واضحه
واصبح الرابع تطور اكثر واكثر ولما وصل
الغزاله كانت تصوف صار له اجرين وايدين
ويعني فعال في المجتمع وكثير مش مثل لاحقا
ولكن في كثير كان من المتصوفين والاقوياء
يعني السراء ابو نصر السراج والى
اخرهم اصواتهم عاليه
علوم الدين احياء علوم الدين هو جمع بين
الرجل التصوف والرجل الشريعه في قالب واحد
ورجل التصوف الشريعه هم الرجلين
بوقف عليهم الاسلام اكثر من اي اشي تاني
يعني كل اشي تاني انا بسموه بسميهن النطاق
المركزي
النطاق الشريعه والتصوف
نطاقان مركزيان في الاسلام ولكن الاشياء
الكثير من الاشياء مثل الرياضيات او اللي
كانت نطاق نطاق فرعي ليش لانه نطق الفرعي
يسند النطاق المركزي ويخدم اهدافه فمثلا
اليوم الفن
هو
نطاق
فرعي يخدم الراسماليه
طبعا فيه كتير اشياء فنيه واذوق فني وجمال
كما يقولون طبعا يعني لما انا ارسم هذه
اللوحات طبعا انا ما رسمتها لاسباب
الراسماليه طبعا انا ما بدي ابيعها لالي
هدول انا رسمتهم عشان احطهم في بيتي ولكن
وكثير من الفنانين من هالشكل ولكن في
الاخر قوه النطاق المركزي يقلب اولويات
النطاق الفرعي فمثلا خلينا نقول اذا
توفاني الله مثلا
وعندي انا بنت بنتي
مثلا تعرف كيف تسوق ممكن زي ما بصير كتير
ممكن يكون هاي ولا مره رسمات حلوات
تصبح مساله بيكاسو اليوم او او من هدول
الكبار لوحاتو وين موجوده موجوده على
يختات اللي
البليونير الروسي اشتراه لمين اشترى له
لصديقته لحبيبته
حطين شراره بكاس وحاط طفل فليش هاي يعني
تصوروا الفن كيف بيكاسو كتب
رسماته في باريس وفي مدريد او في بالاساس
في باريس بين 1905 لتنه توفي وشو كان يفكر
وكيف فنه اصبح قسم من النظام الراسمالي
شركات تامين تشتهيها وبتحطها في في في
قاعات البنايات الضخمه في طوكيو مثلا
لو كان الرسم يخدم الراسماليه يخدم
المركزيه اللي هي مثلا هنا الاسلام اذا
كان اذا كانه النطاق المركزيه نطاق اخلاقي
وهنا موضوع جديد في في المحادثه هذه ممكن
تاخذنا ساعات اذا كان ولكن اذا كان النطاق
المركزي هو نطاق اخلاقي معناته
لا يهمني انا كيف ممكن النطاقات الفرعيه
انها تتحول لانها تخدم بالاخر نطاق اخلاقي
هو النطاق الاخلاقي هو دائما نطاق انساني
يحتم انساني يهتم للانسان الداخل من جوه
مش جسمه ولكن من روحه وبعدين جسمه
روح هو نفسه وجسمه فالشريعه والتصوف هما
مركزان
اخلاقيا في الاساس يعني الشريعه هي هو ليس
في الاساس الشريعه ليست في الاساس جهاز
قانوني بالمناسبه بالمعنى لانه لما نقول
احنا جهاز قانون اليوم انا استعمل كلمه
حديثه اه في القانون ما كان في التراث
الاسلامي موجود
التركي اجا
كخيط ضعيف في مثل انه يزيد عقابات مثلا
الزنا والدعاره وكذا ولكن كان اجي
يثبت المبادئ الاساسيه للشريعه وسمو قانون
ولكن ليس بالقانون اليوم القانون معناته
هو
ال ال القانون هو الاحكام الشرعيه التي
تصدرها الدوله هي مسائل وضعيه سياسيه محطه
طيب فيها على الدوله كنت ذكرت في كتاب
الشريعه انه
الدوله العثمانيه هي اول
دوله تختار مذهبا لها حنفيه
ايش اثر اختيار المذهب الواحد على الدوله
وعلى التشريع اوكي
ليش
العثمانيين مش قبلهم مثلا
المماليك كانوا قبلهم في مصر وسوريا كان
عندهم اربعه مش بس واحد او اثنين كان
قالوا لا الاربع مذاهب لازم يكون لهم
تمثيل واحنا عنا قاضي القضاه في كل واحد
في الاربعه اجل
العثمانيين العثمانيين فقالوا لا المذهب
الحنفي فقط لكن لازم تنظر انه باي
باي نطاق
قامت الدوله العثمانيه العثامنه
مع الدول مع الدوله الصفويه
والمغاليه ثلاث امبراطوريات اسلاميه
من اقوى الامبراطوريات في هذا ذلك الوقت
يعد ويسموهم امبراطوريات البارود
لانه كانوا يستعملوا المفروض في اول مره
استعملوا استوردوا واستعملوا البارود
والبندقيات القديمه
ولكن هذا الاسم ليس مساله وصف لاستعمال
اسلحه فقط وانما وصف لامبراطوريات اسلاميه
وغير اسلاميه جديده
بدات تشتغل بشكل اخر في الحكم السياسي
فهناك مثلا فرق من بدايه الاسلام وحتى
المماليك كان في نوع من الاستمراريه معينه
وكان في قفزه نوعا ما
يعني بالمقارنه مع القناه التاسع عشر تعد
صغيره قفزه صغيره اللي كان فيها اجا فيها
بعدها
الثامنه
والصفوي والى اخره ليش
كله هذا التطورات صارت في ما يسمى
في نطاق التاريخ العالمي
هذا حقل في الدراسات
تاريخ العالم كله لانه المؤرخ ممكن يدرس
قريه جنب حلب في سوريا او حلب نفسها او
خلص هذا تاريخ صغير
بس ممكن يدرس الاسلام او حتى الاسلام
المملوكه بس
اووي ولكن عندك ورد هيستوري اللي هو بشوف
الخارطه العامه لشو كانوا كل الدول تساوي
كيف تؤثر على بعضها وكيف تتعامل مع بعضها
ومين اثر على مين
عشان هيك اللي بقول لك انا بدرس بس قريه
معينه ومثلا
ممارسات الزواج في قريه كذا في شمال الصين
صحتين على قلبك الله يخليك ويوفقك ولكن ما
بتعرف كتير لانك انت محصور بها الا اذا
بتقدر تقارن وتشوف يعني لا بد من دائما من
المقارنه مع اشياء يعني دراسات المقارنه
اهداء هو علم جديد في العقل البشري يعني
اذا انا بضل بدونه بكون عقلي اشي وبس
استورده لعقلي وابدا اقارن عقلي راح يتطور
بخطوات شاسعه
مقارنه مهمه جدا انا هذا قسم كل كل مشروعي
العلمي من اول لاخره هو دائما انه كل ما
اغطي منطقه بروح على منطقه ثانيه شبيهه
فيها موازيه لها في حضاره تانيه بشوف كيف
صارت
عشان اعرف شو النسبيه هاي
القضيه الحقل الاول اللي درسته اللي هو
الشريعه بالنسبه الي
المقارنات مهمه جدا جدا
السؤال كان عفوا
الى الحديث عن
اختيار الدوله العثمانيه
فاحنا شردنا في موضوع موضوع ميثادولوجي
يعني منهجي
ولكن
العثمانيين اجوا كرد فعل قسم منه كرد فعل
للتوسعات الاوروبيه الاولى يعني لما قاموا
العثمانيين هو كان
العصر النهضه في اوروبا كان ماشي التجار
اللي كان عم بيصير بايطاليا في هذاك الوقت
وايطاليا يعني جنب كتير قريبه على اللي عم
بصير في ايطاليا وفي اسبانيا بهداك الوقت
كان كان مهم جدا جدا والعثمانيين كان
دائما الهن اجر في اوروبا واجر في اسيا من
قبل احتلال الدول العربيه من قبل ما اخدوا
مصر وفلسطين وسوريا
لما لما بجيوا يطوروا مثلا تطلع على مين
السلاطين العثمانيين تقريبا اغلب امهاتهم
تقريبا الغالبيه العظمى من امهات السلاطين
العثمانيين والذين حكموا مع اولادهم مع
ازواجهم بشكل بشكل قوي جدا يعني النساء
القصر الملكي في الاسلام لهم كان اهميه
كبيره وتاثير كبير في الحكم فمثلا سليمان
القانوني مين مرته كانت اوكرانيه مسيحيه
تزوجها وطبعا اسلمت
وخلف منها اولاد واصبحت شريكي في الحكم
معه سليمان العظيم هذا سليمان القانوني
يعني لما بتروح على السليمانيه وبتزور
السليمانيه في اسطنبول بتكون ما شاء الله
انه هذا هذا من اعظم رجالي وهو فعلا كان
من اعظم ولكن امراته مهمه جدا كمان فكل هو
واولاده مين امهن هي رخصانا
العثمانيين كانوا يبعتوا جواسيس يشوفوا
ايش احدث مدفعه بنون الاوروبيين عشان
يبنوا زيه في اسطنبول فيعني اذا بتدرس
التاريخ العسكري
العثماني بتلاقيه انه كلياتهم مليء بانه
الامبراطوريه كانت مش بس هي كانت تشتري
مهندسين نمساويين وسويديين تجيبهم تشتريهم
كلهم تعالوا اسطنبول شو بتساوي في في
بتربحوا في اوروبا وبس ساعدونا نبني نبني
هذا النوع من المدفع يعني كانوا كتير
فكانت ردود فعلهم كانوا يعرفوا شو عم بصير
في اوروبا فشو اوروبا ايش الواحد من
الصفات الاساسيه
لدخول اوروبا في الحضاره في الحداثه اللي
احنا بنعرفها هو
مركزه السياسي يعني اصبح كل اشي
متمركز في محل واحد اللي سموه بالانجليزي
سنترال انه كل اشي عليه لانه التاريخ
الاوروبي هو نشا من الحاكم من الملك كانوا
يسموه الحاكم المطلق لانه هو يشرع كان
الحكم الملكي هو كان الملك يكون انا انا
اتكلم بالنيابه عن الله
اللي كانوا يسموه الحكم المطلق في اوروبا
هو هيك لما كان انا انا ممثل الله على
الارض
فالقانون هو انا كما قال
لويس الرابع عشر
وانا من انا ممثل عن الله اتكلم بسم الله
الاوروبيين العثمانيين ما بيقدروش كانوا
هاي الشغله ليه لانه عندك الاسلام عندك
مجتمع اسلامي تقول هيك بكل
الاسره العثمانيه راح تنفى وقت راح تقوم
عليها كل الشعوب الاسلاميه
اربع مذاهب وتعقيدات كثيره ومشاكل كثيره
وكان في بعض المشاكل لما بتكون انت عندك
تعدديه المذاهب هالقد في حريه في القانون
بدك تدفع سعرها
بعد شوي صغيره
فقالوا من من من من منزل الثلاث مذاهب
الاخرى لتحت بالمعنى مش بمعنى السلبي
بمعنى انه يحكم عليهن ويدار اداريا يداروا
من قبل مذهب
من اسطنبول يعين قاضي القضاه وخلينا نقول
قاضي قدر مصر فيذهب من اسطنبول الى
القاهره ومن القاهره هو يعين في القاهره
وفي الاسكندريه والى اخره والى اخره يعين
من يعين قضاه حسب المن يسكن هذه البلد
فاذا كان في البلد حنابله فيعطوهم كان في
كثير كان يعطيهم مثلا اكثر من قاضي حنبله
واحد واذا كان فيه
شافعيه والى اخره والى اخره
مش انه اختلفوا ولكن الاداره الاداره
الشرعيه العثمانيه اصبحت مركزت في يد
اسطنبول واسطنبول انتجت المذهب الحنفي فقط
وقاضي القضاه يكون الحنفي
تكون حنفي هذه القضاه دائما هو
الناظر
الناظر الذي يتفحص الامور كيف كان اثر هذا
الفكره او هذا التغير على العالم الاسلامي
التغير انه انه
ليس تغير
كيفي وانما تغير كمي
وطبعا اذا كان الكم يزداد عن حده يصبح
كيفي صحيح يعني الكيف والكم هم ليس ليس
نوعيه مختلفتان فاذا انت عندك عندك انت
وعاء من الدهان الابيض بتحط فيه نقطه
واحده حمراء
وبتدوروا بضل ابيض بتحط نقطتين بدل ابيض
بتحط 100 نقطه بضل تقريبا ابيض حط فنجان
بصير زهر بس اذا بتدب عليه عشر اضعاف احمر
بصير احمر وببط الابيض صحيح فالنوع والكم
مربوطين مع بعض
الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه كان عندها نوع من الكم الذي لم
يصبح كيف
ولكن هل كم
لاحقا لاحقا في القرن التاسع عشر بعد
1826 اصبح له اهميه
التغييرات هاي مثلا مركزت الشريعه في
اداريا في المذهب الحنفي
وتقسيم السناجق
والامبراطوريه بطريقه معينه وضرب وجمع
الضرائب بطريقه معينه كلها كانت هاي تحاول
انها
تسويها بطريقه ناجحه عشان ايش عم تتعلم من
اوروبا مش انه كانت خايفه من اوروبا
كانت ضعيفه جدا ولكن لما بتشوف انت جارك
حتى بخترع مثلا سلاح جديد وحتى انت انك
اقوى منه 100 مره بدك تعرف شو بساوي جارا
من منطقه قوه فكانوا ياخذوا من كمان اشياء
من اوروبا اللي واحده منها انه
يسهلوا اداره الامبراطوريه عن طريقه
ولكن في
1826 اول مره
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه واجهت وجدت نفسها
في مازق شديد جدا انه من
1700 وسبعين ثمانين
لحديث 1800 وشوي واكثر بعدين ولكن انا
بحكي عن هديك الفتره بس قبل 1826 روسيه
القيصريه كانت تضرب
العثمانيين تكسرهم كسره بعد كسره كل حرب
تقريبا
الروسي يفوزوا بالاول كانوا العثمانيين
يفوزوا مثلا المناطق اللي متنازع عليها
اليوم بين اوكرانيا وروسيه
ولكن القرم والى اخره ولكن ولكن بعد في
هذه الفتره
خسرت
الامبراطور عثمان حرب بعد حرب لدرجه انه
دمرتها اقتصاديه
فبدات في اصلاحات داخليه فاصلحت الجيوش
الكل الجهاز العسكري تبعتها قبل 1826 بس
1826 انتهت المرحله الاولى في الاصلاح
الجيش
مهمه جدا جدا ولكن كان في هناك
تغيير جذري يدخل في في الكيف ليس فقط في
الكم انه لاول مره في التاريخ الاسلامي
اول مره في التاريخ الاسلامي
تقول الدوله ان الاوقاف الاسلاميه الكبيره
والمهمه
تابعه على اسطنبول للعاصمه
في التاريخ الاسلامي الاوقاف دائما مستقله
هي التي لها ميزانياتها وهي التي اقتصادها
وادارتها مشرف عليها القاضي بالمناسبه كل
سنه يجي يشوف الكتب بالحسابات والى اخره
اللي الها فيها بضل فيها هسه شو صار بالف
كل الاوقاف تبعت مدخولها للعاصمه والعاصمه
بتقارن قديش يرجع للاوقاف
بطلت كل واحد عنده كل وقف عنده ميزانيته
اصبحت ميزانيته خاضعه لتدخل الدوله
وبديت الامور اكثر واكثر للشريعه من
يومتها فاذا انت اخذت الوقف من من ايدين
الشريعه قتلت الشريعه الوقف كان في هداك
الوقت مش في البدايه بالبدايه الشريعه بنت
حالها من غير وقف ولكن لاحقا بس بديت
القرن الخامس الهجري يعني في عندك
النظاميات في في بغداد اللي انشا النظام
الملك الوزير السلجوك المشهور من هناك
اصبح شلال في التاريخ الاسلامي في بنايه
الاوقاف يمينا ويسارا
بالمناسبه لما دخلوا
الصليبيين على اخر هن تعلموا انشاء او
انشاء
كلياتهم في بولونيا وفي باريس ولندن من
من المسلمين الجامعات
الكولومبيا هي نسخه محدثه يعني حديثه من
المدرسه النظاميه في اسطنبول في عفوا
بغداد
[موسيقى]
فهذا اللي
كان اول تدخل بانه ماخذ الاوقاف
للدوله العثمانيه فسيطروا على الاوقاف
وبعد ذلك دخلت مرحله حوالى عشرين سنه دخلت
مرحله ما يسمى بالتنظيمات ولكن التنظيمات
برايي انا بديت في 1826 مش 1856 تنظيمات
هي بدايه بدايه
تغريب البنيه التحتيه للامبراطوريه
العثمانيه تغريب بالمعنى انه تصبح الغرب
فالقوانين الاسلاميه بدات تزاح على جنب
صاروا يجيبوا القوانين الجرائم والعقوبات
من المانيا
قانون الكذا من فرنسا قانون من ايطاليا
ويحطوهم بدل محل الشرائع الاسلاميه وبديت
اولها بشكل جذري بده 1852 اول خطوه ولكن
الوقف
ومصادرات الاوقاف يعني بالمعنى اللي انا
حكيت عنهم ليست مصادره التقليديه
هذا 26
هي كانت الخطوه الاولى اللي اضطرت الارض
كما يقال طرت الارض
لنسف
القسم من الشريعه الاسلاميه والقوانين
الاسلاميه بالخمسينات من القرن التاسع عشر
وبعدها بداوا بانشاء كليات حقوق على طراز
الاوروبي
وانشاء جيل جديد اللي هو اللي هو له علاقه
في في القانون الغربي والتطبيق القانون
الغربي
عفوا وهنا حصل تقنين الشريعه في هذه
الشريعه لم يحصل الا لاحقا ولكن ولكن هذه
بدايه هو المجله هي نوع من التقنين ولكن
نتكلم عن التمرين ربما لاحقا لانه شوي
معقد اكثر من هيك
خلينا نرجع شويه صغيره ل 1826 شو صار مع
الاوقاف
فاسال الاوقاف كلها هاي
مدخولها ذهب لاسطنبول
ترجع قسم صغير بس منه وتاخذ الباقي تصرفه
على الحروب وعلى اشياء اخرى
فاساء
[موسيقى]
المدارس الجديده اللي هي مدارس قانونيه
جديده اصبحت تدرب اشخاص اللي لما يروحوا
يتخرجوا ياخذوا مناصب قويه وفي نفس الحين
شو صار
الفلوس اللي ترجع على العلماء والتقليديين
اللي كانوا اصحاب الشريعه نزلت من من من
نسبتها الاولانيه لعشرين و15% شو كانوا
ياخذوا فتصور
انه الصين تحت الامريكا
في امريكا
خصبه
رغوه
القانون في امريكا هم بالاساس المدربين
الاساسيين هم مثلا المدارس الكليات الحقوق
المعروفه في
كولومبيا
واربعه خمسه ثانيه
طيب احنا بتطلع على مثلا
شو بساوي بعملوا
هناك خلينا نقول بين 3500 الف دولار اليوم
معاشاتهم هذه
بين صغير والكبير خلينا نكون معدل بين
3500 الف تصور الصين تقول احنا راح نخلق
مدارس قانونيه جديده في امريكا
وراح نخليها هي الفعاله وتقرر شو بصير في
السوق القانوني والشرعي في المحاكم والى
اخره وبندفع للهدولا
300 الى 500 الف بس
بدنا ننزل معاشاتهم
هذا بالضبط اللي صار في في القرن التاسع
عشر في الاسلام
اذا بتاخذ استاذ في هارفد في كليه الحقوق
في هارفد اللي كان
مبسوط ومرفه وبعمل فلوس منيح واله اسم
كبير هذا الشخص
راح يبعت او تبعته واولاده او اولادها
لنفس الهذا لا راح اقول لك انا هاي خلص
احنا نازلين في الهواء ببعتها وين ببعتها
على المدارس الجديده لانه اولادك ضلعك
كبدك بدك تبعته لوين احسن شيء
فتصور تدهورت المدارس الفقهيه وبدات في
التلاشي لدرجه انه
ب 1860 الف
وثمانمكترت انكترت
اخر الناس كتبوا على الطريقه الفقهيه
القديمه والاسلوب القديم والطريقه الجدليه
القديمه
توقفوا
وبدات كتابه جديده ضحله
غير عميقه ولا تعرف شيء عن الماضي فيعني
لما صار في قضاه في مصر وبال 1920 بداوا
اللي صار عندي مشكله انه يقروا
الفقه اصبحوا عندهم صعوبه في قراءه الفكر
وفهمه يعني الى درجه اعطيك مثال شوي مبالغ
فيه انه انا تكلمت مره في صغري ولما كنت
استاذ صغير بعدني
اجتمعت في في من غير اسماء اجتمعت في
حينها
القادر الرئيسي في محكمه العليا الدستوريه
في مصر في لندن كنا نتكلم في الشارع
فبقول لي ايش انت الشريعه يعني اه انا
فاهم عليك بس شو شريعه
هدول الجماعه
بكت متلاصم الواحد يعني مش انا مش غادر
احط يعني
مش فاهم كيف بكتبوا كيف شو الفقه عنده
صعوبه في انه لدرج بالنسبه له طلاسم
قلت له مش الي انا بالنسبه لي مش راسم
بالنسبه للمنطق منطق باهر كيف كيف التركيب
الجدل الفقهي يعني زي ما بنكون في فلسطين
بمخول العقل
فهذا اللي اثر عليه اللي صار في الدوله
العثمانيه من هذه خطوه نوعيه من الدرجه
الاولى هذه غيرت غيرت ليس فقط الجهاز
القانوني والشرعي في الامبراطوريه واصبح
قانوني الان قال يصبح جهاز قانوني وليس
شرعي بالرغم كل
التزييفات
والمصادرات من الشريعه في قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه والتي ليست لها علاقه كبيره
بالفقه الاسلامي لانها غيروا كثير
وركبوا التلفيق ما هو التلفيق تلفيق من
احد اهم الادوات
للاصلاح الحديث اللي بدا بالاساس من 1917
في الامبراطوريه العثمانيه 1917 في قانون
العائله
فصاروا يجيبوا لك من حتى من الفقه الشيعي
ويحطون مع الفقه المالكي ربع من هنا وثلث
من هنا ومش عارف يحطوه مع بعض ويقول لك
هذا هو القانون مين اللي قرر هيك على اي
اساس اي فقيه جاب كل هدول وحطهم مع بعض
بشكل لا مش مهم المهم احنا احنا الدوله
واحنا بنقرر شو هو الفقه يعني لما انت
تجيب من هنا من هون وتقول انه هذا هو من
غير تسيير من غير تفنيد الفقه كله مفند كل
قول له تفنيد والتفنيد احيانا يكون عالم
في فن التفكير يعني لما تقرا انت النووي
وتشوف لما اعترض على الشافعي حتى انه يا
عمي مزبوطه انت نتيجه الشافع بقاله
الشافعي النتيجه تبعتك هون مزبوطه صحيحه
ولكن طريقه تفنيدك خطا او انه مش كامله او
انه فيها نقص فيدخل في كل التفسير ليش
الشافعي لم يكمل هذا التمرين الرياضي في
الفقه الذي ينتج هذه النتيجه والنتيجه في
القول في المساله تصور
فهذا كله اختفى ما في تفنيد ولا في شيء
خلص انه المراه يحق لها كذا كذا في العقد
كذا كذا
لانه احنا قلنا هيك طب ايش التركيب
المنطقيه تبعتها مش مهم لا في اجتهاد ولا
في ترجيح ولا في تخريج ولا في اي شيء هذا
لانه احنا كنا لانه هذه احنا دوله عشان
كده انت تقول انه القرن التاسع عشر كان
قرن مفصلي في تاريخ الشريعه اصبحت الدوله
العثمانيه في اخر القرن التاسع عشر وبدايه
العشرين الدوله حديثه ليست دوله اسلاميه
ولما اقول دوله حديثه انا اول شيء مش عم
بعطي مدح
لنكون ولكن في نفس الوقت انا لا اقول انه
دوله حديثه بالمعنى الزمني انه حديثه يعني
لا حديثه يعني تعبير عن الحداثه التي هي
ظاهره نوعيه خاصه
فلذلك في فرق شاسع بين ما يسمى بالحكم
الاسلامي وما يسمى بالدوله الحديثه
وهذا ولا يمكن هذا موضوع كتاب الدوله
المستحيل كنت تشوف انه لا يمكن ان تكون
دوله حديث الدوله الاسلاميه
بالمعنى الحديثه انه انه انه تركيبه
حداثيه اوروبيه لان هي الدوله الحديثه هي
دوله اوروبيه يعني يعني حتى في الصين
اليوم اللي هي اكثر الدول المبدعه في خلق
مجالات سياسيه واجتماعيه
من
لا شيء وبعدين من
معطيات داخليه وخاصه في الصين لن تهرب من
من تهرب من التركيبات الدوله الحديثه
طيب عن الحداثه ودائما لو دخلنا على
الحداثه او الدوله الحديثه اخذ مفهوم
الحداثه فكنت تقول ان الحل لمشكله الحداثه
هو فهم علاقه كل شيء بكل شيء
لان كل شيء متصل ببعض صحيح ايش تقصد انت
تعطيني
خليني اسالك هذا السؤال
ايش من اهم طرق الحكم اذا بتفوت بتفوت على
بلد فيه قبائل قبائل
مثلا خلينا نقول لما الانجليز راحوا على
امريكا
ايش كان اهم سلاح عندهم عشان يسيطروا على
الارض فصاروا يعملوا
بيعملوا حلف مع قبائل يغروهم بشيء عشان
يساعدهم او عشان يكونوا في حرب على
اخوانهم قبائل اخرى اللي هي ايش اسمها فرق
تسد
تفريق هو سلاح من اقوى الاسلحه في السيطره
على شيء
اذا كانك بدك تواجه عشرين شخص طبعا واضح
جدا بس بعطيك مثال عشان نفهم اهميته راح
يتغلبوا عليك بس اذا كانك تاخذهم واحد ورا
واحد خلاص تقدر اذا كانت قوي كفايه تقتلهم
كلياتهم
[موسيقى]
الحداثه
هدفها الاساسي بديت واستمرت وما زالت
تستمر حسب منطقه السيطره
السيطره على كل شيء واهم شيء السيطره على
الطبيعه ولكن بما انه الانسان قسم من
الطبيعه فهو سيطره الانسان على الانسان
انا كما قلت في
قصور الاستشراق
ان اوروبا استعمرت نفسها قبل ما تستعملها
العالم
دخلت في مشروع تحويل الذات الاوروبيه من
ذات دينيه طبعا اوروبا عندها مشاكل عندها
كان مشاكل اكثر من اي محل اخر في العالم
لانه المسيحيه في اوروبا كانت
معفنه كانت فاسده وكانت قاسيه وليست رئه
صحيح بدين الدين يجب ان يكون متسامح وعطوف
المسيحيه في اوروبا كانت عنيفه جدا انا لا
الوم الاوروبيين
لانهم كانوا يريدون ان يخرجوا من العصر
المسيحي والعصر
القيصري يعني
العصر الملكي المطلق الابسولوتيزم
لانهم عانوا كثيرا انا ليس عندي اعتراض
لان مسيحيه الاوروبيه هي ليست ليس لها
مشروعيه ولم وكان لم يجب ان لم تقم في من
البدايه
انا لا اقول المسيحيه بشكل عام ولكن
المسيحيه اوروبيه لانه مثلا انا اعرف
بشكل جيد ما كيف تمارس المسيحيه مثلا في
البلاد العربيه
مسيحيه
المسيحيه البلاد الاسلاميه هي شيء ومسيحيه
في اوروبا اشياء اخرى فهناك ذاتيه تختلف
اختلافا تاما الاوروبي قد جلب
التقاليد والاعراف القديمه الاوروبيه الى
المسيحيه في اوروبا وخربها
ولكن لا نستطيع ان نقول ذلك على
المسيحيين في العالم الاسلامي لانه
المسيحيين في العالم الاسلامي تشربوا
القيم الاسلاميه كمان
فكان عندهم نظره تختلف للدين يعني
المسيحيه في العالم الاسلامي برغم
مسيحيتها هي اقرب في النظر الى الوجود
الى الاسلام من المسيحيه اوروبا
وهذا الشيء قليل من الاشخاص يفهمونه ليه
لانه تسهل التعميم سهل مسيحي مسيحي سهل
الواحد يقول مسيحي ولكن المسيحي اي مسيحي
فكانوا بدهم يخروا لكن لما خرجوا
حاولوا في البدايه وبعدين نجحوا بينهم
يخرجوا من وقعوا في نفس
الورطات التي تركوها فاصبحت اصبحت
الابتزازات
والشناعات المسيحيه الكاثوليكيه في اوروبا
اصبحت معلمه ودخلت في حيز الدوله ومارست
نفس الاضطهاد ضد المواطن كمان مارست
المسيحيه فكما قال
فيلسوف الماني شهير برغم انتمائه للنازيه
والى اخره ولكن افكاره كانت كان عقله باهر
جدا قال ان كل مفهوم سياسي مهم في الحداثه
اليوم هو مفهوم محول من
الكاثوليكيه الى اللغه العلمانيه
فمثلا كان الله في
المسيحيه هو الحاكم الاعلى
فحولوا الله الى الدوله
كان كان الله هو الله فاصبح الانسان هو
الله يحكم باسم الله في البدايه ولاحقا
يقول ليس انا لا احكم باسم الله ولكن انا
المرجع الاخير في الحكم اي الانسان تقصد
هنا الانسان الانسان
هنا ندخل في مساله اخرى كيف يستعمل كيف
يستعمر شعب نفسه
مثلا من من من اشهر العقائد او الفلسفات
في نظام حكم في النظام الفلسفي في ماركس
الفيلسوف الشهير بغض النظر عن كيف تفسروه
الى اخره ولكن
فيلسوف محترم زي الفلاسف الاخرى في عندهم
اراء بتناسبك في اراء بتناسب
لا تقع في تناقض هذا الشرط الاساسي
بقول انه في كل مجتمع لازم يكون في عندك
انت ناس اللي
يسيطروا على تنين في فهو عرف السيطره عن
طريق الماديه
اللي معه فلوس معه مصاري
هو اللي بيقدر
يتحكم في جهاز الاجتماعي السياسي فيصبح
القائد متى نطلع اكبر برهان عليه وشو عم
بيصير في الولايات المتحده اليوم اللي
المفروض تكون المثال الاعلى للديمقراطيه
في العالم
عندك حزبين
ومين اللي بقرر انه هذا هو الممثل للحزب
انه يفوت في الانتخابات معه فلوس
ومين منين بجيب الفلوس من الشركات والى
اخره عشان هيك مثلا اسرائيل عندها دعم
مخيفه انا مسيطره على
البيت الابيض
في في في في كل السياسه الامريكيه تعتمد
اعتماد رئيسي وساحق
على مساله
القوه السياسيه والقوه الاقتصاديه من اللي
معه الفلوس ولا معه الاسلحه السياسيه وكيف
اثر هذا لانه
معناته معناته ايش معناته انه في عندك
طبقه مثلا مش رح تلاقي في امريكا
شخص عادي
اللي بالاخر يصير عادي عادي يعني يصير
رئيس
الامريكي من غير ما تتمناه الشركات
انه هو يصير لحاله انه يتصوتوله لانه هو
عنده عنده تعبير
دقيق وصحيح ومخلص لاماني واماني الشعب
الامريكي هذا هذا لم يحصل الان
وطبعا كل ما بمرق الوقت اكثر كل ما تسوى
القصه
فهذا اثبات على حكي ماركس فيعني هون في
عندك انت طبقه اللي تستعمل قانون اللي
تغير الشعب الذي يصبح هو لاحقا قسم منه هو
الحاكم وهذا الدائره تستمر في الدوران
تقول انه من عمر 950 الى 1970 شكل الانسان
كموضوع حداثه
نفسيا ومعرفيا ودهنيا وروحيا
كيف كان الانسان قبل 1950 بتوقف وين بس بس
كان في اشياء كتير مشتركه
قبل ذلك الانسان كان حتى في اوروبا
الانسان قبل القرن السابع عشر في اوروبا
وقبل الثامن عشر والتاسع عشر في جميع
انهار العالم توقف وين
الانسان كان له علاقه في تربيته ونشاته
وتكوين ذاتيته من هو السؤال من انت كانسان
كان له علاقه مات في القيم الاخلاقيه
ولكن ما حدث في اوروبا بعد القرن السابع
عشر كان له لاحقا تاثير على العالم جميعا
والان وصلنا لمرحله خطيره جدا في انه حتى
الشعوب الغير اوروبيه حتى في الصين
واليابان وافريقيا وباسيا تقريبا
بسبب التواصل الاجتماعي العولمه
ساصبح هناك نوع من
النسق الواحد للتركيب الذاتي
وكان واحد صغير وواحد اكبر والناس تروح
تشتري وتروح
15 سنه لاحقا
كان في عندك يمكن 20 مجمع تجاري كبار كبار
البلد كل واحد بحجم بلد
واصبحت جيل الصغير بين 13 وال 18 19
يعيشون هناك
يعني يروحوا من الصبح للكل همهم واللي
دخلت عليهم بعدين التواصل الاجتماعي فكل
اللي يهم الاشخاص اليوم هو ليس تنميه
النفس من الداخل وانما من الخارج فقط ليس
هناك اعتناء في الداخل ليس هناك تقنيات
تقنيات التي يمارسها الشخص على نفسه في
تكوين شخص شخصيه ذاتيه اخلاقيه
فهذا هذا هنا اهميه الصوفيه في الشريعه
كما حتى انه كانت تهتم للداخل كتير كتير
اكتر من مشاريعها تمت تمت الشريعه ولكن لم
تكفي فدخلوا عليها صوفيا اليوم ما في
اهتمام فلاحظ انت ايش ايش
الشاب المثالي هو اللي بروح على بتمرن على
عضلات
وقصه شعر على اخر طرز وبلبس
شو بسموه
ما في اهتمام لداخل تماما بالمره هذا كله
وعايش وين عايش بين بين بين المطعم
والحفلات
وربما على اغلب الاحوال المشروب
كحول وزيارات الشواطئ والاخره هذا كل انا
لا ليست عندي اعتراضات على هذا كلياته
تقدر تساوي انت تروح على الشط قد ما بدك
وتزور وتلبس حلو ما في فيه اي اشي غلط
ولكن هذا يكون قسم من موازنه كبيره تبدا
في الاعتناء في الداخل في الاول عشان هيك
الفلسوف الفرنسي المشهور
قضى حياته الناس ساءت فهمه لفكوك قضت قضى
حياته انه يدرس
ما هي العوامل
والظروف التي تنتج ذاتيات مختلفه
فدرس السجن مثلا الحديث كيف السجن الحديث
ينتج ذاتيه معينه ولكن قضى اكثر حياه سنين
حياته ايش يدرس ايش يدرس
التاريخ اليوناني
الروماني في كيف حتى
الامبراطوريات باطره الرومان حتى كيف
اهتموا
لتطوير الانسان من الداخل ما سماه هو
بالتكنولوجيا تقنيات الذات
فتقريات ذات هذا مش شيء اللي بيجيك من برا
وهو يفرض عليك هذا لا اشي اختياري
هذا اشي اختياري انت انت بتختار انه انا
بدي اصلي وبدي اصوم وبدي بدي بدي اصمت وما
اتفلسفش كثير وما احكيش وما كانه انا
الوحيد اللي في الغرفه
هذا كلياته هاي قيم اللي اللي
تصنع الذات
تكنولوجي ضد السلف
هو سؤاله انه هذه توقفت في القرن الثامن
عشر تماما اضمحلط كما قال واترجم انا من
الفرنسيه اضمح الله
والان انا اعرفها وبزدياد الوقت ومرور
الوقت تتلاشى اكثر لدرجه انه احنا اصبحت
عنا قصه غامضه ولكن في تقنيات ذات هذه
التي مارسها المسلمون وغيرهم اليونان
والهنود والصينيين هناك نرجع لي اول دقائق
من هذا من هذا من هذه المقابله هناك نوع
من الحريه التي لا نعرفها اليوم قد
نسيناها نسيانا كاملا واثرت على الانسان
اليوم طبعا لانها خلقت انسان لا يعرف اي
معنى حريه الا الحريه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه
هنا بقوسين لانه مش حريه مزبوطه يعني انك
تروح تصوت مش مش بدايات ونهايه القصه صوت
لمين صوت
اللي هو وليد العنف الاقتصادي الامريكي
والنصب والاحتيال والى اخره والى اخره
ويصبح رئيس في امريكا طبعا انا ما استحقي
في التصويت لا بس لايش لاي هدف لاي
طيب
بس مع ذلك اليوم نقدر نشوف يعني اعتقد انك
على اطلاع بظهور فكره التامل ولا
البودزم
العالم
مركز التصوف وهو بعيد عن الاسلام يعني
فحضور الروحي اصبح حاضر اليوم
كالعالم
انا كثير سعيد انك اثرت هذه النقطه لانها
نقطه كتير مشكله
زي ما بنقول احنا في الشرق تبعنا
مليان المشاكل اوكي هناك
ناخذ الطب
كقياس تمثيلي ناخذ الطب
في عندك طريقتين في التعامل مع الجسم
الجسم كماده بس انت الروحي شوي
في عندك الطريقه الغربيه انه كله يشرب شو
بدك
وكل الصناعات اللي تصنعها الشركات الاكل
الكبيره يعني هذا اللي بدنا اياه انت
بالنسبه الهن مش مهم الا كاداه اقتصاديه
تدفع تشتغل وتدفع وتخلي هالعجل يدور
وبعدين لما تمرض بتروح على المستشفى او
بحكمك الدكتور
فمثلا اذا عندك تيك توك للاكل بصير عندك
مساله حوامل في المهدي
اعطوك دواء للحوامل بتخمد الحوامل انت
مبسوط تروح تاكل شو بدك كمان اكثر حتى
لانه فش عندك حوامل
راحت الحمامه من المعده
بس شو اجت اجت السرطان في الامعاء الغليظ
وبتروح على المستشفى فهنا شو ساوى فيك
الشركه باعتك الاكل اكلت شو بدك ودفعوك
فيها
ومردوك ورحت على المستشفى ودفعت اكثر عشان
تتعالج هذا المنطق الراسمالي الاقتصاد
وهذا منطق الطب تبعنا اليوم
فما في اهتمام
لانك انت
انه انه شخص يعتني خذ الحكمه الصينيه
الحكمه الصينيه تختلف تماما
الحكم الصينيه مش حكمه معالجه انما حكمه
وقايه بقول لك انه احسن احسن حل للمرض
وانك متمردش فعشان هيك لازم تاكل كذا كذا
كذا تشرب كذا كذا كله مفيد هائل في الجسم
ولازم
تلعب رياضه وكذا ومش رياضه عنيفه مثل
اليوم اللي بسوى حتى رياضات بسيطه يعني
ليش الفظيع مثلا في الكاراتيه لانك انت مش
بحاجه ولا تشتري اي شيء لا تقال ولا اشي
كله بجسمك تعمل معجزات
فهذا خذ اللي انت حكيت عنه
في في عندك
في فرق كبير بين الوقايه والعلاج
العلاج اللي هو بسموه ثيرابي في الغرب
واحد مشهور جدا هذا من اهم الكتب التي
كتبت برايي في اخر اخر في القرن العشرين
هو
من قبل كاتب اسمه
فيلب ريف
احنا حضرتنا اليوم حضاره انه بتمرض
وعندك كل المساعدات انك تمرض نفسيا وبعدين
بعد ما تمرض بتروح بتشوف دكتور نفساني
بتروح تعمل يوجا بتروح بتدخل بتصير عضو في
مركز الصوفي في نيويورك
هذا كله من بعد ما كلش تدهور بس شو بتصير
بتصير التصوف خلينا نبقى في التسوف لانه
زي اليوغا زي اشي تاني فلما تروح انت على
المركز الصوفي هنا في نيويورك ليش انت عم
بتساوي انت عم بتحاول تساوي زي ما بتساوي
باليوجا ما هو الماء ما ما شو الوضع يعني
هنا انك انت مريض بعيد عن السهله انه
الواحد مريض وبروح على
مريض نفسيا مريض جسمانيه مريض التنين مع
بعض بده يلاقي علاج عن طريق الهدوء
والسكينه
النفس التي تجلب الها اللحظات القليله في
المركز الصوفي ولكن لما بترك المركز
الصوفي وحتى بترك بيته من بعد ما عمل
[موسيقى]
في بيته 15 او 20 دقيقه هو يواجه
جهاز عالمي جهاز في العالم بره بريه البيت
الذي يوقع يوقع في مشكله وفي صدمه وفي مش
عارف ايش في كل ساعه ترجع البيت تكون بدي
يوجا فهذا هاي ليست قسم من
رجوع هذه الديانات القديمه الى الحداثه هو
رجوع
علاجي وليست وقايه بينما
الصوفيه في الاول
واليوغا وحتى وحتى الرياضات ما يسمى
بالمارش الارز
الرياضات العسكريه يعني الكراسي
وتايكوندو وكل هذه الشغل هاي كلياتها
استصدرت الان وتستعمل بشكل زائف وبشكل بس
علاج لانه الواحد من بعد ما يشتغل عشر
ساعات في مكتب محاماه او في بنك او شيء
بيكون زهق حاله انه بده يطلع يساوي اشي
تاني بروح على بالليل على كلوب على مركز
وبعمل له شويه سعه كاراتيه بينفض عن حاله
بروح على البيت شوي مبسوط اكثر بس ما حلت
بالاول الكاراتيه زي ما بتعرف انت في في
الكونغ فو هي قسم من ممارسات دينيه
وفلسفيه عميقه جدا جدا اذا بتروح على على
الصين في مراكز الكونغ فو في الجبال قليله
جدا يعني لانه خلصوا عليهم الحكومه
الصينيه ولكن اذا بتلاقيهم بتشوفهم وممكن
تشوف تاخذ نظره من خلال اليوتيوب شو عم
الكونغ فو قسم من الممارسات الدينيه
فالاعتناء في الجسم كقسم من الاعتناء في
جسم كينونه دينيه انت مولود الله وانت
تعتني في الجسم لانك انت
حارس
والمعتني
بجسمك مش الك لانه هذه النظره الدينيه
الها قيمه كبيره جدا اللي احنا نسيناها
اليوم
لما اعتناء في الداخل هو نوع من العباده
يعني لما لما احنا نقول انه التصوف هو
عباده
بتقول تصوف وعباده بقول لك الناس شو عم
تحكي طبعا هو عبادي يعني مفيش حاجه للحكي
طب ليش اسا التصوف هو عبادي بس لما بتدخل
اليوغا بطلت عباده
اصبحت لشفاء مرض
مثلا الشخص القوي والذي ليس له بحاجه وليس
عنده مشكله
الاحباط
والياس والى اخره
وطبعا يواجه مشاكل كثيره في الحياه والاخر
ولكنه قوي
يتحمل وعايش حياه بشكل ما هو مبسوط بشكل
عام ويعرف كيف يعزل السيء عن
الجيد والى اخره
ليس بحاجه لهذه الشغلات لماذا لانه قد طور
من الداخل قلعه ما سماهير عدو اللي هو اثر
على تفكير فوكو سماه القلعه الداخليه
القلعه الداخليه اذا عندك انت القلعه
الداخليه من جوا ما بحاجه الى بالنسبه لك
مجرد شيء سطحي ما هي القلعه القلعه هي
التقنيات النفس التي
اساسها الاخلاق فلما انت تقول جوع وصوم
انت تصوم كالسوفي طب صور انت القدره انت
عندك القدره السيطره على النفس لانه لم من
لم من لم يسيطر على نفسه لا يسيطر على اي
شيء
اول شيء في الدنيا لازم اذا بدك تحكم كل
حاكم في في المنطق الاسلامي
احكم نفسك قبل ما تحكم غيرك
عشان هيك لما لما الغزالي وغيره وغيراته
لما كتبوا كلهم من المورد وابن جماعه
اهم نصيحه للسلطان وللخليفه
لما الغزال بقول لك اعلم يا سلطان العالم
ملك الشرق والغربي كذا كذا انا لله عليك
نعم ظاهره والاء متكاثره
وبدخل في كل عشر صفحات انه انه كيف انت
تفرجي
شكرك للمنعم لله وهذا اساس الحكم وهذه
الصوم من وحدي
الممارسه يعني نظام الصوم احنا بنسويه
اليوم مثلا رمضان لانه
ولكن هدفه اكبر من ما نفهمه اليوم انا
براي القيم الدينيه برغم ممارستها اليوم
وبعد ممارستها ضعفت في مفهوم الاساسي
فمثلا المسلم القديم قبل الف سنه لما كان
يصوم في نفس درجه التعليم والوعي اذا
بناخذ وهم عنده كان فهم للفلسفه الصوم
مثلا في رمضان اكبر واعمق مما
ما يساويها وما يوازيه مسلم في القرن
الواحد والعشرين ليه لانه الفلسفه
فلسفه التي التي تبطن
وتكون اساس
للتقنيات الذات وهي تقنيات صوفيه قد ضاعت
لا نعرفها اليوم
طيب بالنسبه للانسان كيف ينظر الانسان
الحداثي للعالم اليوم
كيف
كساحه كساحه له ومرح
فن بتلاحظ انتبه بالانجليزي هون اكثر كلمه
تستعمل بين الناس كلمه فن
المهم الواحد يكون مبسوط
بس نلاحظ
كل ما يكونوا مبسوطين اكثر بالمعنى انه كل
ما يكون معهم فلوس اكثر وعندهم سيارات
اكثر وعندهم مدخول اللي ما حدا عمله
بتاريخ البشري في هذا المستوى اليوم شباب
صغار 30 سنه في في صناعه التكنولوجيا
والكمبيوترات بيعملوا لهم
اموال هائله
يصبحوا ب 30 35 مليونيريه
وعندهم كل شيء اشتروا بيوت وحتى اشتروا
جزر وبانوا جزر فخمه على على
بيوت فخمه على جزر جميله يعني عندهم كل
شيء في الدين كل الامكانيات موجوده عندهم
ولكن يركبهم الياس والاحباط
والاكتئاب والحزن اكثر من اي شعب في تاريخ
البشريه
الفقير اسعد من الغني حتى اليوم ولكن
الفقير القديم اسعد مليون مره من اغنى
غنيه اليوم
القانون هو واحد كل ما تغنى اكثر في
الحداسه كل ما انك انت بتياس اكتر بتكون
حزينه وما كان هذا الحداثه ليش
من الداخل من الداخل بس اليس نفس الموضوع
هو نفس المعدل لا على المعدل اذا بناخذ
المعدل طبعا انا ليش بقول معدل لانه دائما
في عندك استثناءات يعني ممكن من الف شخص
تلق واحد يستثنى من القاعده اللي انت عم
بتقولها انا ولكن انت بتطلع على اغنياء
المسلمين شو عملوا اغنياء المسلم المسلمين
ولا قسم من
من
الجهاز
العرفي والعادي يعني من العاده العادي في
النظام الاسلامي هو ان المال يجب ان ان
يدور
فمن بنى
المباني الضخمه في الاسلام من كل المساجد
والمدارس
ابار المياه والاخره هيك في الشوارع وجسور
ومن بنى
المسلمون الاثرياء
السلاطين والوزراء والباشوات
والتجار الكبار
كل واحد
مع صنع الخير والحسنات والى اخره كلها
كانت قيمه داخليه لانه المساله مش بس
مساله انه انا كثير من المسلمين طبعا بدهم
يعملوا عشان يفرجوا انه عندهم منهم
بيعملوا كذا عشان يصير عندهم مركز اعلى في
المجتمع هذه الطبيعه انسانيه تقريبا شامله
في اشخاص بيهتملهاش ولكن على الغالب ولكن
عندهم اشياء اقتناء داخلي انه انه انه انه
مثلا
الممارسات التي مصرها الدين والتي تصر على
نوع من ممارسات اخلاقيه واعمال اخلاقيه
كانت قسم من الدين ولذلك كانت تفعل
كطريقه للخلاص الشخصي اليوم ليس ليس هناك
اغلب الناس لا تؤمن في الغرب
وليست عندها هذه الدوافع وحتى لو امنت
وكانت تروح على الكنيسه
عندهم اشياء غريبه جدا بصراحه يعني بروح
السي او تبع شركه كبيره على الكنيسه مع
زوجته واولاده وبعملوا كل
الفروض
الدينيه وحتى يمكن يتبرع في كميه دولار
مثلا للفقراء والاخره ويوم الاثنين الصبح
بيكون قاعد بورد مكتبه في الشركه الكبيره
اللي تبتز وتسرق اموال الناس وتعمل
الشنائعتز نعرف شو هو شو شو
امازون كيف بعامله
عمالهم كيف بصنعوا الاكل تبعهم كم واحد
دفع اسعار باهظه بس عشان
الطبقه العليا في مثلا امازون انها تصير
غنيه من هالشكل
لانه ما في
روادع ودوافع دينيه
ما في تقنيات الذات الداخل داخل الداخل
للشخص الحداسي هو داخل فارغ
ما تم فصلت الاخلاق
عن
يعني عن الانسان وعن
الدوله وعن الشركات بدات في القرن السابع
عشر
في اوروبا وربما طبعا
ليس هناك اي شيء يبدا في نقطه معينه من
الزمن ويبدا من لا شيء يعني غير خلق الله
كنت
ولكن كل شيء اخر في الظاهره الانسانيه
انما بنقول انه بتساوي عشره بدي يكون اله
كان بادي اشياء بعدها غير واضحه
وعامه قبل شويه صغيره ولكن فانا بقول انه
مثلا ممكن السادس عشر حتى الخامس عشر شوي
شوي شوي شوي ولكن في السابع عشر ظهرت
ملامحه الاساسيه وهي انه بدات في اوروبا
مفاهيم جديده ففي
حركات كبيره في
العلوم والى اخره ما سميوا بالحركات
الميكانيكيه
متى الفلاسفه الميكانيكيين
وما يسمى في الانجليزي حركات اخرى فلسفيه
تسمى لا اعرف المسرح العربي لانه لم يوجد
في العربيه وهو
ما تقول هذه الحركات تقول
نحن مسيحيين
ونعترف بوجود الله
وكل شيء احنا مش مسويين اشي غلط الله خلق
الارض
واحنا بنامن فيه ما في غلط ولكن
خلق الارض شغلها كالساعه
واعطى الانسان حريه السيطره على هذه
الساعه
وترك
ترك المشهد فبالنسبه للفلاسفه الميكانيكيه
الله خلق الارض واختفى
وهذا بالمناسبه
له علاقه في الفلسفه اليونانيه القديمه
التي اعترض عليها الغزالي وابن تيميه
وجميع المسلمين وهي انه هل يعرف الله
اجوزيات ام لا وهي مشكله ومساله لاهوتيه
كلاميه فلسفيه كبيره جدا بدات من العصر
اليوناني
واستمرت حتى وزادت في النقاش في الاسلام
لان هاي السؤال هذا ليس فقط سؤال فلسفي هو
سؤال سياسي محض وقانوني لانه اذا الله لا
يعرف الجزئيات معناته انه انت بتقدر تسوي
شو بدك
عرف الجزئيات هو راح يعرف اذا كانك انت
حتى فكرت فكره سلبيه عن اشي اللي مش لازم
تسويه
حتى مثلا خلينا نقول اشتهيت امراه لا يجب
ان تشتهيها
معناته انت الله عرف عنك فهذه تكتب في
الكتاب في سجلك الى يوم القيامه عندما
تحاسب عليها
الا اذا عملتها افعال الخيريه اكثر ساعتها
الله بسامحك ولكن السؤال القضيه هنا انه
ايه انه الله يعرف كل شيء
هذا له
اهميه سياسيه لانه معناته انه انه انه
القانون
والشريعه والى اخره كل عمل يعمل الانسان
ليس فقط له عقاب في الارض له عقاب بعدين
فالشخص الذي ينمو ويربو على انه هون بس في
عقاب واحد هنا اذا نفت فيه نفدت واذا ما
نفتش فيه نفدت
عفوا
تعاقب هنا فقط ولكن في الاسلام وفي
وعندما يكون الله يراقب كل شيء ولم يسكر
العالم
ببوابه وتاخذ المفتاح وترك
الشخص الذي يفعل شيء هو يعاقب عليه اليوم
ويعاقب عليه باضعاف لاحقا
فهذه عندك انت خلق ذات مطيعه شخصيه مطيعه
التي
ربما
تمارس النظام الاخلاقي الشريعه في هذه
الحاله حتى لو لم يكن حدا احد يحاسبك عليه
هنا في الارض فاذا كان هناك بوليس ولما في
بشرطه قدامك في ابوك وامك ولا مش مش من
قدامك في
مراقب ولا مش مراقب مش مهم في مراقب اعلى
هنا في عندك انت شخصيتين ذات داتان
تختلفان عن بعض كل الاختلاف فقط بسبب هذا
الافتراض الثيولوجي
فلما خلينا نكمل قصه اوروبا فلما لما لما
قامت هذه الحركه هي كانت انتقال من
الكنيسه الكاثوليكيه الى المرحله الوسطى
التي هي الميكانيكيه التي تعترف بالله
ولكن لا تعترف بمقدرته على اداره الشؤون
الانسانيه فاصبح الله خسر الله في
المسيحيه في اوروبا خسرت قوه التشريع
وقوه المحاسبه على
المخالفه الشرائع والقوانين هاي المرحلتين
بعدين هذا القرن السابع عشر هات سابع عشر
والثامن عشر بعدين بديت بديت حركات جديده
تقول انه احنا مش ملزمين بالدين ابدا الله
مش بس ترك كل المفاهيم الدينيه ما هي قلنا
من من هذه اللحظه وطالع فلازم نبدا نفكر
فحتى لو في دين
الدين ما له علاقه في الامور السياسي
والمجتمع وهذا الفرق بين
الزندقه وبين
العلمانيه
عدم اعتراف في الله كفر
فانت بتقول انه الله مش موجود ولكن
العلمنه
هي ان تعترف بوجود الله يوم الحد الصبح
لما بتكون بالكنيسه ولكن يوم الاثنين
الصبح بتقدر تروح وتكترف الجرائم اللي بدك
اياها
هاي علمني هاي نتيجه العلمانيه لانه الان
ليس هناك علاقه بين الدين كنظام اخلاقي
ليوم الحد
باقي ايام الوقت في المسيحيه
بينما في الاسلام ما في هذا الفرق انت لما
بدك على الطريقه الاسلاميه في 14 قرن من
او على الاقل لحديث جديد لسه بعض المسلمين
عم بساوي تقريبا زي شو المسيحيين
يعني عندهم بعض
الشعائر الدينيه ولكن لا ينظرون الى ما هي
ما هي ابعاد اعمالهم لما يبدوا يوم
الاثنين الصبح يشتغلوا
مسؤوليه العامه اتجاه المجتمع هذه مسؤوليه
اخلاقيه ليست هناك ليس هناك اي اهتمام في
اي شخص اخر
الا اللهم عائلتك الاساسيه الا بدون بدون
دوافع الاخلاقيه
وكون لما محل الاخلاق
كلما تضمحل الاخلاق كلما تصبح انت غير
مسؤول اتجاه المجتمع ومشاكله وغيرك
ليس هناك كما قال طه عبد الرحمن ليس هناك
انسان بغير اخلاق
الاخلاق تصنع الانسان
وانو اي انسان بدون اخلاق هو
[موسيقى]
بدون روح غير مسؤول وممكن انه يقترف اي
جريمه من غير ما حتى يعرف
فاهم كيف
في اوروبا هذا صار في عزل او فصل بين
الاخلاق وبين كل شيء عشان هيك اجى
الفيلسوف
اسكتلندي المشهور
وقال ايش قال انه هناك فصل تام بينما هو
كائن وما بينما يجب ان يكون ما هو كائن
الاشياء الموجوده
وما يجب ان يكون هو الاخلاق
انا بقول هذا جبل هذه حقيقه هذا جبل موجود
قدام الكل ولكن شو معنى الجبل بالنسبه الك
ويلي انت بالنسبه لك الجبل اه والله هذا
الجبل منيح اني ابني عليه بيوته واعمل
استثمارات
واعمل فيه
برك وسباحه
والى اخره ومحلات صيد وبالاخر هو واحد
تاني يطلع سبحان الله
بجماله هذا جبل اللي بس اطلع عليه بركه
بحب اروح ازوره وامشي فيه وارجع
اتمتع في هواء وصفي هدول شخصين يختلفن
تماما
ليش الاولاني الاولاني هو هو تبع الاز
يعني تبع الماء يجب ما يكون
ولكن الثاني رجل اخلاق يعترف بجمال الجبل
لاجل الجبل نفسه لاجل خالق الجبل لاجل
علاقه الجبل بالانسانيه التي خلقها الله
ولا يمنع عمارته لا طيب لحد لحد معين يعني
الاستغلال لازم يكون له حد لا تستطيع انت
كل جبل تروح تبني عليه الفين بيت عشان هاي
دمار الارض ما عم بصير معنا احنا عم بنعمر
يعني انت تعرف الناس يعرفون كفايه انك اذا
انه اذا في اي شط اذا كان بنيت عليه اكثر
من ثلاث طوابق اربع طوابق
يغير كل
مجرى الهواء والطبيعه في ذلك المنطقه
تماما بس مجرد بنيت بنايه عاليه من غير ما
تعمل مصانع ولا اي شيء ثاني مدمر بس مجرد
بنيت لانه الارض لانه الارض مفروض يكون
على الشط عمارات عليه كان خلق الله عليها
على مرض عالي من الاول من قبل ما احنا مش
بحاجه لنا احنا نعملها
ولما يكون في عنا سبب انه انه في عنا
اسماك في البحر والى اخره من انواع عديده
كل شيء له سبب الله خلق كل شيء
لم يخلق اي شيء عبثا
له سبب فاحنا بالنسبه لنا مش لا نعرف انه
انه في نظام اخلاقي يربط كل شيء بكل شيء
وانه اللعب بواحده منها تؤثر على كلاه
يعني يعني الاخلاق هي ليست فقط انه
التصرفات بشكل جيد ولطيف مع الناس وان
الواحد يساعد الاخلاق اكثر من هيك الاخلاق
هو معرفه انك انت مش لازم
تبحش كثير في اسرار الكون لانك مش راح
تفهمها
العلم له اهدافه ولا ليس العلم تبعنا
اليوم مسيطره بس على السيطره هدف اننا كيف
احنا نعيش كمان 200 سنه نعيش للابد كيف
اننا نخلق بني ادم زي زي احنا
الكلوني
هذه هذه
اللي بفكر بهذه الطريقه من اغبى الاغبياء
برجع لك لانها نقطه مهمه بس عندي سؤالين
على الكلام اللي قلته قبل شوي عشان ابغى
توضح هل كل انسان اليوم هو بالضروره حداثي
ولا في ناس وناس
الحداثه
ظاهره مستمره في التكوين
لانه مثلا
خلينا نقول في الغرب قمه
الذات الحداثيه كانت موجوده في الغرب في
1990 مزبوط ولكن
الذات الحداثيه في 1990 قبل السوشيال
ميديا
وتسعين
كقسم من من الظواهر الحداثيه مثلا هي
السوشيال ميديا في اشياء كتيرة
الذاتيه في الحداثه كانت على قمتها في
الغرب في 1990 فبتلاقي انه هذه كانت اعلى
درجات الحداثه لانه هن في الغرب قائدين
بهاي الشغله هاي المشكله
ولكن اذا بتنظر اسا
انزل 25 سنه لاحقا 30 سنه لاحقا اسا اللي
هي يعني تقريبا 30 اكثر من 30 سنه من 1990
تجد انه بدايه الحداثيه تغيرت اليوم الشخص
قبل
التواصل الاجتماعي كان شيء وبعد التواصل
الاجتماعي صار شيء تاني لاحظ في التصرفات
في النظره الى الجسد والروح الانسانيه كيف
الناس تلبس كيف الشباب والشابات عم بلبسوا
شو معنى شو معنى الجنس في كل هذا اللي ما
يسمى الحريه الجنسيه كله تغير التغير هائل
حتى في اخر خمس عشر سنوات
فهذا كله التغييرات هذه ليست فقط تغييرات
عندما اقول تغييرات انا اقول ايضا ان هذه
التغييرات تدخل في صميم تغيير الذات الذات
الحداثيه
فالشخص الحداسي اليوم في الغرب الذي في
قمه الحداثه 2023 يختلف اختلاف
يعني قوي من نفس
الجير من الجيل الذي وصل لهذه المرحله في
1990 فقط ليس فقط تصور 1950 1930 1880
فالحداثه هاي كلها تتطور
فعشان هيك لا نستطيع ان نقول انه الكل يصل
الى نفس درجه الحداثه في العالم بنفس
المرحله ولكن الكل دخل في الحداثه
متفاوته
والتواصل الاجتماعي جعل التفاوت اقل في
العالم
فطبعا مثلا في قرى في في الصين والهند
ربما عندهم شوي اقل من الحله ليش لانه
عندهم التليفون وبشوفوا كل اللي عم بيصير
في العالم ولكن ليست عندهم الوسائل اللي
يبرمجوا نفسهم يعني ينحتوا حالهم يعني
يكونوا ذاتيتهم بشكل اللي مثلا نفس واحد
بنفس الجيل بنفس الاهتمام خلينا نقول في
نيويورك او في
باريس يختلف
ولكن عقليا على الاقل دخلوا في الحداثه
حتى في القريه هذه ما في قريه في العالم
اليوم بعرفها انا الا اذا كان نسيت من
خريطه العالم اللي اللي ما في عندهم
الايفون واذا عندك الايفون الان انت حدثي
يعني هل نقيض الحداثه او الانسان الحداثي
والرجعي بالضروره اللي ما عنده تقنيه اللي
يربطك بها بالتقنيه الحين كما نقف اليوم
في هذا المفترق اي نقيد حداثه هو
من من اكثر الاشياء الايجابيه التي يمكن
ان نجدها حتى لو كانوا يظن انه رجعي احسن
من الاحداث اليوم ليش لانه لانه احنا في
مازق كبير جدا
بخلال 30 سنه راح ندمر حالنا بيئيا من
ناحيه من ناحيه الطقس والفيضانات ب 30 سنه
اذا كانوا بناخذش خطوات
جامده اذا تحسين الوضع كل بنغلاديش قسم من
الهند
وجزر كبيره في العالم وهولندا راح تنزل
تحت البحر مثلا
اليوم كل سنه عندك مئه الف شخص صغير بين
عمره 15 ل 30 ينتحر
زياده عن السنه اللي فاتت فبسال انا طلابي
اكم
شاب شاب
صحيح
35 شباب اكم شاب في العالم ينتحر بالسنه
اسال طلاب
ما حدا يعرف
شباب ما عندهم اي سبب للانتحار هدول كلها
كل الحياه قدامهم
مليون و200 الف شاب كل سنه ينتحرون في
العالم انا بدي اياك انك تحط مليون و 200
الف شخص في ميدان كبير
وشوف كم واحد بده يكون هدول بنتحروا كل
سنه
الامراض طبعا
الامراض النفسيه يعني تقريبا بقدر استطيع
ان اقول انه العالم داخل في مرحله جديده
في كيف احنا دخلنا في السوشيال ميديا في
التواصل الاجتماعي وكيف دخلنا في العصر
التكنولوجي وعصر الكمبيوتر وعصر وعصر عصر
هذا وعصر هذاك احنا دخلنا في عصر الجنون
الجنون الجنون
الان الامراض النفسيه
تقريبا تهجم على العالم بشكل بشكل بشكل
كبير جدا لدرجه انه كل الجيل الصغير الذي
لم يعهد لنوع يتكون قبل متلي انا اتكون
كنا كان في عائله كانت قويه جدا
عند سبع خالات ست خالاته وامي وستي وسته
الثانيه واعمام وخوال كلهم حبوني وكلهم
اخذوني كابنهن
اليوم تصور الامور كيف
اليوم في كولومبيا في جامعه كولومبيا اللي
بعلم فيها
واحد من اربع
طلاب على الدرجه العليا يعني بعد
البكالوريوس يعاني من امراض نفسيه جديه
ماذا كيف تعرف امراض نفسيه جديه
فيها اعتبارات للانتحار
واحد من خمسه كولومبيا الاحصائيات موجوده
انا مش عم بقول لك اشي مني
واحد من خمس
اللي في الدرجه البكالوريوس يعاني من نفس
المشاكل هذا بافتراض انهم كل فصل عنا على
المعدل واحد طالب واحد ينتحر في كولومبيا
كل فصل كل سنه
ومراتنين بالسنه لا جامعه فيها 30 الف
واحد هذا كتير كتير كتير هذا كتير لاي
لكثير في العالم حتى انه ينتحر الشاب او
شابه
ليش
الامراض النفسيه عم تتغي علينا اكثر واكثر
وابنائنا الجيل الصغير هو الضحيه الكبرى
وانا برايي انه
الصغار اليوم اذا كان عن جد بفكروا مزبوط
في الوضع لازم لازم يبدو يفكروا بشكل
لانه هن راح يدفعوا احنا احنا كنا قاعدين
مسؤوليه تركنا لهم وضع مزري جدا وهم اللي
راح يدفعوا السعر واولادهم وهم يحق لهم
الثوره على هذا الوضع انا اقول ثوره
بالمعنى الثقافي والى اخره لا ادعي الى
العنف تماما ابدا ولكن هناك يجب ان تكون
ثوره ثقافيه يجب ان يبدا ان يسالوا اسئله
الكبيره والمهمه ماذا يحصل لنا من نحن
ما ما
كونا بهذه الطريقه لان نعيش في الارض
فسادا
يعني اذا كان في شعب في كل التاريخ البشري
عاث في الارض فساد او هو الحداثه
انا مش راح انا ما بحاجه اعطيك المعلومات
كله كل اللي بحاجه الى انك تطلع على جوجل
وبس تاخذ قديش اكم اكم فصيله تختفي في
العالم كل يوم فصيله حيوانيه ممكن اسالك
يعني عرفنا
110 يوميا بينما المعدل العلمي للاختفاء
الفصائل في العالم حسب تقدير العلماء بشكل
عام هو خمسه بالسنه
لنقل خمسين بالسنه ولكن اليوم
كل يوم احنا اليوم عم نخسر فوق المئه
فصيله من الحيوانات في العالم نحن ندمر
نحن دمرنا كل شيء لمسناه
ناخذ النظاره ثانيه فهذه نظاره متشائمه
ممكن اعطيك نظاره ثانيه تقول لك انه اليوم
احنا
صحيح انه تجي امراض جديده مثلا
السرطان ولا
الاكتئاب ولا غيره من الامراض النفسيه او
غيره من الامراض الدقيقه اللي اكتشفت
مؤخرا لكن هي لانه قدرنا نحل امراض كان
يعاني منها
الانسان القديم فصار عمره اطول اليوم
متوسط عمره الانسان كان قبل مئه سنه مثلا
في السعوديه وفي الجزيره العربيه خمسين
سنه الان اصبح سبعين سنه في امريكا يزيد
فمتوسط عمر الانسان في العالم ارتفع وهذا
يعطيه ان صحته صارت افضل ومعها انها تطلع
امراض جديده لكن كل مالهم يكتشفوا حلول
لهذه الامراض فهذا بالنسبه للامراض
بالنسبه
للحروب
الان نعيش في عصر هو اقل الحروب في تاريخ
البشريه
تاخذ الحروب تاخذ بالنسبه
للغناء والفقر نسبه الفقر ناخذ واحده
بواحده يعني تقدر وكيف انه الفقر هو اقل
اليوم في التاريخ صحيح فعندك عوامل
ايجابيه احدثتها الحداثه خليني اقول لك
جواب مو لازم ناخذ نظره سلبيه
مش نظره سلبيه انا نظره ايجابيه اكثر من
اللي انت
لانه هناك تفسير سيء للنظره ايجابيه بس
مرات النظره السلبيه هي التي تؤمن
بالايجابيات اكثر من النظر لان النظره
الايجابيه ممكن ان تتهم
بعدم الاهتمام وعدم المسؤوليه كل شيء منيح
كل شيء حلو كل شيء ممتاز
بتقوم القيامه واحنا كل شيء حلو كل شيء
ممتاز
وبتكون ونفس الشيء لتنه مزبوط نقع في
النظره السلبيه اللي انا بعد انا اعتبر
وجهه نظري سلبيه ولا تسمى
هذا كمان
انه فيه تش اؤم انا بالعكس انا
النقد تبعي مشروعي مشروع نقدي النقد تبعي
هو ايجابي لحد الى اكبر حد ليه لانه انا
افكر انه يجب ان نسترجع مفهوم المسؤوليه
لما اكون انا انتقد لمين عم بنتقد لانه
عشان انا انا من زمان كنت بقدر اتقاعد مش
بحاجه اني اشتغل بس اتقاعد لايه
شغلي
تعبدي
تعبدي وسبب موجوده هو طبعا عند عيلتي
بحبهم بموت عليهم ولكن سبب الاخر في
الوجود هو انه
في شغل في مسؤوليه لازم تكون فيها
ليه لانه زي اغلب الناس لما يصيروا 30 او
اربعين بصير عندهم اولاد
مع انه عم تتلاشى هاي الظاهره بس انه في
كتير في ناس عندهم اولاد هاي الاجيال
الجديده اي عالم راح نترك لهم اذا كانوا
مش رايحين نواعيهم انه في عنا مشاكل بنكون
روحوا شو بدكم انتم انبسطوا في الكلابات
موجوده روحوا اشربوا
والدنيا حلوه جميله وروح اشتري اللي بدك
اياه ويكب اللي بدك اياه واستهلك نصف اللي
بتشتريه مش مهم والدنيا حلوه هاي هاي اكبر
هاي كارثه ولكن ولكن اذا بتسمعني انا شو
عم بقول مزبوط وشو جوهر قولي وانا اللي
بقوله انه لازم يكون حذرين انه ممكن واحد
يتمتع في الحياه وانا
برغم كل حضري كمان لست بزاهدا يعني عندي
كمان ابسط في حياتي ولكن بنبسط بشكل مسؤول
اول شيء في حياتي اليوميه امارس النقد
لانه الناس لازم تفهم لازم يكون عندها وعي
ولا شو عم بيساوي واحد بيروح زي الطلابي
بقولوا لي احنا من بعد ما ناخذ الدورات
تبعتك بتغير بتغيرت حياتنا اسا ما في عنا
بالاول ليه لانه القصه لما بيروحوا بشتروا
قنينه كوكاكولا او علبه كوكيلو بيشربوها
كل طالب بياخد عندي صف ببطل تقريبا يعمل
هاي او اذا عملها دغري عنده تانيب في
الضمير من كل اللي سمعوا شو معناته هذا
الحركه البسيطه هو هو فعل بسيط تروح تشتري
قنينه كوكاكولا بتدفع حقها دولارين وبتروح
تشربها
لا هذا فعل
حرام
في شريعه الحداثه يجب ان يكون حرام ولكن
بما ان الحداثه ليس فيها اخلاق فليست فيها
شريعه
فانت انت اثرت نقاط مثل مثلا انا لا اريد
ان اتهم انه انا بتفادى اللي انت مثلا
مثلا مساله الطب والتعمير الطب زي ما انا
لمحت لك قبل شوي صغيره الطب كله هدفه انه
انه مزبوط في لما الواحد يعمل شيء دائما
في له صيده فاكس
التاثيرات الجانبيه تاثيرات الجانبيه للطب
هو انه احنا عم نعيش اكثر واكثر وهذا اللي
احنا بنركز
احنا بنكون مرضى وبنروح نتعالج شو بدك
احسن من هيك نشكر ربنا على الجهاد الطبي
مزبوط لحد معين نشكر ربنا على جهاز الطبي
ولكن ما نظرنا للجنيولوجيه التبعت الظاهر
كلها الجينيولوجيه هي انه احنا ليش
بالمستشفى
ليش بالمستشفى لانه احنا امراضنا القديمه
اللي قبل الحداثه تقريبا قليله جدا تقريبا
مش موجوده اغلب الامراض اللي احنا
بنعانيها اليوم هي امراض حساسيه اغلبها
يعني لما بنقول انه انه انه واحد من اربع
اشخاص لازم يعاني من السرطان بحياته هذا
المعدل واحد من اربع اشخاص كمان لازم
يعاني من الامراض القلب ويموت من مرض
القلب هاي كلها السرطان الامراض القلب وكل
الاشياء التانيه وهاي اغلب الامراض هاي
هاي من وين اجت هاي اجت من من طريقتنا في
الحياه اليوم اما من الماكولات او من
التلوث الجو او من
الضغوط اللي علينا لانه الزعل والحزن بولد
امراض كمان كل هالعوامل كل العوامل اللي
موجوده في اليوم في الحداثه تبعتنا في في
حياتنا العاديه هي التي تولد 80% 90% من
الامراض
فلما تيجي الجهاز الطبي ويقول لك يسمع انا
عمليا يعني هنا لازم تتخيل ان الجهاز
الطبي عم بتكلم مع الشركات الكبيره فشو
بقول له جهاز الطبي بكل الشركات الكبيره
انت شو بدك احنا انت اعطونا مصاري
واحنا بنطور الطب تبعنا عشان نشفي الناس
عشان يضلوا يستهلكوا
ماكولاتكم والى اخره
يعني في تحالف بين المستشفيات والجهاز
الطبي اليوم تقريبا في كل دوله وخصوصا في
الولايات المتحده مع الشركات الكبيره حتى
اصبحت الاجهزه الان المستشفيات في
المناسبه اصبحت شركات كان في الاول عندك
الاطباء يمارسون الطب من خلال عيادتهم
الخاصه
كل واحد عنده عيادته وربما يجتمع طبيبين
ثلاثه يعملوا مع بعض ولكن الان المستشفيات
عم تشتري هدول الاطباء وبتدخلهم في سلكه
بتدفع لهم معاش فشو هذا المعاش هذا المعاش
هو
الفلوس اللي بدفعوا الواحد عشان يسترق
انسان اخر فلاصبحوا الاطباء اليوم
رق للشركات بينما كانوا مستقلين قبل
وكانوا يشتغلون به بكرامتهم ولكن الان
اصبحوا مجرد عاملين في الشركات الكبيره
ويستغل من قبل هذه الشركات
لانه هذه الشركات هي نفس الشركات كل شركه
بالمناسبه لها
اهتمام خاص ومصلحه خاصه بانها تتعاون مع
شركات الاخرى لانهم كلهم كيف كيف الذئاب
الذئاب يجتمعون مع بعض عشان يصيدوا
الفريسه اكبر الشركات ذئاب تجتمع مع بعض
تشتغل مع بعض لانها من نفس النوع بينما
الشركه مش راح تشتغل منيح معي انا كشخص
مثلا ادعو الى الاخلاق راح يقولوا لي انت
بتخرب لنا الشغل انت عدونا بالاساس انا
لما بقول انه احسن احسن طريقه
لتغيير النظام اليوم هي في الثقافه
والاخره ولكن كمان في انه نبدا
بمقاطعه الشركات اذا قطعت الشركات
قل
انتاجها وقل استغلال الارض فخذ انت خلينا
نقول اللحمه الاحمر اللحم البقر هو يسبب
الامراض
السرطانيه معروف ما بحاجه انه
اصر عليها اكثر من هيك
البقر يستعمل ياكل ياكل العلف والعلف يزرع
في اراضي شاسعه كبيره لدرجه انه الغابات
كلها تقص من اجل زراعه العلف للبقر
ومن يفعل ذلك
الشركات
فلما شركات تفعل هذا اذا انا قلت اول شيء
لمسحتي لازم اكل خمس اكله من اللحم الاحمر
يك
في نحن نستهلك اكثر من مشروب بحاجه عشان
هيك في مشكله السماني وكذا اغلب امريكا
عندها مشكله موقفه في
واليوم داخله على تقريبا كل الدول
بريطانيا ودول الخليج المعروفه هذا كلها
بسبب هاي الشغلات فانت اذا اشتريت اقل بقر
رحل شركات مش راح يكون عندها سوق راح تضطر
تنتج اقل راح يصير في استغلال اقل الاراضي
تدمير اقل الغابات ولما تضعف الشركه
وتقصها على حجمها ساعتها بنقول بدنا شركات
صغيره
توفي في حاجاتنا بس مش عمالقه احتلوا
العالم يا رجل احتلوا العالم ما تشوف انه
اليوم برضو نفس الادوات الحداثه والحداثه
نفسها ستخلق هذه الشركات الجديده
والحركات اللي تساعد في هذه الثقافه
الجديده اللي انت تطلبها انه اليوم اعاده
تدوير في نمو يعني انا اتكلم عن لما اقول
اعاده النمو اللي هو ثقافتي اعاده تدوير
او الاكل المصنوع حتى الاكل الحمراء وغيره
كيف انه جالس يقل استخدامها
البلاستيك واستخدامه يعني فيه حركه ضخمه
احس انك تقدر تراها وتلمسها في تقسيم في
التقليل وتحسين وهذا من ضمن الادوات
الحداثه نفسها يعني
مزبوط صحيح حكيك صحيح وممكن تصلح نفسها
حسب
حسب السرعه اللي ماء
الزمنيه اليوم لا لانه احنا اللي عم نسويه
قليل جدا لازم يكون بكتير اكثر هذه اول
شيء ولكن كمان انت انظر للتحسينات هاي
كتير من التحسينات هاي هي قسم من نفس
المنطق
اللي ولدت المشكله في من البدايه فان لما
لما مثلا
اجي اقول طيب بدناش نستعمل البترول خلينا
مصادر اخرى من الهواء خلينا نقول فانا
شركه باجي بعمل بعمل شركه كبيره كمان
شركه وبدخل بابنها عشان ايش انه احسن ولكن
الدوافع تبعتي كلياتها هي استغلال بعد نفس
المنطق الراسمالي
فاذا كانه
في النقطه يعني في النقطه التي لا يكون
هناك جلب فلوس من
التكنولوجيا خضراء
مواده يرجع انه شو اصل الكمبيوتر انه اجا
من الحرب ومن العنف انه انه
اوكي خلينا نرجع
نهاجم الموضوع من طريق من باب من باب اخر
لا يمكن ان تحل مشكله من خلال حل
انتج من نفس المنطق الذي انتج المشكله
قانون رقم واحد
مستحيل والحداثه اثبتت هذا القانون احنا
لم نكن نعرف هذا القانون بالمناسبه في
التاريخ البشري حتى حتى ما حدث في القرن
في القرنين
لان الحداثه هذا هو هذا هو منطقه انه
تحاول تخلق حل من داخل خلينا نقول نرجع
على الحوامض في الجسم
اذا بتطلع عليه شو الحل للحوامل للجسم هو
المزبوط لازم يكون لانك انت تعدل طريقه
حياتك
انه تعمل نوع من الرياضه انه تاكل
الماكولات تاني
بس بس مستحيل على الحداثه انه المنطقه
راسنا انه يكون لكن ساعتها هو بيكون
مدمر للنفس
فهن شو بساويوا بعطوك
مشهور جدا ينتج بالملايين
ولكن ولكن
يعيد فساد في الجسم بنعرف انه هذا معناته
انه بعد كم سنه بني ادم يطور سرطان في كذا
هو الحل الحداثي لمشكله حداثيه
فانت تخلصت من الحركه بس احنا اعطينا
سرطان للمريض
يعني يعني طب لا يا عمي اتركني خليني
بالحلقه على الاقل لا بعطيك
سرطان بعدين بتروح على المستشفى بتدفع 450
الف دولار العمليه
رحت للحركه بيجينا يقولوا انه تسريع
الحركه وجعلها يعني جزء من هذا المنظم
صحيح فيعني ما باسلم لا من هنا لا لا طبعا
احنا ماذا
يجب ان نفهم ان نحن في مازق ليس انا جيلي
حتى جيلك يعني كبرنا شوي ما انك انت بعدك
شب
ولكن عندك اطفال عنده اطفال عندهم اطفال
وشو نعمل ابرياء لا يستحقون ما نفعل بهم
طيب لما نقول الاخلاق يعني هذا السؤال
لعوده على بعض النقاط اللي تكلمنا فيها
فتشير اليها نفس الاشاره طه عبد الرحمن
لها
هل الاخلاق بالضروره تساوي الدين
هذا نقاش هو
بصراحه انا بالنسبه الي هذا ليس سؤال مهم
هو اله مهم لانه عنده ظروفه
قبل شوي قدرت اني افهم كذا يعني انه لما
مثلا في القرن السابع عشر انه فصلوا الدين
عنه
وبالضروره انزاحه الاخلاق فانت حطيت انه
القرن السابع عشر كان مفصلي في الاخلاق
لازاحه الدين فكما
بتعني بالدين هاي المشكله اليوم انه لما
تقول دين
بالانجليزي
بترجمه
في الاسلام
بس بتاخد مثلا شو
المسلمين بالنسبه لهم الدين اشي
والاوروبيين المسيحيين بالنسبه او غير
المسيحيين الاوروبيين بشكل عام بالنسبه
لهم شيء ثاني لما بتقول انه هل هناك هل
هناك علاقه بالدين والاخلاق بدك تقول لي
بالاول شو بتعني بالدين اذا كانه انت
بالنسبه الى انه الدين لازم يكون دائما
سماوي بالمعنى خلينا نقول الاسلامي انا
بقول انه مش بالضروره لانه مثلا في عندك
انت
انواعها مثلا مثل البوذيه
والهندوسيه والى اخره اللي ممكن يخلقه
ساجيات اخلاقيه
انا برايي الشخصي انا بفكر انه الاسلام
اكثر واحد نجح في هذا المشروع
براي الشخصي ولكن لا اريد ان اقول انه
الكل الاخر فشل فشله تماما فممكن انه يكون
انه يكون في عندك
دين بالمعنى اللي انا بقدر اعرفه لانه
طبعا الدين بتمده بتمده بتمده لدرجه معينه
بتقدرش تمده لكل اخر رح يكون في اشياء
مثلا مش ديني بحسب مفهومي انا اذا بتمد
الدين على اكثر باكثر مدام ممكن
هناك علاقه مباشره بين الاخلاق والدين
لانه صعب انه القيام
بنظام اخلاقي متين بنظام اخلاقي متماسك
بنظام اخلاقي منطقي ونظام اخلاقي الذي
يستطيع ان يكون الذات الانسانيه بشكل فعال
على المستوى الفردي وعلى المستوى
الاجتماعي
اذا لم يكن مربوط بحركه تزمولوجيه
ميتافيزيقيه
لانه احنا قسم من الكون واذا كانوا من
التظاهر انه احنا عايشين هون وانه الله
موجود او حتى مش موجود او كذا اعوذ بالله
انه هذا كلياته خزعبلات فاضيه
احنا موجودين
مجرد انه اعرف كما ادهشني لما عرفت قبل شي
عشرين سنه انه
احنا معمولين من نفس المواد اللي معموله
منها الاحجار اللي سقطت من من الفلك
فحللوا شو المعادن في لقوا انه تقريبا 98
99% من المعادن اللي بالميت موجوده في
الجسم الانساني وهو جاي من الفلك
فمجرد اعرف هذا الاشي مجرد مجرد اعرف انه
احنا في كوكب صغير صغير بين بلايين
وبلايين من الكواكب التي لا نعرف وين
بدايتها ولا نهايتها ولا نستطيع ان نعرف
عنها اي شيء غير هالاتنين ثلاثه اللي
حوالينا هون وحتى منعرفش كفايه
هذا كله الكون ايش
في بده يكون في اشي بدو يكون في في احنا
مش موجودين عبثا هون يا عمي
كل اشي مترابط مع بعضه انا نحن اولاد عم
القرود والقرود اولاد عم الحيوان اللي
بعده والفيل مربوط مع الزرافه كلياتنا من
الارض وللارض نعود فهذا كلياته هذا كله
دين
دين مش مش حسبنا كيف العقول الصغيره بتفكر
الله في لحيه قاعد في محل كيف بعض
المسيحيين حتى الله في لحيه وقاعد
بده يجرب تجارب في الله موجود موجود وين
مكان في الجبال والاشجار في الحيوانات وفي
الانسان في الضوء وفي الرياح في النار وفي
موجود وين مكان نحن واحد
نحن كلنا واحد وان نكون نحن نحن جميعنا
بترابنا بجبالنا بافلاكنا
بحيواناتنا اخواتنا على الارض
طيب ودي اعرف بعض الاشياء لانه اليوم مع
الحداثه اصبحت
كثير من المفاهيم ناخذها على انها مسلمات
وانه هذا هو هذا هو المفهوم انترجت في
بدايه حديثنا يمكن على الحريه وتعرف
الحريه
يعني هل كانت حاضره في التراث الاسلامي
طبعا كيف كان الحريه
ليست نوع واحد
الحريه انواع ولكن نعرف عن نوع ثاني اللي
هو بنفس القوه
والجداره واكثر جداره بكثير حتى من الحريه
التي نعرفها اليوم
فحريه اليوم هي حريه التصرف من غير عوائق
خلينا نقول من الدوله او من انه الواحد
اذا بدي انا ادخن بدخن اذا بديش ادخن بدخن
ما حدا بده يفرض علي هاي ولا هيك ولكن فكر
انت ما في عندك حريه انك تقول انا ما بديش
هذا القانون انا بدي قانون تاني
مزبوط فالحريه مش معناته حريه شامله في
اليوم هي حريه سماها ايزايا برلين اسحاق
برلين سماها الحريه السلبيه وهي حريه ان
تتصرف من غير عوائق التي
تطيح
بحقوقك كمواطن هذه الحريات هي مصنوعه
بالاساس
هي تظهر انها حريه سياسيه لكن هي مصنوعه
في الاساس لا تكون حريات اقتصاديه ماديه
الهدف الاساسي للدوله هو دائما الاقتصاد
الاقتصادي يجلب الاموال والاموال تصنع
الجنود والجيوش والقوه والى اخره والاخر
فعزل دائره
هناك
تعاون مخيف بين الراسماليه والدوله والراس
ماليه والدوله هما اكبر مشروعين قامت فيهم
الحداثه بمناسبه
هما
النطاقان المركزيان الاساسيان في الحياه
الحدثيه احنا كنا في الاسلام انه
النطاقين النطاقين المركزيهما الشريعه
والتصوف اليوم ان التقان المركزيان هما
الدوله
والعالم المادي بما في الشركات وراسماليه
والاخيره لانه لما نقول الماديات هي اكبر
من الراسماليه لان الراسماليه هي ليست فقط
ممارسه بس ايضا فلسفه
ونظرت نظره او فلسفه للحياه كمان
هذه السمى جميعها كلياتها يعني انت تشتري
شو بدك بتشتري شو بدك هذا اساسو اقتصادي
ولكن اذا بتيجي الاشياء الكثيره اخرى
الدوله تتحكم فيك وتملكك في الاساس تملكك
حرفيا
مثلا في اليوم لما بتقول لك الدوله انت
بدك تروح على الجيش تحارب في فيتنام او
تحارب في افغانستان او في اللي هو في
امريكا مجبور تروح اذا بتروح تعاقب
ولا حدا تاني بقدر يسيطر على هذا القرار
خذ الاسلام لما كان في نفير للجهاد اول في
ناس اللي بدهم يروحوا بس حتى اللي قرروا
يروحوا اذا كانه ولد بده يروح ابوه وامه
اذا قالوا لا خلص يروح
اذا كانه مديون لواحد اذا الدائن قال له
انت بتقدرش تروح ما بتقدرش يروح على
الجهاز
شايف الفرق بين النظام الاسلامي وفي الحكم
الدوله اليوم هذه الحريه الموجوده
توجد في مساحات كبيره جدا ولكن مقبوضه في
نواحي اخرى وتسمى حريه
ولكن حريه اللي انا بحكي عنها اللي سماها
اسحاق برلين من غير ما يعرف شو هي بالضبط
لانه هم فش عنده فكره واضحه عنها كتير
فكوك فكوه هو الفيلسوف الوحيد اللي في
الحداثه لا يعرف عنها اكثر من اي شخص اخر
كتب عنها شيء 15 كتاب
هذه الحداثه هي الحريه من
وليست حريه الى الحريه الاولى الحريه
السلبيه هي حريه الى انا انا حر الى ان
افعل ما اريد ما اشتري ما اريد في نطاق
القانون
ولكن الحريه من هو ان اني اني اذا كنت
وصلت في داخلي الى القناعه بالسعاده
والفرح حتى الاحتياج الصوفي
من غير ان اشتري هذه السياره او اكل هذا
الكيلو اللحم الصافي او كذا لانه انا
مقتنع ذاتيا من غير بحاجه للماديات هذه
الحريه الصحيحه
انا حر من
لماذا نسميها في العربيه حر انك انت
حررتها من عندما تحرر قطعه من اللحم من
جسم الحيوانات حرر
القطعه حررت الضلع او حرر يعني قطعته
التحرير هو انك انت تلاقي وين حدود الشيء
وتاخذه من محله وتقول هداه كتحرير الكتب
نفس الشيء نفس المبدا فالحريه
الحريه هي ان تكون حر من داخلك
من غير ما انت تكون بحاجه لشيء لما تصبح
انت
يعتمد كل مشاعرك وكل كيانك على انك انت لن
تكون كاملا الا بان تشترك في سياره
المرسيدس فانت اصبحت عبدا لها
فالحريه من الاولى هي حريه عبوديه
والحريه الى هي الحريه الخالصه
لن يستطيع احد ان يكسرك العكس العكس لا لا
العكس حريه من هي الحريه الخارسه الحريه
من هي الحريه الخاصه
لانك انت انا انا استطيع ان اكون انسان
كامل في داخلي قوي عندي القلعه الداخليه
القويه التي حكينا عنها
قلعه قويه في الداخل من غير ما اكون انا
بحاجه انه لاكتمل يجب ان ان ان
يكون عندي هذا البيت الفخم او انه اتدين
فلوس ليوم القيامه عشان ايش عشان اشتري
سياره فخمه عشان افرجها لجهري او لصاحبي
هايدي عبوديه ونحن كما كتب الكثيرون
بخصوصا في نطاق الكتابه عن الدين ما هو
الدين والاخره قالوا اننا اليوم نحن
عبيدا للراسماليه حتى
مع حتى لو كنا نظن اننا احرار
ودي اخذ بعض المفاهيم الثانيه مثل
المساواه هل كان كيف كان هذا المفهوم ما
قبل الحدث
هل كان حاضر ترى كل هذه المفاهيم
العدل هل هذه المفاهيم اللي حاضره اليوم
بزخم كانت حاضره ما قبل الحداثه ترى كل كل
مجتمع عنده طريقه انه
يخلق الشروط الضروريه في انه يستمر في
الحياه مرات يعاني من بعض الازمات كل
مجتمع يعني نزولات وطلوعات
ولكن
في هذه الاطارات
يستطيع دائما المجتمع عنده الوسائل التي
التي تمكن
الاشياء
تمشي في هذه العجل
فالمسواه هو هي طريقه حل بعض المشاكل لكي
لكي لكي يستمر المجتمع
بحياته العاديه
لا نستطيع ان نقول انه احنا ظروفنا لانها
بتتطلب نوع من المساواه لازم تكون موجوده
في اي مجتمع تاني ونبدا نقول كان عندهم
مساواه ولا ما كانش عندهم فالسؤال بحد
ذاته شوي مشكله
هل كانت حاضره هذه المعضله
ما كانت ما كان في مشكله لانه كان في
الشريعه
التاسع عشر كانت قد نظمت الحياه
والناس بسبب بسبب اهميتها للمجتمع
وحتى قداسيتها
تقبل المجتمع تقبل احكام الشريعه تقريبا
زي ما بقول الطبيعه ثانيه له
[موسيقى]
المساواه ما كانت مهمه الهم بالمعنى اللي
احنا احنا احنا
بنفتسره لانه المساواه معناته ايش انه
خلينا نقول من ناحيه الزلمه ومراه انه
الزلمه بتعمل بيعمل زي المراه نفس الحقوق
الى اخره ولكن شو شو معناته هذا معناه شو
معناه انه انه كمان المراه بتقدر تشتغل
ومعناته انه كمان رحيم لما بتقدر تشتغل
الاولاد راح يكونوا في البيت
وراح يكون في حدا ثاني غير الامه يربي
الاولاد
شو المشاكل اللي راح تخلق من الاولاد وشو
وين الابو موجود هل هو حاضر في
حياه الولد ولا لا لانه هو عنده مستواك
كمان ما هو مرته اذا بتشتغلوا وبتروح
محلات عديده وهو كمان يحق له طب وين
الاولاد كمان مره وين العيله الى اخره الى
اخره الى اخره
هذه ليش انا بجيب هذا بالذات الوضع هذا
لانه ليش المره لازم يكون عندها حق انها
تشتغل لانه احنا مجتمع راس مالي يقيس كل
شيء بالفلوس والمصاري
فتصبح مساواه الرجل للمراه هي المراه
للرجل هي انه اذا المراه لكي تساوي الرجل
يجب ان تفعل بالضبط شو كان شو الرجل يساوي
او يعمل فاذا كانه اذا زلمه بيعمل مثلا
بالمعدل 100 الف دولار لازم المرض تكون
عشان مساوي له تعمل مئه الف دولار او على
الاقل او اكثر
فاصبحت المساواه مساواه مادي ولكن هل
الرجل المراه نفس الشيء
المراه بتخلف اولاد الزلمه بخلفش اولاد طب
مين اللي لما بتخلف في اولادي يا عمي في
مسؤوليه عليها وعليه
وعليها شوي اكثر
لا لا مش لانه هي مفروض انه تسويه من
ناحيه لانه الطبيعه تتطلب منها الزلمه ما
بيقدر يرضع اولاده
يعني انا كنت بحب اسويها هاي الشغله لودرت
بس ما بقدر يا عمي
الام الوحيده اللي بالدنيا بتقدر ترضع
يعني في قوانين طبيعيه لا يمكن ان
نتجاهلها وتدخل في مشكله
المساواه هنا انا برايي انه المراه
الغربيه والمراه بشكل عام الحدث كلما
تتحرر كلما تستعبد اكثر
خد مثلا مثال بسيط
تتحرر المراه
وتذهب الى السوق لتعمل وتجلب فلوس كزوجها
واحيانا اكثر واحيانا اكثر
ترجع الى البيت هي التي تطبخ لانه زوجها
قاعد بيحضر تلفزيون لعبه ماتش
سوكر او او فوتبول وربما يشرب له شيء وهي
قاعده اشتغلت طول النهار وبتيجي بدها
والاولاد بعتمدوا عليه ماما ماما مش اقل
بقول
حالات معينه موجوده ولكن بالمعدل هي التي
تطبخيه
قليل من الرجال اليوم اللي بوازنوا بوساوه
ونسوانهم في الاشغال الداخليه فمين اللي
بيطلع دافع السعر الكبير المره
انا لا اقول لا يجب ان تشتغل ولكن في عندك
اعتبارات كثيره اخرى في قضيه المساواه
المسلمين اعرفوا ايش كل واحد عنده دوره
وكل واحد بيلعب بهالدور زي ما قال
الموارده له كل
الاجتماع الاجتماع هو تعاون
وكل واحد له اهميه تكون انك انت ام بيت
اللي بقول انه هذا الوظيفه اقل احترام من
واحد بروح بجيب نص مليون ومليون دولار على
البيت واحد يا انه اعمى لا يرى الحقائق او
انه غبي او شيء من هالنوع انا برايي
الامومه
بشرط انه طبعا انا بالنسبه للمراه لازم
تتعلم دائما وزي الرجل وكل شيء ولكن لما
تقع في في موقع الامومي في فتره في حياتها
انا باين انه لازم تكون تقدر اكثر من ما
يقدر الرجل حتى لما يجيب مليون دولار
لبيته
ولكن هذا مش موجود ليش لانه الام عندما
تخلف ليست مثمره للراسماليه فالراسماليه
لا يكافئها
فمثلا قليل من الشركات التي حقوق جيده
ان تتحسن الامور تدريجيا الان لابد اكيد
يعني لا انكر ذلك ولكن
لفترات
مئه سنه واكثر استعبدت النساء لانهم كانوا
بدهن اياهم يشتغلوا ويخلفوا كمان من غير
اي اي لا المراه يجب ان تكون في البيت
ويجب ان يدفع لها مرتب عالي جدا بسبب انها
امراه ام
ولكن هل هل هذا من الراسماليه
قانون راسماليه هو المال ليس هناك اهتمام
كل شيء اخر
يحترم هو يحترم في نهايه المطاف ليه عشانه
بالاخر بيجيب فلوس اكتر فاذا الشرك بتعطي
التبرعات لما تحف او لا مؤسسه خيريه كله
بينزل من الضرائب وبحطوا اسمهم بعطي فلوس
كثير بس ليه عشان عشان الاقتناع الاخلاقي
والروحي واللاهوتي نو لانه
بعطيه بعطيه اسم كبير والناس بتصير تالهو
وتحبه اكثر وهذا معناته بجيب فلوس
كله فلوس كله فلوس
فالمسواه هي مساله ماديات في الاساس وليس
فيها احترام جوهري
بالضروره لا للرجل ولا للمراه الانسان
الحداسي هو انسان مهان
غير انه فارغ من الداخل
طيب الدوله الدوله المستحيله هي دوله
الحداثيه في اطروحتك الدوله المستحيله
ملخصه انك تقول انه اي تعريفي دوله
اسلاميه حديثه
متناقض
ذاتيا بصوره جوهريه ومنطقيا
يعني انا الان
يعني كل الدول هي دوله الدول حديثه تعيش
في دوله حديثه اصلي سوم زكي
امارس كل ممارساتي الاسلاميه
وين التناقض يعني معلش
الدوله الحديثه
نشات على اساس فصل الاخلاق من اي شيء اخر
يعني ممكن اؤكف الان فقط واقول لك حل لهذه
الجمله تحليل صحيح وكبير وعميق وستجد
الاجوبه هناك تماما لن ندخل في متاهات
طويله عريضه فقط من هذا
الدوله الحديثه ليس اهتمامها في انشاء
انشاء
ذات اخلاقيه وذات الاخلاقيه هي عمده
المجتمع المسؤول
لا تستطيع ان تنتج مجتمع مسؤول من غير ذات
اخلاقيه
خليني اعطيك مثال صغير ولكن مهم
الان نحن نعرف
ناخذها من الاخر زي ما بنقول في فلسطين
بتقولوها
ناخذها من الاخر
احنا نعرف الان انه تقريبا الاسره انحلت
تفكفكت في الغرب ولاح عم تلحقنا عم تلحقنا
في جميع البلدان بالسعوديه فلسطين
اليوم لانه بقعوا بالنسبه لهم
مشاكل كبيره
النسوان تقريبا ما بدهاش
التنين ما بدهنش اولاد تقريبا عم تنحل
المؤسسه الزواج عم تنحل تماما قبل الواحد
بقول ليش
مفروض نسال سؤال ليش
اذا بنبدا من 1840 هاي بناخذها من اولها
من 1804
الاستاذ الشريف
عمل قانون
الكود
القانون النابليوني المقنن
وهذا غير العالم
لانه كان اول قانون
مقنن على هذه الطريقه
يستجلب كل الصلاحيات وقوه الدوله
وبدي فيه في قسم من هذا القانون قوانين
كثيره
بالنسبه للعائله
فاصبح اصبحت الدوله تشرع قوانين لكي
لكي تصمم العائله من جديد
نقول انه في تشريع طبعا على المستوى الاول
والثاذج تقريبا ساذج هو انه التشريع قادر
قانون اجى من الدوله وبشري على الجميع
وخلاص في نظام هذا مفهوم صحيح ولكن ساذج
التفسير الغير ساذج هو انه تسال السؤال طب
ايش هذا القانون راح يساوي في المجتمع
اذا تمشي من 1804 لليوم
قوانين الدول جميعا هي قوانين لافساد
الاسره
ولكن تاثيراتها
وعواقبها كانت افساد الاسره فانحلال
الاسره اليوم هو مربوط ربط تام بالقوانين
وبالنظام الراسمالي ما في شيء ثاني بقدر
يفسرهم
الراسماليه
والقوانين الدوله شوف كيف
تشتغل مع الدوله مع بعض
فالاسره
الاسره تفككت لانها عباره عن قسم صغير من
الصوره الكبيره التي بها الدوله
تحلل المجتمع وتكسره الى اقسام وتفرقه الى
اقسام
فهدف الدوله دائما انه تقضي على المجموعات
الكبيره التي لها نظامها الداخلي واخلاقها
الداخلي مثلا هنعطيك مثال بسيط اذا بتطلع
على دول الشرق الاوسط في الغير السعوديه
ولكن تطلع مثلا مصر واسرائيل
طبعا اسرائيل عندها مخطط استعمالي ولكن
عندها اشي يشترك مع مصر
انه التنين بدهن
يقعدوا البدو تبع
السكان البدو تبعنا في منطقه
مركزه وحدي ويخلوهم مش يضلوا يدوروا في
الخيامهم ولكن ياخذوا محل ويبنوا بيوت فيه
ويوطنوهم مع مدارسهم والى اخره ليش لانه
البدو لهم كما نعرفه القبائل عندها اخلاص
[موسيقى]
واحترام فقط لقوانينها هي هي لا تعترف
بدها تضلها تدور وعندهن عرفهم وعاداتهم
العبد واحرار بدو احرار اكبر احرار في على
وجه الارض في اخر القرن في القرن الاخير
هم البدو في العالم لانه عايشين حياتهم
كيف بدهم ولكن هم يواجهوا معارضه الدوله
وين مكان
الدوله بدها توطنهم ليش لانها بدها تفككهم
بتعلمهم في المدارس تبعتها
وبتفككوا بتقرر القوانين الزواج تبعتهم
بتفككه وبيصبحوا افراد منفردين تستطيع
السيطره عليهم هي والجهاز الراسماني
هذا هدف الدوله
انا انا بدي ارجع للي حكيته انت سالتني
كيف انه الدوله الدوله الحديثه مش ممكن
تكون اسلاميه انت عم بتفكر انه اه مجرد
انا بقدر اصلي اصوم معناته انا مسلم وعايش
في دوله حديثه لا بس الدوله الحديثه عم
بتفكفك المجتمع تحت اقدامك
فانت انت ولادك ربما على الارجح مش انت
يعني الجيل الاول راح يصبح يواجه نفس
المشاكل انه ما في عيله ما في اعمام ولا
خالات ولا حب من العائله الكبيره في
العالم وتعيسين في العالم والى اخره هدف
مصير الجميع
هذا مصيبه اثبتوا ملايين وملايين من
الاشخاص قبلي وقبلك
هل تفكك الاسره
وخساره جميع اقاربك ويصبحوا غرباء عليه
قسم من الاسلام الاسلام
يعتمد على الجماعه بالاساس ليس هناك اسلام
من غير جماعه
لانه ليس هناك خير من غير جماع اليس هناك
اعمال خيرات وتعاون وموده وحب وصداقه في
الاسلام من غير جماعه
فالدوله تفكك الجماعات
ربما في في منطقتنا الحركه شوي ابطا ولكن
في اخر المطاف هيك راح يصير هل بفعل
الدوله ولا بفعل العولمه
لا ما هو العولمه داخلي في العولمه هي
العولمه هي جهه من جهات العالم هي جهه من
جهات الحداثه وجهها من جهات الدوله والراس
النظام الراسمالي يعني انت بدك تطلع على
الحداثه كانه كره قدم من هدول اللي احنا
بنحبهن بالشرق الاوسط فيها
مسدسات او مسمنات
مخيطات مع بعض بعمل كل وحده منهم تدخل
بشكل
في داخله والها محتواها تخيلها هيك وهذه
الحدث في عندك انت ان العولمه في عندك
العلم العلم الحديث له قصه خاصه ما دخلنا
فيه اليوم تمام بالمره العلم
وقداسته والى اخره في عندك الشركات
والاقتصاد والبنوك
الراسماليه وعندك الدوله والجهاز فكل واحد
بدخل يكون هذه الظاهره
فالعولمه ليست شيء مختلف العولمه هي فقط
جهه من جهات او قسم ديناميكي من الاقسام
التي نتكلم عنها عندما اتكلم عن الدوله
وعن الراسماليه انا اتكلم عن العولمه بنفس
الوقت ولكن انا مش عم بذكرها او قال لك
انا عندي طبخه ملوخيه بتجنن بالاخر مش عم
بحكي انا عن اللحمه اللي حطيتها بالملوخيه
بس انت عارف انه فيها اذا تعرف كيف
الملوخيه بتنعمل فيها لحمه صحيح اذا لما
بقول انا كلمه
بقول المنطقيين بالتضمن يعني لما اقول انا
انه اقول انا انه هذه ام انا قلت ايش انه
اذا هذه ام
معناته انه في الجمله في اولاد من غير ما
اذكر الاولاد بطبيعه الحال
لما نتكلم عن الحداثه هذه الصعوبه في
التعليم انه انه بحكي الواحد بحكي عن
الدوله بالاخر بيجي طالب
كذا اه طيب شو بدنا نساوي بدك تروح من باب
تاني من لكل اشي كل ظاهره بدها تفسير هي
مدينه لها سبعه ابواب على الاقل وقت
تدخلها من باب واحد تعرف قسم من المدينه
فالشرح الكامل هو انك انت تدخل السبع
ابواب على على المدار فدائما انا اقول انه
العلم هو هو جبل ونحن العلماء ولكي تفهم
ما
ما هو الجبل يجب ان تدور حوله كله لانه
الجبل من جهه ممكن يبين لك انه عالي ولكن
ضيق اذا بتدور من الجهه الثانيه بتكون ما
شاء الله هذا طوله 50 ميل الجبل فيصبح شيء
اخر تمام فبدك تدور حواليك انك تفهم انت
شو الجبل
فهذا هذه الشرح الحداثه لا يتم الا بان
تدور حواليها وتشرح كل اقسامها
يعني وخذني على
قدر فهمي
يعني الان يعني صحيح انه لو بدانا نعطي
امثله بيبدا الحرج في لكن في برضو في
العالم العربي في دول كثيره اسلاميه وحتى
غير العربي مثلا لما تاخذ ايران هي
جمهوريه اسلاميا
ففي تجاربة واذا قلنا انه الدوله الحديثه
هي
منتج اوروبي
[موسيقى]
لا يستطيع ان
يتسلق على الشجر هذا الشغل القرد القرد
يفعل ذلك والنمر
المنشار تقص الخشبه انت لا تستطيع ان
تستعمل المنشار لان تصيغ خاتم من الماظ
صحيح
كل جهاز له وظيفه وله طريقه في العمل
ولو هدف وله جينيولوجي له خلفيه له
الدوله
ليست مصنوعه باي شكل من الاشكال
لتنميه وتربيه وانشاء ودعم القيم
الاخلاقيه لانه اذا فعل ذلك
لن تكون دوله بعد ذلك
الدوله بحد ذاتها كما قال نيتشي بحد ذاتها
هو
هي هي ظاهره غير اخلاقيه نشات على
انقاذ
موت الاخلاق
يعني زي ما تقول هل هل حيوان ماتوا انت
سماد الارض وقصر الارض عشان تظهر فيه شجره
اللي ما الها علاقه بالحيوان
على على
ركام هذا الحيوان
فالدوله الحديثه
لن ممكن انها تنطيق زاويه صغيره ما هذا ما
هذا ما يقسم من تعريف العلمانيه العلمانيه
هي ايه انك انت انت بدك تصلي وتصوم نعطيك
زاويه بالغرفه روح صلي وصوم بس لما تطلع
من الزاويه هاي ما بتقدرش تحكي اشي عن
الدين
ليه لانه بتقدرش تبشر انت اي قيم اللي
تعارض القيم الدوله
وعندما تصبح قيمتك شوي الها شعبيه واهميه
ستصبح خطرا على الدولي
في الغرفه راح يتقلص راح ياخدوا لك اياه
اعطني مثال على امريكا
يعني امريكا تزعم انها دوله حريات وانها
تعطي الاديان حرياتها في التعبير عن
مشاعرهم ولكن ليس ليس
لكل هذه المجالات الدينيه
تاثير في
الاوس او او حقوق في صياغه
الكيان السياسي الجمهوري قبلك يعني في في
فرق مش فرق ولكن في عزل بين
الدين ينتمي الى الا هو الشخصي
الزاويه صغيره اللي ما حدا بشوفك فيها انت
بتروح في بيتك بتساوي شو بدك ولكن لا
نستطيع ان نفرض الاخلاق الدينيه تبعت
الدوله حتى للاكثريه على على السياسه
العامه والاخره لانه هذا يعادي سياسه
الدوله هي نشات لكي تعزل الدين عن عن
والاخلاق عن كل شيء اخر ما هذا سببها هي
الاساس نشات لانها تحل مشكله عويصه
لاوروبا اللي هي الحروب الدينيه
الدوله كانت حل للحروب الدينيه
فاليوم بتقدرش انت تتوقع من انه الدوله
انها تتبنى اي دوله تاخذ
المعدل الوسط لما هو الجمهور الذي عنده
القدره على تغيير نظام السياسي وتشتغل
حسبه لانه اذا لا راح تتدهور هي
ولكن لا تستطيع دوله انهايه تمارس
الاخلاق لانه راح تخلق نوع من السياسه
اللي الاخلاق تصبح في اوروبا تصبح مصدر
للمشاكل
فالكنيسه المشكله هي اساسها هي مش اوروبا
الحديثه هي مشكله اساسها برايي انا هي
المسيحيه الاوروبيه هي اصل الكوارث
هي اللي خلقت الحداثه لانه الحداثه كانت
محاوله لانقاذ اوروبا من من الحياه
البائسه التي عاشتها والظلم
الشنيع الذي عاشته في القرون وقرون
هل ممكن نقول انه هذه قدره الانسان في
تطور صناعه كوكب او حياه افضل في انه قدر
انه يخلق كيانات جديده ليس بالضروره لها
دين
ولكنها قادره على انها تجمع ناس باختلاف
اديانهم باختلاف
مشاربهم في انه يقدرون يعيشوا مع بعض
فخلقت كيان مثلا كيان مثل الدوله
وكذلك مثلا عندك الشركات وبرضو مسؤوليه
محدوده
وهذه ساهمت في انه نصل الى لما وصلنا اليه
اليوم صحيح انه اتفقنا ناقشنا اذا كان
سلبي ولا ايجابي بس متفقين على المكان
اللي هم اللي هو وصلنا لليوم من هذا
التطور التقني والمعرفي لا طلع كل كل
مجتمع اول على اخر راح يقدر يجمع كل فئاته
طب خذ الحكم الاسلامي يا عمي
المسلمين كان عندهم زي ما قلت لك قبل شوي
صغيره انه المسلمين كانوا حاكمين كليات
اكبر منهم عددا طب كيف جمعوهم كلهم والكل
عاش بشكل بشكل بافضل من من اقليات اليوم
اليوم الاقليات مضطهده يعني اطلع على
المسلمين باوروبا المسلمين باوروبا يعانون
معاناه شديده في المانيا في فرنسا بالذات
في المانيا يعني يعني لا حتى لا يستطيعوا
انه ينشئوا
مساجدهم اغلب المسلمين في اوروبا بيصلوا
في في شقق
وبحكوا على المسلمين على التاريخ الاسلامي
انه كان في تحديد نوعا ما لبناء الكنايس
يعني يعني يعني
منافقه شميعه جدا
الاقليات اليوم مش كثير مش كلها يعني هي
ظاهره غريبه جدا بس هي مش مش في نفس الوقت
مش يعني مش وحيده وفريده من نوعها انه انه
في عندك مرات الاقليات مثلا في اندونيسيا
هالثلاثه بالميه الصينيين وهن عاده
المسيحيين بالمناسبه هم يملكون
موارد الطبيعيه للبلد صحيح ولكن اقليات في
الغرب مثلا هون اذا كانت حتى اقليات سوداء
او اقليات اسبانيه او اقليات يابانيه او
صينيه او كوريه مثلا
نستطيع في خلال الكورونا تتذكر كم من
الاسيويين تعرضوا للعنف في امريكا في
اليابان نفسهم اليابانيين كما ذكرت لك في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه انظر ما حدث لهم
يعني في ابرياء تماما ما لهم علاقه واثبت
بعدين انه ولا مره كان عندهم علاقه مع
الحكومه اليابان في في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ولكن دفعوا ثمن باهظ
الاقليات في الغرب مش طلع المسلمين هون في
امريكا اليوم في نيويورك هنا العرب
والمسلمين مضطهدين
وحاطين عليهم سلوك تجسس والى اخره
لا اتقبل انا انه الاقليات اليوم مبسوطه
انا برايي انه
حتى لو في الوضع المثالي وكانت مبسوطه
السؤال الاخير الاول والاخير بالنسبه الي
هو يرجع الى تقريبا كل موضوع بحثناه اليوم
هو ما سعر هذا المشروع
هل سعره ان احنا ندمر الارض
انا كل شيء بدمر القارب او السفينه اللي
انا عم بسافر عليها في البحر مش راح
اتقبله لانه بالاخر فيه فيه ثنائي
فاحنا اللي عم نسويه انه نبني بنبني راسها
مبسوطين عنا كتير مصاري وبناكل شو بدنا
وبنشتغل شو بدنا والاخره الحمد لله طيب يا
عمي شو سعر هذا كلياته اهم شيء نسال
السؤال شو سعره وليش عم بنسويه ليش حاجتنا
انه نساوي اسم الشكل ليش بحاجه انا اني
اكل ثلاثه كيلو لحم كل يوم
هذه الاسئله ما حدا بسالها
ان شاء الله الناس
بتبدا تفكر شوي اكثر في الشيء اللي بتسويه
ومين كل واحد هو من انت من الداخل هذا
السؤال لازم يسالوها من انا من الداخل
عينه نوع انسان انا هل انا انسان
استحق وجود وجودي في في مجموعه الاشخاص
اللي حواليه هل انا استحق حبهم واحترامهم
ماذا استطيع ان افعل
لاسد هذا الدين
ماذا استطيع ان افعل لايكون مسؤول لاتجاه
الاخرين واتجاه
الحياه في بشكل عام
الكوكب بجميعه فهذا كله بيبدا من الداخل
ببدا كلياته من الداخل ما في شيء من
الخارج من هاي النحل الاخلاق تبدا من
الداخل
تقول انه اذا انتو اذا كنتم تريدون ان
تقيموا حكما اسلاميا
صحيحا ينسجم مع تاريخ الحكم الاسلامي فيجب
ان نعطي نظام السياسي طابع اخلاقي
هل افهم من هذا الكلام انه انه في طريقه
الى جعل الدوله الحديثه
باليه لحكم اسلام
يا انه احنا راح نقضي على حالنا وخلاص
نخلص وربما هذا ما نستحق
او انه نفيق على حالنا ونبدا نغير الامور
اذا كانه احنا رحنا الطريق الثاني
فلابد للحداثه ان تندرس
ضروري انها تندرس لانها مشروع مدمر
يجب ان نخلق من الحداثه اذا كنا شاطرين
يعني واذكياء وحكماء اهم من كل هذا لانه
الحداثه كثير شاطره وكتير ذكيه ولكن ليست
حكيمه هناك فرق شاسع بين الذكي والحكيم
الذكي ممكن يكون مخرب
ومدمر
ومريض عقليا حتى يعني كتير بتصير ولكن
الحكيم لا يستطيع ان يفعل افعال سيئه حتى
لو اخطات يصلح حاله ويكمل
وبرجع على الطريق المستقيم هذا الحكيم اذا
كنا حكماء نستطيع انه نطلع من هذا الموضوع
وهذا المازق لا ينحل الا عن طريق التربيه
يجب ان نربي اولاد وبنات صغار من من السن
الصغير من يوم الكل بفتحوا عينيهم على
العالم انه انه انه في قيم لازم
يتقيدوا فيها
ولكن نحن بحاجه الى نظام يستطيع ان ان
يؤهل شروط الضروريه يعطينا شروط الضروريه
انها ننشئ هذه الاشياء
فهذا كيف بتصير ما تسالني لانه انا بصراحه
اقول لك انا تعبت مرات من هاي الشغلات اه
الوضع
كثير صعب
يعني انا مش ياسان ولكن تعبان لانه لانه
لانه لانه
حتى لما الناس بتفهم ما بتفهم بتفعل شي مش
مستعدين يتنازلوا عن اي شيء حتى لو عرف
الواحد لابدلوك انا عارف انه احنا زي ما
تقول خليني مدمن على المخدرات وبموت وانا
مدمن مش واعي على حالي هذا التصرف تبعنا
اليوم
هل انه ما في حل ما في بديل
لابد في بديل طلع خليني اقول لك شيء
اوروبا كانت في وورد ورطه عويصه كبيره في
جهنم في حتى القرن الرابع عشر
طب دخلت في الحدث كيف دخلت في الحدث هيك
بدون مجهود اشتغلوا كتير واستنوا كتير
استنوا في الحدث المحاوله اللي هي كانت
انا بدون شك انا بقول لك يعني بصراحه انا
بفكر انه محاوله كانت عن
نيه حسنه هن بدهم كانوا يحلوا مشاكلهم كل
واحد لاجل البقاء
بحاول انه يحسن حاله وحاولوا وبعطيهم انا
هذا الحق تبعهم
فشلوا فشل ذريع ويجب ان نعترف به ولكن هن
حاولوا في البدايه ولكن تصور قديش اخذت
منهم عشان يدخلوا في الحداثه من عصر من
عصور كانت عصور كنيسه
قاسيه وعقل مسكر
وعدم فهم
واشياء عنيفه وسيئه جدا دخلوا في عصر
التنوير
وطوروا اشياء
طوروا اكثر من اللازم اصبح العلم تبعهم
صار استعماري ويقتل ولكن في البدايه على
الاقل كان كان عندهم طب كيف دخلوا في هاي
يعني اشتغلوا اشتغلوا قرنين او ثلاثه قبل
ما يبدو يشوفوا نتائج هذه
الاعمال ولكن تغيروا كثير
من نواحي معينه كتير طب كيف ممكن انه
تركوا ما قبل الحداثه ودخلوا في الحداثه
زي ما دخلنا في الحداثه بندخل بنطلع منها
هل نقدر نطلع منها هل المفترض اكيد انه
العرب والمسلمين يشتغلون على مشروع خاص
فيهم ولا هل المفترض انه نشتغل مع الغرب
على مشروع جديد للبشريه الاثنين معا يجب
ان يكون لنا مشروعنا
نشتغل عليه باستقلال
بجراءه وشجاعه لان اليوم المشاكل اللي
احنا نتطلب شجاعه على اعلى حد بدون شجاعه
وجراه لن نستطيع ان نفعل اي شيء يجب ان
يكون لدينا شجاعه وجراه عقليا يعني شجاعه
ثقافيه شجاعه
علميه نبدا بالتفكير على طريقتنا الخاصه
نحضر نستحضر بعض او كل المفاهيم الاسلاميه
المهمه والتي كانت عامل ايجابي في تاريخ
البشري
التجربه الاسلاميه في العالم في العالم
بشكل عام كانت تجربه ايجابيه جدا بنو بنو
حضاره
رائعه مليئه بالاخلاق والعلوم كله من غير
تناقد واشياء جديده اخرى لا نعرفها
وتعارض كل المفاهيم مثل مثلا انظمه الحكم
الاسلامي كانت متفوقه على كثير من
نراه اليوم وانا الان بالمناسبه انا اشتغل
على كتاب طويل ومعقد في هذا الموضوع في
الحكم الاسلامي الذي هو تقريبا شرح
شاسع
للفصل الثالث من الدوله المستحيله
يعني يمكن يوصل 500 600 صفحه ما بعرف وين
وصلت وصلت تقريبا 300 صفحه بس بعدني في
المنتصف يعني
كل هذه الانجازات كانت الانجازات اسلاميه
فيجب ان ان لا نستطيع ان
نستحضر الماضي كله بكل لانه خلص ما فات
مات ولكن اشياء كثيره في الاسلام لم تمت
ممكن ان استرجعها وممكن نبني عليها ممكن
انها تخلينا ندمجها ونخلطها مع اشياء اللي
مناسبه للعصر اللي عايشين فيه من اجل
الخروج من
الحداثه يجب ان نخرج من الحداثه اذا كنا
نريد ان نبقى على قيد الحياه اذا كنا اذا
كنا نستمر في الحداثه ونصر عليها انا
بوعدك وعد شرف زي ما بيقولوا انه كلنا راح
نروح في الداهيه بتشوف
فيها
طلع على التدهور الطبيعي والبيئي
والجسمي والعقلي كله والعائله والجماعي
طيب في في واحد من اللقاءاتك اتذكر انك
قلت انه فيها
حركات هنديه او صينيه او حركات هنديه
في محاوله لاستعاده تاريخهم
في الصين الصين مثلا في عندهم مفهوم
بسموه ما بعرف بالصيني انا ما بعرف الصيني
بالانجليزي
هو ليس وهذا مشروع هائل جدا ومهم
وهناك نموذج ثالث بالمناسبه ثاني وثالث
عندك النموذج الصيني هل هو الدائري عندك
النموذج الغربي الذين يتبناه اليوم جميعا
وهو النموذج الذي
يصبو الى المستقبل
[موسيقى]
وعندك النموذج الاسلامي الذي يسبو الى
الماضي
فهذه ثلاث نماذج في رؤيه الحياه الانسانيه
مهمه جدا جدا لانها تكون الفلسفه التي يجب
الذي يستطيع الانسان ان يعيش على حسبها
فخلينا ناخذ اشياء القريبه علينا في الاول
لانه
النموذج الصيني يصبح قسم من هذه الحلول
ولكن اذا نطلع على الاشياء
الظواهر اللي مناسبه لنا اكثر لانه احنا
من العالم الاسلامي نتكلم عن الاسلام وعن
الغرب لانه هو اللي اثر علينا اكثر شيء
بالحديث اليوم الصين ما الها الواقع راح
تصبح ولكن حتى الان لم لم يحصل
كيف
المسار
التاريخي بالنسبه لهم انه دائره اشياء زي
كانه تولد وتفنى وعلى هذا انه انه المساله
مساله الحياه دائما في حركه دائريه في
الكون يعني اللي بيجيك برجع لك
شايف كيف لما تعرف انت الشيء راح يرجع لك
انت مش راح انت تعمل اشي عاطل لانه راح
يرجع لك هذا واحد من المبادئ هاي فالاسلام
في في الغرب اليوم ولا هو مفهوم مسيحي
اصلا كما قلت لك فما هي من الاساسيه
الكبيره المسيحيه هو
نظريه
التقدم نظريه التقدم هذه من اكبر النظريات
المؤثره في التفكير والتصرف الانسان
الحديث ليس في الغرب فقط
نحن نؤمن انه دائما في نحن في تقدم يعني
خربنا الدنيا وبرضو احنا في تقدم ليش لانه
عنا سياره احسن اسا عنا كمبيوتر بعمل اشي
احسن هذا تقدم
مش مهم انه احنا نازلين في الباس والياس
والحزن والحزن
والانتحار والى اخره هذا كله على جنب بس
احنا في التقدم اصله هو ايش الخلاص
المسيحي انه اول على اخذ نصر للخلاص
معيار الاخلاق في النظريه التقدم هي ما
نستطيع ما سنه حققه في المستقبل معنى لا
نعرف ما يحدث المستقبل
هذه التناقضات ولكن اذا بتطلع على الاسلام
التاريخ هو
اعلى نقطه فيه هو الخلق
والرساله خلق الله اول شيء والرساله محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اعلى شيء وبعده في فساد الزمان كل ما تبعد
عن
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يفسد الزمان اكثر هذا في ناس بقول لك انه
شو هالشغله هاي يا عمي هاي مش مضبوطه هيك
بتيارسونا هو انه لا هذا بالعكس هذا من
اكثر الاشياء الايجابيه ليش لانه لانه لما
احنا بننظر للعصر الرسول ولا الرسول نفسه
صلى الله عليه وسلم كان منظار المنظار
الاعلى يصبح هو الانسان الكامل حس كما
يقول الصوفيه فاذا كان هو الانسان الكامل
احنا ايش الواجب علينا انه نحتدي وراءه
ونقلده نقلده بشكل طبعا بشكل عقلي ومش
نقلده على العمى انقلدوا ونصبح قد ما ممكن
نصبح زيه نصبح زي الانسان يعني تصبح
المساله النظر الى الخلف يصبح تقدم اخلاقي
هذا غير موجود في النظريه التقدم الجديده
لانه نظريه التقدم الجديده هي انه احنا عم
نتقدم اكثر واكثر بس حسب معايير معينه
ولكن ليس الاخلاق واحد منها
اخلاق ليست منها
حتى لما نقول مساواه هاي لا تعني انه
الاخلاق المساواه هي معادله سياسيه
واقتصاديه ولكن ليست معادله اخلاقيه
الصينيين اتوا بتاريخهم زي ما انا عم بدعو
المسلمين انه يسترجعوا تاريخهم من ناحيه
التركيب التاريخيه زي ما سردت لك اياها
الصينيين يعني بحاولوا يعملوا نفس الشيء
انه يشوفوا شو الكونفوشيسيه
والتقاليد الصينيه بتدعو انه يسترجعوها
على اساس يعطوا يعطوا للمنظار الحداثه
للواقع الحداثي نوع من الانسانيه والاخلاق
لانه الحداثه هي
تعارض تام للانسانيه
الحداثه قتلت الانسان
كظاهره نحن لسنا فقط لحم وشحم وعظم
اهم من لحم وشحم وعظم هي الروح
والنفسيه النفس والروح كما يقول الصوفيه
والنفس هي باب الروح هي التي هي المصفاه
التي تقرر ماذا يدخل من من من شر وسوء
وخير وتكرر ان حسب ما انت شو بدك ومن هنا
تدخل ماذا تقنيات النفس تقنيات النفس
تتحكم في مصفاه النفس
فتقرر لا انه النفس هي حسب مفهوم العام هو
النفس هي زي وعاء
انت لما بتملي وعاء مي بتحط نقطه راح تسيل
فهذا الوعاء محدود
اذا بتحط فيه خير رح يطلع الشر
بتحط فيه اكثر خير راح يطلع اكتر شر بتحط
فيه شر راح يطلع الخير
انت بدك تغذي نفسك بطرق عديده منها الصلاه
والصيام والى اخره والى اخره والهنود
عندهم طرقهم الصينيه عندهم طرقهم
والمسلمين عندنا عده طرق هي الشرعيه
وصوفيه والى اخره لانه الطرق الصوفيه
نوعا عن الطرق الشرعيه وتتعداها كلها
عندها عده طرق تقنيات النفس عديده جدا
ولكن المهم ايش هي بالاساس انها تنتج
هالنتيجه الواحده ان هل وعاء هذا وعاء
النفس انه ينتلي يمتلئ في ايش في اشياء
حسنه وعندما تمتلئ فتصبح غلافا للروح التي
هي تفسد فقط بفستان يعني الفطره
كل انسان ولد على الفطره
يعني مسلم ولكن شو اللي بخرب هالامور انه
في حوالي ناس مش مضبوطين
يعني معناته ايه معناته انه النفس سمحت
لنفسها ان تدخل اشياء الا تخربت على خربت
على الفطره مش خربت الفكره خربت على
الفطره
فاذا كان النفس تتحسن
فتتحسن وهذه النفس هي هي كل شيء نحن نملكه
اله قيمه وفيه نمارس هذه التقنيات النفس
الله يعطيك العافيه يزيدك عافيه شكرا اهلا
وسهلا فيك شكرا لكم شكرا
لايمن الحمادي منتج فنجان والشكر كذلك
لعند المذيعه في التلوين والتحليل محمد
نور شمت وخلف الكاميرات ادم الشهراني
والانتاج اصيل فرض وفي اداره محتوى
التواصل الاجتماعي نوره السبيعي والهندسه
الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي اداره التحرير
فنجان اسيل بعبد الله هذا فنجان احد
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع ننشر
كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع
المقبل
[موسيقى]
دخلت انا المت
عفوا المتحف المتعه
يعني مسروقه وكذا كيف يبررونها الغرب
وهيطلع في بريطانيا يعني كلها يعني واضح
اصلا هي تنسب للمسلمين ولا تنسى النظره
[موسيقى]
غربيه للاستعماريه انه انه
الحقيقه الحقيقه تتكون من مشاهد ومشاهد
المشاهد هو الاوروبي الذي ينظر الى
المشاهد والمشاهد هو المتحف
فنحن متحف بالنسبه للاوروبيين حتى لما
مثلا خلينا نقول في
الحفلات الاستقراطيه في انجلترا في القرن
التاسع عشر لما كانوا مستعمرين الهند
كانوا يجيبوا خدام من افريقيا
ولونهم بني واسود ومن
اسيا صينيه ومش عارف ايش ويخليهم يخدموا
يقدموا العشاء والاكل
على الطاوله
ليه عشان يطلع عليهم كانه المتحف دائر
يعني كانهم قرود ودببه
ونمور وزرافات تاتي
لكي ننظر اليها
الاستعمار الاستعمار
ليس فقط يحتل الارض ولكن يخلق من
المواطن الاصلي
موضوع المتاحف تبعته
فنحن
الاسيويين والافريقيين نحن متاحف الغرب
والمتاحف يعني
مشروع حداثي طبعا طبعا طبعا
الحداثه هذه طيب